>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED
BY JIM BEAM.
GREAT AMERICAN BALL PARK, LOOKS
LIKE A BEAUTIFUL DAY IN
CINCINNATI.
>> IN MY OPINION, HE COULD STICK
SEVEN BASEBALLS IN HIS RIGHT
HAND.
>> JOHNNY BENCH, THE REDS GET
READY TO HOST THE GREATEST TEAM
IN BASEBALL, THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS WHO HAVE WON FOUR IN A
ROW.
CINCINNATI WILL TRY AND SNAP A
THREE-GAME SKID.
ALONGSIDE DAN PLESAC, I AM
STEPHEN NELSON.
WE ARE GETTING YOU SET.
>> SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS RIGHT
NOW ARE THE BIGGEST STORY RIGHT
NOW IN BASEBALL.
THEIR STARTING PITCHING RIGHT
NOW, TODAY, IS THE BEST IN THE
SPORT.
NOT A LOT OF HOUSEHOLD NAMES BUT
ACTIVITY.
>> THAT IS NOT AN OPINION.
THAT IS A FACT.
THE BEST ROTATION IN BASEBALL.
JOHNNY CUETO, IT ALL BEGAN FOR
HIM THERE.
STEVE: HE IS A FUN GUY TO WATCH.
HE HAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DELIVERIES.
GO THROUGH HIM OVER THE YEARS.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
CONVENTIONAL MECHANICS, YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR THE WRONG GUY.
THIS IS WHERE IT ALL STARTED.
THE KANSAS CITY ROYALS
TREMENDOUS DOWN THE STRETCH.
HE WILL STOP TWICE, STOP THREE
TIMES.
HIS WHOLE DEAL IS ABOUT
DISRUPTING TIMING.
IT IS ABOUT DECEPTION AND
ANGLES.
THE ONLY THING HE NEEDS TO CLEAN
UP, THE SLIDER HAS NOT BEEN A
GOOD PITCH FOR HIM THIS YEAR.
IT HAS GOTTEN THEM INTO TROUBLE.
IT HAS GOTTEN BALLS HIT OUT OF
THE BALLPARK.
A PITCH THAT USED TO BE A REALLY
GOOD PITCH FOR JOHNNY CUETO IS
NOT RIGHT NOW BUT THAT IS NOT
SAYING IT CAN'T BE.
IT IS A PITCH HE NEEDS TO TRY TO
WORK AROUND A LITTLE MORE.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF DAMAGE
ON HIS SLIDER.
ONE GOOD LOOK TODAY COULD GET
HIM IN A GOOD GROOVE.
DAN: HIS E.R.A. STILL LOOKS
GOOD.
HE IS ONE OF FOUR GIANTS
PITCHERS WHO ARE FORMER
REDS.
SPEAKING OF FOUR PITCHERS IN
CINCINNATI, LAST YEAR THERE WAS
THAT BIG 4.
THEY WERE LOOKED AT AS FOUR
BECAUSE OF TYLER MAHLE.
STEPHEN: HE HAS BEEN LOOKING
REALLY GOOD.
HE IS FINALLY PUTTING IT
TOGETHER.
HE HAS CLEANED UP HIS MECHANICS.
HE HAS PUT THE SPLITFINGER MORE
AND PLAY RIGHT NOW.
TYPICALLY, IT GETS LEFTIES.
HE IS A TALL GUY WITH LONG
LEVERS.
THIS SPLITFINGER AGAINST LEFTIES
REALLY PLAYS.
IT IS A HARD SPLITFINGER, UP TO
91 MPH.
GOOD FASTBALL, LOW TO MID 90'S.
YOU WILL SEE THE SPLITTER
PRIMARILY AGAINST LEFTIES.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO USE IT.
HE HAS COMMANDED IT SO MUCH MORE
THIS YEAR.
DAN: DAVID BELL IN PREGAME
MANAGERIAL MEETINGS MADE IT A
POINT TO HIGHLIGHT TYLER MAHLE.
STEPHEN: MOST OF THE SPORT,
PARTICULARLY OUT OF THE BUMP IS
ALL CONFIDENCE.
TYLER MAHLE IS ONE OF THOSE
GUYS.
I CALL IT STEPPING IN A BUCKET
OF SASSY.
DAN: AND HE IS COMING OFF A
VICTORY AT COORS FIELD.
WILL THAT HAPPEN?
OPINIONS.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN TODAY'S
GAME?
THE GIANTS OR REDS?
JOHNNY CUETO VERSUS TYLER MAHLE.
LET US KNOW.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE RESULTS AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST WHEN WE
COME BACK.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK WE GAME SHOW --
PREGAME SHOW.
WE ARE BACK WITH A SPECIAL
GUEST.
SEAN DOOLITTLE OF CINCINNATI.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
WE ARE ON YOUR HOME MOUND.
STEPHEN: A GUY FROM MEDFORD, NEW
JERSEY.
HOW DID YOU END UP AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA?
SEAN: SHOOT MAN.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET
RECRUITED BY SCHOOLS DOWN THERE
IN THE ACC.
WHAT VIRGINIA HAD TO OFFER,
ACADEMICALLY, AS WELL AS WITH
THEIR BASEBALL PROGRAM, COMBINED
WITH THE FACT THEY WERE ONE OF A
FEW SCHOOLS THAT WOULD LET ME
HIT AND PITCH IN COLLEGE WHICH
IS SOMETHING I REALLY WANTED TO
DO, DO THE TWO WAY PLAYER THING.
IT ALL CAME TOGETHER.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR MY TIME
THERE.
DAN: NOT ONLY DID HE PLAY THERE,
HE SET RECORDS.
YOU ARE AS AWARE AS ANYBODY WHAT
IS GOING ON AROUND THE SHOW.
SHOHEI OHTANI.
I WOULD LOVE TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS AND IMPRESSIONS OF HIM
DOING WHAT HE IS DOING AT THIS
LEVEL.
SEAN: ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN DESCRIBE
HOW AWESOME IT IS WHAT HE IS
DOING.
SO MUCH FUN TO WATCH.
HE IS A GUY THAT YOU COME IN
AFTER THE GAME AND LIKE MAYBE
AFTER YOU ARE DONE EATING DINNER
AND DECOMPRESSING, YOU CHECK
YOUR PHONE TO SEE WHAT HE DID
THAT DAY.
HE IS DOING SOMETHING SPECIAL
EVERY NIGHT.
FOR US, WE ARE STILL ON EAST
COAST TIME, MAN, HE IS OUT THERE
ON THE WEST COAST, A LOT OF
NIGHTS YOU COULD CHECK IN ON THE
GAME AND MAYBE WATCH IT AS IT IS
HAPPENING.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE.
EVERY NIGHT, HE IS DOING
SOMETHING INCREDIBLY SPECIAL.
IT IS AWESOME.
IT IS ONE OF THE COOLEST STORIES
IN BASEBALL RIGHT NOW.
STEPHEN: 2019, YOU WERE ON THAT
MAGICAL RIDE WITH THE NATIONALS.
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT POSTSEASON
THAT STICKS OUT TO YOU THAT YOU
STILL THINK ABOUT?
THAT WAS THE COOLEST THING?
SEAN: THERE IS A LOT.
A LOT OF STUFF LIKE THAT.
THE THING I COME BACK TO THE
MOST IS THE GUYS ON THE TEAM,
THAT WE HAVE IN THE CLUBHOUSE,
THE CHEMISTRY AND THE MAKEUP OF
THE TEAM.
THIS IS MY 10TH YEAR IN THE
LEAGUE.
I HAVE BEEN AROUND A LITTLE.
IT IS SO RARE TO HAVE A GROUP
LIKE THAT.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT WAS A
GROUP OF OLDER GUYS.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT VERY MUCH,
NOT ANYMORE.
THE GUYS HERE, THEY KEEP ME
YOUNG.
AWESOME GROUP.
ABSOLUTELY LOVING IT.
THEY ARE KEEPING ME YOUNG,
HELPING ME TURN BACK THE CLOCK.
DAN: YOU GAVE THE INCORRECT
ANSWER.
THE COOLEST THING ABOUT '19 WAS
YOUR LIGHTSABER.
WE TALKED AFTER YOU WON AGAINST
THE DODGERS.
WE WERE A COUPLE WEEKS REMOVED
FROM STAR WARS.
MAY THE FOURTH.
HOW DID YOU CELEBRATE IN 2021?
SEAN: I GOT TJ TO START WATCHING
THE STAR WARS MOVIES.
HE HAS BEEN WORKING HIS WAY
THROUGH THE ENTIRE SAGA.
EVERY DAY HE COMES DOWN TO THE
BULLPEN AND HE HAS NEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PLOT AND
CHARACTERS.
IT HAS BEEN FUN TO SIT WITH HIM
AND WATCH SOMEONE DISCOVER IT
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
STEPHEN: GETTING FANS BACK IN
THE STANDS, IS IT MAKING THE
PLAYERS FEEL CLOSER TO THE GAME
THEN IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO HAVING
MORE FANS THERE THIS YEAR?
SEAN: ABSOLUTELY.
THE ENERGY, THE ENVIRONMENT THE
FANS CREATE DURING A GAME HAS
BEEN AWESOME TO HAVE THEM BACK.
TO PLAY IN FRONT OF OUR FANS
AGAIN.
LAST YEAR WAS TOUGH, WITHOUT
THAT ENERGY IN THE BALLPARK,
JUST LOOKING AROUND AND SEEING
ALL THE EMPTY SEATS.
I THINK WE DID A GOOD JOB OF
EASING IT TOGETHER AS BEST WE
COULD.
THIS YEAR, HAVING FANS BACK,
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE NOT AT FULL
CAPACITY -- IT HAS BEEN REALLY
SPECIAL.
THE FANS IN CINCINNATI, THEY
BRING THE ENERGY, THEY GET LOUD,
THEY CREATE A COOL HOME FIELD
ENVIRONMENT FOR US.
DAN: YOU HAVE BEEN AMONG THE
MORE VOCAL, IN THE BIG LEAGUES,
SINCE YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE SHOW,
TO BE FRONT, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
PANDEMIC, ENCOURAGING FOLKS TO
GET VACCINATED, DO WHATEVER THEY
CAN, WEAR MASKS, SOCIAL
DISTANCING, REMINDING FOLKS WE
ARE NOT OUT OF IT YET EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE GETTING CLOSER.
SEAN: YEAH.
A REMINDER OF THAT IS WE HAVE
SEEN SOME COVID POSITIVES, EVEN
ON TEAMS AROUND THE LEAGUE WHERE
85% OF THE GUYS ARE VACCINATED.
WE STILL HAVE THESE PROTOCOLS
WITH MASKS AND TEMPERATURE
CHECKS.
WE ARE WEARING SENSORS TO STAY
ON TOP OF OUR DISTANCING TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE NOT SPENDING TOO
MUCH TIME TO CLOSE TO EACH OTHER
.
IF IT CAN HAPPEN IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT, IT CAN STILL HAPPEN
ANYWHERE.
IT IS SOMETHING WE HAVE TO STAY
ON TOP OF.
WE CAN SEE THE LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL.
WE ARE ALMOST THERE.
WE HAVE TO KEEP DOING WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING UP TO THIS
POINT.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL GET THERE
SOON.
STEPHEN: A LOT OF PLAYERS,
DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT.
YOU PITCH WITH YOUR GLASSES ON.
DOES IT PRESENT A PROBLEM WHEN
YOU ARE PITCHING IN HOT WEATHER,
HUMID WEATHER, LIKE IN
CINCINNATI?
: DID YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENED THE
OTHER DAY.
>> WE DID.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN: IS THAT WHY YOU ARE ASKING
THIS?
I HAVE NEVER HAD THAT HAPPEN
BEFORE.
SO THERE IT IS.
I ALMOST STEPPED ON THEM.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AWFUL.
I HAVE A BACKUP SET.
THEY ARE NOT THE UPDATED
PRESCRIPTIONS.
I THINK I WOULD HAVE BEEN OK.
I ALMOST STEPPED ON THEM WHEN I
FOLLOWED THROUGH.
THE WHOLE OUTING, I HAD SO MUCH
SWEAT, ON MY FACE, THEY KEPT
SLIDING DOWN AND BOUNCING
AROUND.
THE GUYS IN THE CLUBHOUSE HERE,
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE,
THEY GOT ME THIS SWEET CR
OAKIES.
THEY ARE NOT GOING ANYWHERE NOW.
DAN: THIS GAME IS ON YOUTUBE.
FAVORITE YOUTUBE VIDEO OF ALL
TIME?
SEAN: OH MAN.
I DON'T WATCH A TON OF YOUTUBE.
ONE THING I REALLY LIKE IS
REACTION VIDEOS.
PEOPLE HEARING A SONG FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
I THINK THOSE ARE REALLY
WHOLESOME AND FUN TO WATCH,
WATCHING SOMEONE ENJOY A SONG
THAT IS YOUR FAVORITE SONG,
WATCHING THEM SEEING IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HEARING IT IS
REALLY COOL SO I GO THROUGH THE
COMPILATIONS OF THOSE EVERY ONCE
IN A WHILE.
THEY ARE PRETTY FUN.
DAN: WE COULD TALK TO YOU
FOREVER.
YOU HAVE A JOB TO DO.
THANKS FOR SPENDING TIME.
JOHN: THANK YOU GUYS --
SEAN: THANK YOU GUYS.
DAN: LET'S TURN THIS THING BACK
ON.
THE YOUTUBE CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON ALEX.
HEALY6 IS THE NAME OF HIS
CHANNEL.
YOU COLLECT CARDS OF CURRENT
PLAYERS AND LEGENDS OF THE GAME
AND COMPETE.
IN REALITY, THE CHICAGO CUBS,
THE TEAM HE IS REPPING NOW, AS
WE WELCOME HIM IN.
ALEX, GREAT TO VISIT WITH YOU.
WE HAVE A LOT OF YOUNG FANS
WATCHING.
THEY MAY WANT TO GET INTO IT
MORE.
DIAMOND DYNASTY MY APPEAL TO
THEM -- MAY APPEAL TO THEM.
ALEX: DIAMOND DYNASTY, YOU
COLLECT A BUNCH OF CARDS WHICH
INCLUDE LEGENDS LIKE KEN GRIFFEY
OR BABE RUTH.
YOU CAN USE CURRENT GUYS LIKE
KRIS BRYANT OR EVEN GUYS OF THE
FUTURE LIKE ADLEY RUTSCHMAN.
YOU CAN EARN THEM IN CERTAIN
WAYS.
YOU CAN PLAY NEXT TO THE
COMPUTER, ONLINE.
SO MANY WAYS FOR EVERYONE THAT
WANTS TO PLAY THE GAME.
MY FAVORITE PLAYER I HAVE ON MY
SQUAD IS ALFONSO SORIANO.
BIG CUBS FAN AND THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY ADDING NEW LEGENDS.
WITH DAVID BOTE HITTING THE HOME
RUN, I WAS KIND OF IN THAT
SECTION AS WELL AND THE STADIUM
JUST WENT WILD.
DAN: DAN PLESAC WAS LOVING THAT
ONE TOO.
STEPHEN: I REMEMBER GOING DOWN
THE YOUTUBE RABBIT HOLE AND IT
LED ME TO ONE OF YOUR VIDEOS OF
YOU TRYING TO HIT HOME RUNS.
THAT IS ONE OF THE FEATURES OF
"MLB THE SHOW" AND YOU HAD A
LITTLE HOME RUN DERBY.
TALK TO FOLKS ABOUT THAT.
ALEX: YOU ARE ABLE TO CREATE
WHATEVER STADIUM YOU WANT.
SOME PEOPLE ARE CREATING
HISTORIC STADIUMS.
I WANTED TO TEST THE LIMITS.
I WANTED TO SEE IF I COULD HIT A
HOME RUN ON THE GAME WITHOUT ANY
HELP, 500 FEET LENGTH HOME RUNS,
THE WALLS WERE 40 FEET HIGH.
I HAD A LITTLE HELP.
I RAISED THE ELEVATION TO THE
MAX.
I SAT THERE FOR TWO HOURS BEFORE
I WAS ABLE TO HIT ONE OVER.
STEPHEN: THOSE ARE TANKS.
WHO WON THE DERBY?
ALEX: I ONLY HIT FOUR HOME RUNS.
FERNANDO TATIS HIT THREE OF
THEM.
I WAS TRYING OUT DIFFERENT GUYS
TO SEE WHAT ONE COULD PUT IT
OVER.
FERNANDO TATIS HAD THE MOST, THE
COVER BOY.
STEPHEN: WHICH ALSO MAKES SENSE.
I WILL GIVE YOU A
MULTIPLE-CHOICE QUESTION.
I WILL TAKE FIVE CURRENT
BIG-LEAGUEERS AND YOU TELL ME
YOUR MOST CREATIVE TYPE PLAYER.
FERNANDO TATIS, RONALD ACUNA
JR., MIKE TROUT, SHOHEI OHTANI.
STEPHEN: IT ENDS WITH THE WORLD
SERIES PREDICTION OF THE PADRES
AND HALOS, IS THAT RIGHT?
ALEX: I WANTED TO HAVE FERNANDO
TATIS HIT THE HOME RUN.
STEPHEN: I IMAGINE IT WAS HARDER
THAN PEOPLE THINK GOING BACK IN
TIME?
ALEX: I HAD TO SPEND TIME
DOWNLOADING EVERY SINGLE GAME.
I HAD SIX HOURS OF FOOTAGE
BEFORE I EDITED IT DOWN.
WE ARE GETTING A PEEK
OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS A TRIP DOWN MEMORY LANE.
YOU CAN CHECK OUT ALEX AND HIS
CONTENT ON YOUTUBE.
THERE IS JOHNNY CUETO WARMING
UP.
STEPHEN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK WE GAME SHOW --
PREGAME SHOW.
DAN: YOU DIDN'T DO ANY
STRETCHING BEFORE THIS.
STEPHEN: I DID NOT.
DAN: NORMALLY I WOULD SAY OVER
BECAUSE OF THIS BALLPARK.
THE PACE IS FASTER.
I'M SAYING UNDER.
IT IS A GETAWAY GAME, GETAWAY
DAY.
NORMALLY THEY ARE QUICKER.
I SAY UNDER.
STEPHEN: INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE
AND ONE YOU HAVE TO APPRECIATE.
NEXT UP, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
GIANTS HAVING THE BEST RECORD IN
ALL OF BASEBALL.
IF WE SHINE THE SPOTLIGHT ON THE
NL WEST, THE DODGERS.
IT IS THE GIANTS UP BY A HALF
GAME ON THE PADRES.
WHEN IT IS ALL SAID AND DONE,
WHO WAS THE WINNER?
DAN: CLOSE RACE.
I THINK THE DODGERS WIN THIS
DIVISION.
THEY WILL STRUGGLE TO WIN 95
GAMES.
THEY ARE NOT AS GOOD.
THEY ARE BEAT UP.
THE GIANTS HAVE MONEY.
THEY WILL BE AGGRESSIVE AT THE
TRADE DEADLINE.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL BE
SELLERS.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO PLAY WELL,
THEY WILL BE IN ON WHATEVER IT
IS SHORT-TERM TO HELP THEM GET
THERE.
STEPHEN: THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
STILL DON'T BELIEVE IN THEM
DESPITE THE OUTSTANDING PITCHING
STAFF.
THEY KEEP CHUGGING ALONG.
A LOT OF VETERANS DOING GOOD
THINGS.
HOW ABOUT CINCINNATI?
THE BREWERS ARE THE TRENDY PICK.
DAN: THE REDS NEED ONE GUY TO
COME UP WITH STARTING PITCHING
BETTER.
TYLER MAHLE, REALLY GOOD PITCHER
.
THE REDS ARE GOING TO SCORE
RUNS.
A LOT OF TEAMS HAVE HOLES IN
THIS DIVISION.
LOVE THE BREWERS STARTING
ROTATION.
THEY CAN'T HIT.
I STILL THINK THE CARDINALS WILL
BE THE BEST TEAM.
I WILL WATCH OUT FOR THE CUBS.
THEY ARE GETTING GUYS BACK
HEALTHY AGAIN.
THIS WILL BE AN INTERESTING
DIVISION.
THIS GOES DOWN TO THE LAST WEEK.
STEPHEN: YOU ARE THE PERFECT
PERSON TO ANSWER THIS.
N.L. CY YOUNG, '21.
A LOT OF GREAT CANDIDATES.
DARVISH, ROGERS, DEGROM.
LOOK AT THESE TEAMS WE ARE
WATCHING TODAY.
PITCHER FROM EITHER OF THESE
SQUADS MOST LIKELY TO WIN.
DAN: CRAZY ANSWER BUT I WILL SAY
ALEX WOOD.
IF ALEX DON'T LIGHT YOUR FIRE,
YOU'RE WORKING WITH WET WOOD.
ALEX WOOD, N.L. CY YOUNG.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
STEPHEN: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO GO KEVIN.
DAN: ALEX WOOD, FUNKY
LEFT-HANDED DELIVERY.
STEPHEN: SONNY GRAY, THAT
HEADSHOT WITH NO BUTTONS UNDONE.
WE LOVE HIM.
FOUND HIMSELF IN CINCINNATI WITH
DEREK JOHNSON.
STRIKEOUTS.
DAN: LET'S DO IT.
STEPHEN: JOHNNY CUETO, COMING
IN,
DAN: UNLESS HE FOUND NEWFOUND
LIFE FOR THE BREAKING BALL, HE
WILL HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME WITH
THIS LINEUP.
JESSE WINKER, ONE OF THE BEST
HATERS IN ALL BASEBALL.
-- HITTERS IN ALL BASEBALL.
STEPHEN: 6.5 OVER-UNDER, SET FOR
TYLER MAHLE.
DAN: OVER.
SPLITFINGER HAS TURNED INTO A
WEAPON.
YOU WANT TO USE THAT AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED BATTERS.
I THINK HE PITCHES WELL.
I WANT TO SEE JOHNNY CUETO.
STEPHEN: DAN PLESAC'S PICKS TO
CLICK.
FOUR LEFTIES IN THE LINEUP.
LET'S SHOW YOU THE POLLING
RESULTS.
WHAT YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
65% OF YOU ARE ROLLING WITH THE
GIANTS.
27-16 RECORD.
35%, I SEE YOU THERE IN THE
QUEEN CITY.
AS WE GET READY TO SAY GOODBYE,
WE HAVE ONE MORE MINUTE FOR YOU
TO SHARE A MEMORY, STORY OF YOUR
TIME SPENT PITCHING IN
CINCINNATI.
DAN: I NOTNE OMY
FAVORITEARKS TO PITCH IN.
I GAVE UP A HOME RUN TO AARON
BOONE.
I GOT A CHANCE TO PITCH IN THAT
BALLPARK THE NEXT YEAR.
THAT BALLPARK AND THE BALLPARK
IN ARLINGTON WERE NOT KIND TO
ME.
THERE ARE VERY MANY GOOD
MEMORIES.
STEPHEN: AMY G, ANYONE WHO
WATCHES GIANTS BASEBALL, SHE IS
IN THE CHAT AND SHE IS NOT
HAPPY.
DAN: LISTEN.
YOU HAVE TO PICK SOMEONE.
AMY, I'M SORRY.
STEPHEN: WE HAVE TO PASS THE
TORCH TO SCOTT, JEREMY, DANNY
AND J.P. MOROSI.
ENJOY.
SCOTT: WE HAVE A COUPLE FRIENDS
JOINING.
THE GIANTS HAVE TAKEN THE FIRST
THREE MATCHUPS IN THE SERIES.
HELLO TO EVERYONE WATCHING
WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE.
WE DO THIS JUST ABOUT EVERY
WEEK.
WE HAVE TODAY'S GAME EXCLUSIVELY
RIGHT HERE.
I HAVE A COUPLE FRIENDS JOINING
ME.
JEREMY AFFELDT PLAYED WITH BOTH
SIDES, ESPECIALLY WITH SAN
FRANCISCO, THREE RINGS, AND
DANNY GRAVES, TWO-TIME ALL-STARS
WITH THE CINCINNATI REDS IN THE
LATE 1990'S.
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITE.
LOOKS LIKE I AM LONELY HERE.
JEREMY: I APPRECIATE FOR YOU
BOTH COMING ON.
THAT TALK ABOUT MY CAREER.
SCOTT: YOU CAN START US OFF ON
THIS CINCINNATI TEAM.
HOW INVOLVED?
DANNY: WE DIDN'T GET TO SEE THE
NICK CASTELLANOS WE THOUGHT WE
WERE GOING TO SEE.
THE SHORT SEASON WAS A STRUGGLE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE THOUGHT
WE WOULD GET OUT OF HIM.
PHENOMENAL CRUSHING FASTBALLS
THIS YEAR.
CONTACT ON THE BARREL IS BETTER.
HE HAS BEEN SUCH A LEADER IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
SCOTT: LAST YEAR IT WAS ABOUT
PITCHING AND THIS YEAR IS ABOUT
HITTING.
2021, I THOUGHT IT WAS AN EVEN
YEAR.
JEREMY: WITH BUSTER POSEY COMING
BACK, BEING AS HEALTHY AS HE
OLLOWED HIS
LEAD.
THERE ARE HOMERS, WALKS, THE
TEAM IS HITTING WELL, SEEING THE
BOOK, THE COACHING IS
PHENOMENAL, THE PITCHING IS
GREAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU HAVE DEFENSE.
THE DEFENSE HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL.
IT ALLOWS THE PITCHERS TO PITCH.
SCOTT: THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE
RIGHT FORMULA.
JOHNNY CUETO IS BACK IN TOWN.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE TYLER MAHLE.
ALL OF THAT COMING UP ON A
GLOBAL STAGE, LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
WE WILL SWING BACK FOR THE FIRST
PITCH IN THE BALLPARK BY THE
RIVER.
STEPHEN: WE ARE AT GREAT
AMERICAN BALL PARK FOR THE REDS
AND THE GIANTS.
TIME FOR GABE KAPLER'S STARTING
NINE.
HE LEADS THE TEAM WITH 10 HOME
RUNS ON THE SEASON.
MAURICIO DUBON IS MIC'ED UP
TODAY.
TYLER MAHLE ON THE MOUND FOR
CINCINNATI.
HE IS COMING OFF A BRILLIANT
OUTING IN DENVER.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS AN E.R.A.
SOUTH OF THREE ON THE YEAR.
THE FASTBALL VELOCITY KEEPS
TICKING UP.
WE WILL GET BACK TO DANNY AND A
SECOND.
>> HE IS THE SPARK PLUG FOR THE
GIANTS.
HE IS STARTING TO PICK UP A
NOTCH.
ONCE HE GETS GOING.
POPPED UP FOR WINKER TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
ONE DOWN.
YOUR JIM BEAM BREAKDOWN ON TYLER
MAHLE.
>> A FEW THINGS I LIKE FROM
TYLER, HIS FASTBALL COMMAND.
USUALLY LATE IN THE COUNT.
HE EATS UP THE LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
YOU WATCH HIM GO DEEP IN THE
GAME, HE JUST GET STRONGER.
>> FIRES A STRIKE.
LAST YEAR, TYLER DITCHED THE
CUTTER.
HE IS A FASTBALL GUY.
>> THAT IS THE THING, HE WAS
TRYING DIFFERENT THINGS,
DIFFERENT BREAKING BALLS, THEN
YOU TURN IT INTO JUST ONE.
WHEN YOU HAVE MULTIPLE BREAKING
BALLS, IT IS HARD TO GET A FEEL
CONSISTENTLY.
>> 2-1.
AT ONE POINT, DARIN RUF WAS IN
L.A.
2-2.
GABE KAPLER SAID HE WORKS A
GREAT AT-BAT.
HE FEELS LIKE EVERY TIME HE
LOOKS UP -- THAT IS WHY YOU WANT
TO HAVE HIM AT THE TOP.
HE WILL GIVE YOU GOOD AT-BAT.
STAYS ALIVE.
KNOWS HE CANNOT DO ANYTHING BUT
IS JUST TRYING TO FOUL IT OFF.
HE IS GIVING HIS TEAMMATES A LOT
OF LOOKS.
HE IS TRYING TO RUN THE PITCH
COUNT UP TO SEE HOW LONG HE CAN
GET THE PITCHER TO WORK EARLY IN
THE GAME.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO.
>> GREAT BATTLE HERE.
3-2 COUNT.
>> ONCE AGAIN, HE FOULED THAT
BALL OFF.
OUT OF THE ZONE, HE IS STILL
ABLE TO MAKE CONTACT.
THAT IS WHY GABE LOVES HIM SO
MUCH.
>> FINDS SOME OPEN SPACE.
DARIN RUF IS HEADING FOR TWO AND
HE IS IN WITH A ONE OUT DOUBLE.
>> THAT FRUSTRATES A PITCHER
MORE THAN ANYTHING.
YOU BATTLE FOR EIGHT PITCHES,
THEN HE ROPES A DOUBLE.
THAT IS WHAT THE GIANTS SEEM TO
HAVE BEEN DOING ALL YEAR LONG.
THEY HAVE A GAME PLAN, THEY
BATTLE, THEY DON'T JUST GIVE
AWAY AT-BATS.
THEY MAKE PITCHERS PAY FOR
MISTAKES.
HONESTLY, THAT WAS AS BIG-LEAGUE
A BAT AS YOU CAN HAVE ANY
BASEBALL GAME.
>> GREAT JOB SETTING THE TABLE
FOR BRANDON CRAWFORD, HAVING ONE
OF THE BEST SEASONS OF HIS
CAREER SO FAR.
TAKES A PICTURE WAY.
-- PITCH AWAY.
10 HOME RUNS, MOST OF THEM VERY
VALUABLE.
7-10 OF THEM HAVE AT LEAST TIED
THE GAME.
>> A STANDARD FOR BRANDON
CRAWFORD, HE CARRIES BASEBALLS.
THESE MONTHS ARE A BIG DEAL FOR
THE GIANTS.
YOU HAVE A SHORTSTOP YOU LEAN
ON.
HE WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
MONTHS AT A TIME, CREATE HOMERS,
THEN HE HAS SOME OFF MONTHS.
THIS IS THE EARLIEST I HAVE SEEN
HIM ON THE EXPLOSION.
PHENOMENAL TO SEE HIM GO UP AND
HIT KEY HOMERS IN KEY
SITUATIONS.
IT IS A VETERAN SHOWING THESE
YOUNG KIDS HOW TO PLAY IN THE
BIG LEAGUES.
OVERALL, IT IS FUN TO WATCH HIM.
>> THAT FASTBALL UP IN THE ZONE
I WAS TALKING ABOUT FROM TYLER
MAHLE.
IF HE GETS GOOD COMMAND, IT
COULD BE A LONG DAY FOR THE
GIANTS OFFENSE.
UP AND IN ON CRAWFORD.
THAT IS THE ONE HE NEEDS TO
COMMAND.
THE UMPIRE WILL CALL IT A
STRIKE.
THEY WILL NOT SWING AT IT.
THAT IS THE SUCCESS TYLER MAHLE
HAS WITH THAT FASTBALL.
>> THE ARSENAL FOR TYLER MAHLE.
THE SLIDER, SPLITTER,
OCCASIONALLY.
>> HIS FOUR-SEAMER HAS MOVEMENT.
IT APPEARS TO RISE.
IT FORCES LATERAL MOVEMENT AT
TIMES.
>> ANOTHER GREAT AT-BAT HERE FOR
THE GIANTS.
THESE ARE CLOSE PITCHES.
>> THEY ARE MAKING HIM WORK.
THAT IS WHAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN MAKING AN
ATTEMPT.
THIS OFFENSE HAS A PLAN FOR
EVERY AT-BAT.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE THE BEST
TEAM IN BASEBALL.
>> CRAWFORD DOWN ON STRIKES.
OUT NUMBER 2.
>> YOU SEE THAT CHANGEUP.
WASN'T A GREAT PITCH BUT
MOVEMENT DOWN IN THE ZONE GETS
GUYS TO CHASE.
>> LOCATION OF THAT PITCH, DOWN
AND IN, IS SOMETHING CRAWFORD
LIKES TO SWING AT.
>> TYLER MAHLE IS ONE OF THE
BEST STRIKEOUT ARTIST IN THE
GAME.
>> LONGORIA HITTING THE BALL AS
HARD AS HE EVER HAS AT ANY POINT
IN HIS CAREER.
>> TYLER MAHLE, 20 PITCHES INTO
HIS OUTING, COMING OFF A
SEASON-HIGH SEVEN INNINGS.
HE HAS NEVER GONE ABOVE THAT
MARK.
>> 92 MPH, 0-2 FASTBALL, HOPPED
UP, 94 MPH.
SO DECEPTIVE.
92 MPH THESE DAYS DOESN'T SEEM
HARD BUT THE BALL JUMPS OUT OF
HIS HAND.
>> TO ME, THAT IS THE KEY TO
PITCHING.
NOT NECESSARILY HOW HARD YOU
THROW IT.
DECEPTION TO THE HITTER, 92
MIGHT LOOK LIKE 96 MPH DEPENDING
ON LOCATION.
YOU ARE TO SEE THAT MORE AND
MORE.
THIS YEAR, THESE GUYS ARE
STARTING TO FIGURE OUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO PITCH.
YOU CANNOT JUST THROW IT AS HARD
AS YOU CAN.
WE GOT TO WHAT, SIX NO-HITTERS
THIS YEAR?
GUYS ARE PITCHING.
PITCHERS ARE MAKING ADJUSTMENTS
AND USING THEIR FASTBALLS A LOT
MORE THAN THEY WERE.
A PITCHER LIKE THIS KNOWS
WHAT HE IS DOING, HE IS
JUST FACING A SUPER TOUGH
LINEUP.
>> PAYOFF PITCH, PAST THE
ENFIELD.
BASE HIT.
HE WILL SCORE EASILY.
R.B.I. KNOCK FOR EVAN LONGORIA
TO BREAK THE ICE FOR SAN
FRANCISCO.
1-0.
>> YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
ALREADY.
HE JUST ALLUDED TO IT.
THESE GUYS ARE NOT SWINGING AT
PITCHES.
TYLER MAHLE IS CLOSE WITH A LOT
OF THESE.
NOW, THE ADJUSTMENT HE ESTIMATE
-- WHEN YOU GET AHEAD EARLY,
FINISH HIM OFF.
>> HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO COME
AT HIM WITH FASTBALLS, FORCING
THEM TO SWING.
IT SEEMS LIKE IN THIS GAME HE IS
GETTING TO A FULL COUNT.
YOU HAVE TO TIP THE HAT TO THE
GIANTS HITTERS.
THAT WASN'T A BAD SLIDER.
HE IS SEEMING TO BE MISSING THE
ZONE EARLY IN THE COUNT.
>> WHEN YOU SEE SO MANY PITCHES,
YOU CAN PICK UP THE GOOD ONES.
THE SLIDERS, DOWN AND AWAY.
THEY HAVE SEEN A BUNCH OF THEM.
>> A LOOK AT THE DEFENSE FOR THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
WE WILL GO THROUGH THEIR LINEUP
AND THE NEXT HAPPENING.
-- IN THE NEXT HALF INNING.
VERY GIANTS-ISH FIRST INNING.
SECOND LOWEST SWING PERCENTAGE
IN BASEBALL.
THEY WAIT FOR THEIR PITCHES.
THEIR STARTERS HAVE BEEN GOING
DEEP INTO GAMES.
GOT HIM.
TYLER MAHLE PICKS UP THREE
>> TYLER MAHLE WILL JOIN US ONE
INNING FROM NOW.
>> WINKER LAUNCHES TO RIGHT
FIELD.
THAT IS OFF THE WALL.
STANDING DOUBLE.
>> RIGHT AGAINST THE GRAIN OF
THE SHIFT.
WINKER TAKES A TURN.
THE HUSTLE FROM JESSE WINKER!
WINKER UNLOADS.
WHO KNOWS WHERE THAT IS GOING?
SEVEN HOME RUNS FOR JESSE
WINKER.
PART ON THE GROUND, THROUGH THE
BASES.
NO CHANCE!
HE DANCES ACROSS THE DITCH.
THE REDS TAKE THE LEAD.
REDS 2-1.
>> HE SENDS THAT ONE JUST OVER
SECOND.
ANOTHER BASE KNOCK FOR JESSE
WINKER.
>> GIANTS PUNCH A RUN ACROSS IN
THE TOP FIRST.
TYLER STEPHENSON, YESTERDAY AT
FIRST.
JESSE WINKER LEADS OFF.
HE IS MIC'ED UP ON YOUTUBE
TODAY.
>> NAQUIN!
NAQUIN, NAQUIN!
I GOT THAT.
I GOT IT.
I GOT IT!
WOOO!
>> CAN WE MIC UP JESSE WINKER
EVERY SINGLE DAY PLEASE?
>> HE WOULD LOVE THAT.
JESSE LIKES TO TALK MORE THAN WE
DO.
OH MY GOODNESS.
HE WOULD BURN A HOLE THROUGH IT.
HE IS NOT SHY.
HE HAS BEEN GREAT THIS SEASON AT
THE PLATE.
EIGHT HOME RUNS.
JOHNNY CUETO'S THIRD PITCH OF
THE DAY IS INSIDE.
>> IF HE IS NOT TALKING TO
SOMEBODY, HE IS TALKING TO
HIMSELF.
SO FUNNY.
LOVE HIS PERSONALITY.
AMAZING HITTER.
HE IS A REALLY GOOD HITTER.
>> I WOULD TALK A LOT TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TRUE, VERY TRUE.
>> THIS IS A TALENT.
.544 SLUGGING PERCENTAGE IN
AUGUST, LAST YEAR, LEADING THE
TEAM.
>> SCOTT, GOOD AFTERNOON FROM
THE GREAT AMERICAN BALL PARK.
JOHNNY CUETO ON THE MOUND TODAY
FOR THE GIANTS, JUST AS HE WAS
FOR THE REDS IN HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE
DEBUT BACK IN APRIL, 2008.
APRIL 3, THERE HE IS ON THE
MOUND.
HOW ABOUT DAVID WEATHERS?
HIS SON, BRIAN, -- KEN GRIFFEY
JR. WAS IN THE RED STARTING
LINEUP THAT DAY AS WELL.
>> MANY CONNECTIONS TODAY.
THOSE ARE HIS NUMBERS THIS
SEASON.
EIGHT YEARS WITH CINCINNATI,
2.13 E.R.A. -- HE WAS GREAT,
THEN HE HIT THE SHELF.
HE IS WORKING HIS WAY BACK.
>> HE HAS HAD A HAIRCUT.
>> HE HAS BEEN WORKING HIS WAY
BACK.
INJURIES OFF AND ON.
STARTERS 10 TO BE SLOW COMING
BACK OFF THE IL.
YOU ARE TRYING TO TRUST YOUR
BODY.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE SAME ARM
SPEED.
I THINK HE WILL GET IT GOING
AGAIN.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE HAS BEEN SLOW
COMING BACK.
IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT.
>> TROUBLESOME START FOR HIM.
WINKER WALKS.
CASTELLANOS SINGLES.
THAT BRINGS TYLER STEPHENSON IN,
ELECTRIC AT HOME.
THAT PITCH SKIPS AWAY.
BOTH RUNNERS WILL STAY PUT.
FAR ENOUGH.
>> THAT IS SMART.
THEY KNOW HOW QUICK HE IS BEHIND
THE PLATE.
TOUGH PITCH TO GET TO.
HIS RELEASE IS SO QUICK.
>> NICE USING YOUR BACKUP
CATCHER.
HE IS A CATCH AND THROW GUY.
THAT IS WHAT HE DOES.
VERY SMART.
HE WORKS WITH THE PITCHES.
DEFINITELY A GUY YOU DO NOT WANT
TO RUN ON.
>> CUETO TRYING TO FIND IT.
THREE MISSES TO STEPHENSON.
NAQUIN WAITING ON DECK.
>> THIS IS A TOUGH BALLPARK TO
FIND IT.
IT IS THE WALKS, BEING BEHIND IN
THE COUNT.
IT CAN BITE YOU.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PART TO MAKE
THESE HITTERS FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE AN ADVANTAGE.
IT CAN BE AN UNFUN GAME FOR
PITCHERS.
>> A LITTLE MORE ON JOHNNY
CUETO.
YOUR PITCHING BREAKDOWN.
WITH JOHNNY, HE LIKES TO
MIX-AND-MATCH PITCHES.
HE LIKES TO CHANGE.
HE LIKES DIFFERENT RHYTHM.
THAT CAN MESS WITH HITTERS.
IMPORTANT FOR HIM TO PITCH AS
DEEP AS POSSIBLE TO STAY IN THE
COUNT.
>> JUST WHAT HE NEEDS.
THE GIANTS TURN TWO.
TYLER STEPHENSON IS DOUBLED UP
AS WINKER MOVES TO THIRD.
THIS DOUBLE PLAY STARTED BY EVAN
LONGORIA.
>> PITCHING DEEP IN THE GAME,
GETTING AHEAD IN THE COUNT,
ESPECIALLY WITH THIS WEEKEND
COMING UP, TODAY'S A BIG GAME.
SEEING HIM GO DEEP IN THE GAME
AND TRY TO SAVE THIS FOR THAT
SERIES WILL BE A BIG DEAL.
YOU NEED KEY DOUBLE PLAYS.
IT IS A DANGEROUS WAY TO DO IT
BUT JOHNNY HAS A REPERTOIRE TO
DO IT.
HE HAS THE ARSENAL.
HE CAN PITCH HIMSELF OUT OF
JAMS.
WITH HIM COMING OFF THE IL, HE
NEEDS TO DELIVER AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
>> AFTER TODAY, 7-10 OF THE
GIANTS GOING AGAINST THE
DODGERS.
CUETO PICKING UP THE PACE.
1-2 ON NAQUIN.
>> 2016, IMPRESSIVE YEAR.
2015 WAS TOO WITH THE ROYALS.
>> SIGNS THAT BIG DEAL.
GREAT GAME.
THEN HE HAS DEALT WITH INJURIES.
HAD SOME ARM INJURIES,
SURGERIES.
EXPECT TO SEE, THESE VETERAN
PITCHERS WILL END OF PITCHING
MORE THAN THEY USED TO.
YOU WILL SEE CUETO --
>> THERE IS THE STJUST HAVE TO .
NO PROBLEM.
DOUBLE PLAY, STRIKEOUT TO END
THE INNING.
>> BASE HIT COULD MEAN AN R.B.I.
FOR WILMER FLORES.
THAT IS HIT WELL.
STILL GOING, ADIOS!
THREE RUN OPPOSITE FIELD HOME
RUN.
HIGH FLY BALL TO RIGHT, HIT VERY
WELL, IT IS OUT OF HERE!
>> DUBON, THAT ONE IS SMOKED.
WAY BACK THERE.
MAURICIO DUBON.
>> STARTS WITH THAT FIRST MAN
GETTING ON.
THAT BALL IS DEEP AND IT IS
GONE!
HIGH FLY, DEEP LEFT.
DOES IT CARRY?
YES!
BACK-TO-BACK JACKS!
6-3.
>> ROGERS COMES IN.
>> GIANTS UP IN THE SECOND
INNING.
YOUTUBE ALLOWS MULTIPLE-CHOICE
RESPONSES TO QUESTIONS.
LET'S BRING IN OUR FIRST
QUESTION OF THE DAY.
GET READY FOR YOUR ANSWERS.
MAURICIO DUBON.
IN FOR A STRIKE.
OK, JEREMY?
>> IT IS GOING TO SEEM CLICHÉ.
I THINK THE GIANTS HAVE THE BEST
SHOT.
LITTLE BIT OF ANALYTICS, KEEPING
THE HUMAN SIDE, THE WAY THE
PITCHERS ARE PITCHING, THE
BULLPEN COMING IN STRONG, THE
OFFENSE.
BUSTER POSEY.
THE GIANTS.
>> I SUPPOSE YOU ARE GOING TO
ASK ME?
I PROBABLY SHOULD NOT ANSWER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OF COURSE.
DANNY, YOU ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE INCLUDED.
HE PUTS AWAY DUBON.
THE GIANTS ARE GOING TO MAKE
NOISE.
THE DODGERS AND THE PADRES ARE
THERE AS WELL.
DO YOU AGREE SAN FRANCISCO HAS
THE BEST SHOT?
>> I WAS TRYING TO AVOID THE
QUESTION.
I JUST COULDN'T STAND IT.
[LAUGHTER]
HERE IS MY ANSWER.
THE SAME IS JEREMY.
THEIR PITCHING IS BUBBLY ONE OF
THE BEST -- PROBABLY ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
AND THE DEFENSE.
THE RIGHT FORMULA IS PITCHING,
DEFENSE, HITTING.
IT IS HARD TO SAY THEY WON'T
MAKE THE PLAYOFFS, AS LONG AS
THEY STAY HEALTHY.
>> BEST E.R.A. IN BASEBALL, SAN
FRANCISCO PITCHING.
BEYOND EXPECTATIONS SO FAR.
ALEX WOOD WILL GO TOMORROW FOR
THEM AGAINST L.A.
JOHNNY CUETO WIGGLES OUT OF THE
FIRST INNING.
STEVEN DUGGAR IN THE SEVEN HOLE
FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
2-1 COUNT.
>> I SEE WHY TYLER MAHLE HAS
RIDICULOUS NUMBERS.
HE PITCHES INSIDE TO LEFTIES.
YOU WILL HAVE RESULTS LIKE THAT.
>> TWO COMEBACKERS FOR EASY
OUTS.
TYLER MAHLE DOMINATING AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED HITTING SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
>> IT IS AMAZING, THE NUMBERS.
THE WAY HE COMMANDS THAT
FASTBALL.
HE COMMANDS IT BETTER TO
LEFTIES.
HE STARTS IN ON THEIR HANDS.
RIGHTIES SEE THE BALL AWAY.
HE HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL IN
ADJUSTING HIS GAME PLAN.
>> GOING UP AGAINST HIS FORMER
TEAMMATE.
CASALI WAS A RED.
>> I ALWAYS HATED FORMER
TEAMMATES, ESPECIALLY CATCHERS.
>> YOU SEE THAT SMILE.
>> CASALI STARING HIM DOWN AND
TURNING IT INTO A HIT.
TWO OUT SINGLE FOR CURT CASALI
WITH A LITTLE SMILE STARE DOWN.
LOOK AT HIM GO.
>> NO LIE.
USUALLY A GUARANTEED HIT.
>> THAT IS NOT A BAD PITCH.
>> THE GIANTS RIGHT-HANDERS ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB OF SPINNING
THAT PITCH OR GOING UP THE
MIDDLE.
TYLER MAHLE IS NOT PITCHING BAD.
40 PITCHES.
HE IS NOT PITCHING BAD.
JUST SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE
BATTLING.
>> HE LOVES THE COMEBACKERS
TODAY.
THREE GROUND BALL OUTYLER.
NICE LOCATION FOR JOHNNY CUETO.
1-0 GIANTS.
>> CASTELLANOS ON-DECK.
IT CARRIES, IT IS GONE!
THE REDS GET THEIR FIRST INNING
RUN.
>> THE GIANTS ARE IN BUSINESS
HERE IN THE FOURTH INNING.
NO ONE OUT.
>> DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE,
GOODBYE!
HOMER FOR ALLERGY SIXERS AND --
ALEX DICKERSON.
>> CRAWFORD GETS ONE VERY HIGH,
VERY DEEP, VERY FAIR, OUT OF
HERE!
>> TWO OUTS.
BLANDINO AT FIRST.
>> LINE DRIVE RIGHT TO DUBON AT
SECOND.
HE THROWS HIM OUT AT FIRST.
JUST LIKE THAT, SEVEN STRONG.
>> HOME SECOND WITH 5, 6, 7
COMING UP.
SUNSHINEY DAY.
THE REDS DOWN A RUN.
THEIR TURN AGAINST JOHNNY CUETO.
WE WILL SET UP THE DEFENSE FOR
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE BALLPARK WILL CONTINUE TO
FILL UP AS PARKS ACROSS MLB
WELCOME BACK FANS.
A WELCOME SIGHT.
NEITHER OF YOU DEALT WITH THE
2020 WEIRDNESS.
LONGORIA PUTS HIM AWAY.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE
APPRECIATION LEVEL GOES UP, WHEN
YOU SEE WHAT BASEBALL WAS LIKE
WITHOUT FANS.
>> IT HAS GOT TO BE A HUGE
RELIEF TO PLAY IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE.
LAST YEAR WAS TOUGH, AS AN
ANNOUNCER.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT WAS LIKE
FOR THE PLAYERS.
GREAT SEEING FANS BACK.
>> I DON'T DO WELL, EVEN AS A
PLAYER, YOU ALMOST COULD HEAR
THE GROUND -- I WANTED THE WHITE
NOISE.
IT WOULD FEEL LIKE A PICKUP
GAME, NOT LIKE THIS COUNTS.
I LIKE THE EMOTION, THE
ELECTRICITY OF THE BASEBALL
GAME.
I FED OFF OF IT.
TO HAVE A SILENT GAME LIKE THAT,
ESPECIALLY WITH VETERAN PLAYERS
-- SUPER DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
GUYS.
>> CINCINNATI, JUNE 2, THEIR
HOMESTAND IS WIDE OPEN.
>> THERE IS A STRIKE TO INDIA.
WADE MILEY IS JOINING US AS A
GUEST.
YOUTUBE LIVE CHAT QUESTIONS FOR
MR. MILEY, LET US KNOW WHAT YOU
GOT.
WE CHAT IN JUST A BIT ON
YOUTUBE.
>> NICE PAUSE.
CUETO.
>> STRIKE 2.
>> NO IN THE MEDIA GUIDE, JOHNNY
CUETO --
>> I WAS PICKING UP WHAT YOU ARE
PUTTING DOWN.
I LOVE IT.
>> WE WENT TO THE SAME COLLEGE.
WE THINK ALIKE.
>> I DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE.
>> MIAMI JUST TAUGHT US
BASEBALL.
>> THAT IS WHAT WE NEEDED.
THAT IS A HARD-HIT.
TWO OUT SINGLE.
>> TALKING ABOUT THESE WIND UPS,
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
CUETO MAKES IT LOOK EASY.
PITCHING IS ABOUT TIMING,
RELEASE POINT, BALANCE.
HE WILL DO A DELAYED SHIMMY.
IT IS CRAZY WHAT HE DOES.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO DO.
YOU HAVE TO BE AN ATHLETE.
I WAS JUST HOPING TO GET IT TO
THE PLATE.
THIS GUY CAN DO ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS, THEN THINK
ABOUT PITCHING.
THERE IS A LOT GOING ON IN HIS
WORLD.
>> 0-1.
OUTS BLANDINO -- BLANDINO.
MANY PITCHERS IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS SHORTENING UP THEIR
DELIVERY, JUST PITCHING OUT OF
THE STRETCH, FINDING SUCCESS.
THEN THERE IS JOHNNY CUETO.
>> THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN TALK OF
REPEATING YOUR MECHANICS.
IT IS HARD.
>> AND PICKED GUYS OFF.
>> THAT IS A QUICK THROW.
THE SNAP AND JOHNNY CUETO
CATCHES JONATHAN INDIA.
WE WILL MAKE SURE NO ONE IS
CHALLENGING THAT.
DAVID BELL SAYS, WE ARE GOOD.
THE INNING IS OVER.
TWO OUT SINGLE FOR INDIA.
>> THAT MARKS THE FIRST TIME THE
GIANTS HAVE GOTTEN THEIR LEADOFF
MAN.
BASE HIT TO THE FIELD.
WINKER COMES UP THROWING.
THE GIANTS HAVE A 1-0 LEAD.
>> KEVIN GAUSMAN, EVERY START
THIS YEAR HAS GONE AT LEAST SIX
INNINGS.
>> SUAREZ.
HE THROWS ONE UP.
LONGORIA, WHAT A PLAY TO OPEN UP
THE BOTTOM SEVEN.
>> HERE'S A TOUGH SPOT.
BUSTER POSEY, FIVE GRAND SLAMS
OF HIS CAREER.
>> HIGH FLY BALL TO LEFT.
WELL INTO THE GAP, UP AGAINST
THE WALL, THREE RUNS ARE
GOING TO SCORE.
BUSTER POSEY CLEARS THE BASES.
>> THE GIANTS HAVE A 4-0 LEAD.
>> THIS MEANS IT IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> THIS IS AN INFORMED AUDIENCE.
SMART CHOICE BY THE YOUTUBE
CROWD.
WE GET READY TO START THE THIRD
INNING WITH TYLER MAHLE.
THE GIANTS HAVE THE BEST RECORD
IN BASEBALL.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI.
TYLER MAHLE FINDS THE ZONE FOR
STRIKE ONE.
HIS TEAMMATE JOINS US NOW.
WADE MILEY, HOW YOU DOING TODAY?
WE WILL HAVE A BLAST.
HOW IS THE FOOT?
WADE: IT WILL BE OK.
IT IS A SHAME.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> GIVE US HER SCOUTING REPORT
ON TYLER MAHLE.
HE CONTINUES TO IMPROVE.
WADE: HE HAS BEEN GREAT.
TRUSTING IN HIMSELF.
REALLY GOOD SLIDER AND SPLIT.
HE IS SURGICAL WITH THAT THING.
>> WADE, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
NO-HITTER.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER TATTOO?
WE ALL KNOW THE STORY.
WADE: WE TRIED AGAIN YESTERDAY.
WASN'T AS SUCCESSFUL.
>> YOUR SON -- YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT HIM --
>> I AM SURE HE WATCHES A LOT OF
YOUTUBE.
WADE: YEAH.
HE LOVES ALL THE ATTENTION.
>> MIKE YASTRZEMSKI WALKS.
LET'S GO BACK TO MAY 7.
THIS IS HOW THE REDS STARTED OFF
THE SEASON.
WADE MILEY WAS DOMINANT.
CUTTER, CHANGEUP, HITTING THE
RIGHT SPOTS.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT HOW YOU
DID, WHAT WAS YOUR OWN SCOUTING
REPORT ON THAT OUTING?
WADE: I SHOWED EARLY.
THEY WERE AGGRESSIVE.
THEY KEPT GOING WITH ME.
YOU PROTECT TO THE CUTTER IN.
WE GOT IT DONE.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY IS KIND OF
IN THE SAME MODE WHEN IT COMES
TO SIX NO-HITTERS ALREADY.
YOU TALK ABOUT WHY THAT SEEMS TO
BE?
YOU THINK IT IS JUST ONE OF
THOSE WEIRD THINGS?
IS THAT THE FEELING?
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON?
WADE: I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS HARD.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THE SHIFTS MAKE IT EVEN TOUGHER.
THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
PLAY THE LONG GAME.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE AN ANSWER.
THERE HAVE BEEN 2, 3 THROWN
SINCE MAY 7.
>> CHANCES ARE HIGH THAT THIS
SEASON IS GOING TO BREAK THE
RECORD.
THE RECORD IS EIGHT.
WADE: THERE WILL PROBABLY BE
ANOTHER ONE GOING ON HERE
SHORTLY.
>> THAT IS SOLIDLY STRUCK.
HE IS IN BUSINESS.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI TAKES A LONG
LOOK AROUND SECOND.
TWO ON TO START THIS THIRD
INNING FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
SOME NOTES ON WADE MILEY.
TAKE US THROUGH THE EVOLUTION OF
WHAT YOU LEARNED O'DAY STARTING
-- AS A STARTING PITCHER AND THE
CHANGES AS YOU ARE ABLE TO
THRIVE AT THIS STAGE OF YOUR
CAREER.
WADE: YOU NEVER QUIT LEARNING.
REMAIN OPEN, LISTEN TO PEOPLE.
THE MORE I HAVE BEEN AROUND
PEOPLE, I DON'T HAVE WIPEOUT
STUFF.
IT IS JUST LEARNING HOW TO USE
IT.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
HITTER IS DOING.
ATTACK THAT.
JUST TRYING TO GET KNOWLEDGE
FROM OTHERS.
>> BRANDON CRAWFORD DROPS ONE
INTO RIGHT.
MIKE YASTRZEMSKI WILL MAKE IT
2-0.
SAN FRANCISCO.
R.B.I. KNOCK FOR BRANDON
CRAWFORD TO DRIVE IN THE SECOND
RUN OF THE DAY.
WADE, LET'S CONTINUE.
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS FROM
OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS.
WHAT WAS MORE THRILLING,
PITCHING IN THE WORLD SERIES OR
THROWING A NO-HITTER?
>> I NEVER PITCHED IN THE WORLD
SERIES.
I WAS JUST THERE.
2019 WAS REALLY SPECIAL.
THE NO-HITTER WAS PRETTY HIGH UP
THERE.
>> IT WAS AWESOME AND I'M SURE
YOU WILL BE BACK.
WOULD YOU TRADE YOUR NO-HITTER
TO BE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR?
WADE: I DON'T THINK SO.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
NO-HITTER PROBABLY MEANS MORE.
>> HAS HE ASKED YOU THAT IN THE
CLUBHOUSE?
>> I HAVEN'T GOT THAT QUESTION.
>> OFF-TOPIC AGAIN, I HEARD YOUR
INTERVIEW ON THE FIELD AND YOU
SAID YOU ARE SCARED OF NEEDLES.
WE HAVE TO GET OVER THIS FEAR.
>> IT IS A REAL THING.
THE MACHINE GOES ON, IT IS FULL
PANIC AND I AM OUT.
ONCE I GET THROUGH SPRING
TRAINING, I'M GOOD.
>> DO YOU LOOK AWAY WHEN THEY
ARE DOING IT?
WADE: I ABOUT PASS OUT.
>> YOUR DAD IS NOT A FAN OF
PERMANENT TATTOOS.
HE ALMOST FELL FOR IT.
WADE: I DON'T KNOW IF IT WOULD
BOTHER HIM MUCH.
I HAVE ALWAYS WANTED A TATTOO
BUT THE NEEDLE.
>> ONE LAST QUESTION.
TALKING ABOUT THE ANALYTICS AND
INFORMATION, COACH -- I LIKE TO
SEE THE VELOCITY IS NOT 98 MPH.
YOU LEARN TO WORK WITH IT.
I FEEL LIKE THAT IS THE KEY.
THESE HITTERS -- HEY LET'S LEARN
TO PITCH.
LET'S TRY TO PUT IT IN PLAY.
THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO BE IN
SWING MODE.
SWING HARD, LIFT THE BALL.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT ARC IS
STARTING TO CUT BACK.
WADE: IT PLAYS IN THE FAVOR, THE
WAY GUYS PITCH, I FEEL LIKE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE THAT
AGGRESSIVE, I CAN MOVE THE BALL
AROUND.
THE PITCHING NEVER CROSSES THEIR
MIND.
THAT IS PROBABLY WHY HE IS WHO
HE IS.
I WISH THERE WAS A WAY WE COULD
TALK TO YOUNG GUYS ABOUT DOING
THAT, LEARNING HOW TO PITCH.
SETTING HITTERS UP.
OVER TIME THEY WILL LEARN.
>> R.B.I. KNOCK FOR DICKERSON.
WE WILL LET YOU GO.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HOPEFULLY TYLER MAHLE -- VERY
ROCKY START TO THIS INNING.
NO OUTS.
MAURICIO DUBON UP NEXT FOR THE
GIANTS.
THEY HAVE SCORED TWICETHE THIRD.
THAT PITCH MISSES AWAY.
DICKERSON POUNCES.
HE DRIVES IN A RUN.
YASTRZEMSKI STARTED UP WITH A
WALK.
A COUPLE BASE HITS IN A ROW FROM
CRAWFORD.
DICKERSON WITH A SINGLE SCORE TO
SCORE A RUN.
THIS IS DIVINE, HIS FIRST TRIP.
SHUT THE BAT DOWN AS HE AVOIDED
THAT BASEBALL.
THE COMMAND ISSUES COMING HERE
FROM TYLER MAHLE IN THE THIRD
INNING.
>> I HAVE TO SAY IT IS
UNCHARACTERISTIC.
IT'S VERY UNCHARACTERISTIC,
WATCHING PITCH BY PITCH.
THE GIANTS ARE DOING SOME --
DOING A GREAT JOB COMING OFF THE
CLOSE PITCHES.
GETTING UP ON IT A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT COMING HE'S
THROWING A LOT OFFSPEED
FULL-TIME HIS PERCENTAGE IS SO
MUCH DIFFERENT, THE 53%
FASTBALL, THE SLIDER COME SEEMS
LIKE HE IS THROWING MORE SLIDERS
AND CHANGEUPS TODAY THEN HE HAS
FASTBALLS.
HE ESTABLISHES THE BASEBALL,
USES THE SECONDHAND PITCHES.
>> GOES WITH THE HEAT, LOWS PAST
A BOND, TWO STRIKES AGAINST
THEM.
BASES LOADED, YOU KNOW THE GUY
IS GOING TO COME OUT OF HIS
SHOES.
ALREADY CHALLENGED HIM.
A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN YOU HAVE.
ANOTHER 2-NUMERAL TWO COUNT.
YOU MENTIONED JEFF BRANTLEY
EARLIER.
THE POINT THAT HE MADE IT LAST
START FOR TYLER COME HE SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT, THIS YEAR -- AFTER
THE LAST PITCH, YOU CAN SEE THE
LAST TWO STARTS, IN THE THIRD
TODAY, ALREADY THREE RUNS
ALLOWED, NONE RECORDED IN THIS
THIRD INNING.
>> IT IS NOT JUST TYLER.
I THINK A LOT OF PITCHERS IT
INTO THE RUT OF TRYING TO PICK
OUT THE CORNERS OF THE PLATE
INSTEAD OF JUST FINISHING GUYS
OFF, AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW
YOU ARE WORKING BEHIND WITH FULL
COUNTS.
>> BOND TO THE RIGHT SIDE WITH
OPEN SPACE, AND THAT WILL SCORE
ANOTHER ONE FOR THE GIANTS --
DUBON TO THE RIGHT SIDE WITH
OPEN SPACE, AND THAT WILL SCORE
ANOTHER ONE FOR THE GIANTS.
4-0.
THREE OF THEM COMING IN THE
THIRD, AND THEY ARE ALL OVER
TYLER MAHLE.
>> LIKE YOU WERE SAYING, THE
FASTBALL, HE IS THROWING A LOT
OF SPEED IN THE STRIKE ZONE,
TAKING THESE FASTBALLS.
WHEN HE DOES COME WITH THAT
FASTBALL, HE IS GOING TO BE IN
THE UPPER QUADRANT, THE STRIKE
ZONE.
THOSE FASTBALLS RIGHT THERE OVER
THE MIDDLE, YOU ARE ALLOWING HIM
TO GET MORE SHEEP HITS LIKE THAT
WHEN YOU DO.
FOR ME, HIS FASTBALL WAS NOT HIT
ALL THAT WELL.
STARTS LOOKING FOR THOSE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE.
THE KID HAS A REALLY GOOD --
-- DAVID BELL TAKES THE
BASEBALL.
THE THIRD IN CINCINNATI.
>> HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT WITH
THE HOUSTON ASTROS 40 YEARS AGO.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE A
FULLY BASEBALL I.
BRUCE BOCHY PLATE IN 1984 WORLD
SERIES.
MANAGED IN THE FALL CLASSIC 14
YEARS LATER.
HIS TENURE WITH THE GIANTS, FIVE
SEASONS, CULMINATED IN BUSTER'S
10TH, AND THE MEMORABLE DAY IN
2014 WHEN HE SUMMONED HIS SON'S
-- FOR HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT.
>> THIS IS A MAN WITH
UNSURPASSED LOVE AND
UNDERSTANDING FOR BASEBALL.
ONE OF THOSE WHO PLAY THE GAME.
>> DON'T FORGET TO CHECK OUT
YOUTUBE LIVE COMMENTARY, GIANTS
AND THE REDS, GAME COMMENTARY.
YOUR MOBILE DEVICE ON THAT GAME
COMMENTARY THROUGHOUT THE
BROADCAST.
QUESTIONS -- THEY WILL PROVIDE
INSIGHTS WITH QUESTIONS, J.P.
MOROSI AS WELL.
IT WAS NOT TYLER MAHLE'S DAY FOR
TODAY.
THIS SEASON, HE LEAVES AFTER SIX
OUTS TODAY.
THE GIANTS SHOWING OFF THEIR
PATIENCE, THEIR PERSISTENCE, AND
THEIR GAME PLAN TODAY, AND NOW
PHILLIES TAKES OVER -- AND NOW
FELIZ TAKES OVER.
NOW HE HAS POPPED UP A FEW
TIMES.
NUMBERS ARE SUPERB SO FAR THIS
SEASON, AND THE BETTER WITH THE
BASES LOADED.
MOSTLY FASTBALL SLIDER, AND NOW
MICHAEL FELIZ LOOKED PRETTY
GOOD.
NICE ON THE YEAR.
>> THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT WILL
NEVER BE ENTERED.
SOMETHING IN THE FRONT OFFICE,
THESE GUYS THAT THEY ARE KEEPING
UP ON, COULD HAVE BEEN A ROSTER
SPOT ISSUE, COULD HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING HAPPENING, YOU JUST
NEVER KNOW.
YOU SEE A GUY WITH THIS GOOD OF
AN ARM, JUST GET DESIGNATED FOR
ASSIGNMENTS BY PLAYS.
SORRY, CAN'T HELP YOU THERE.
>> THAT'S ALL I NEEDED.
THAT'S ON THE GROUND.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A FOUL BALL.
>> EVAN LONGORIA CHECKING
HIMSELF.
"THAT DIDN'T TOUCH ME.
>> LONGORIA, MAN.
MOVE AROUND LIKE THAT.
>> HE ALMOST TRIED TO LIKE WALK
HIM.
>> THAT CATLIKE APPROACH.
[LAUGHTER]
>>'S BASEBALL INSTINCTS ARE OFF
THE CHARTS.
>> AND GOT TO FIX THAT.
GET THEMSELVES TOGETHER.
LIKE WHEN YOU ARE RUSHING OUT OF
THE HOUSE.
OK, I'M GOOD.
>> LONGORIA, DICKERSON, AND
DUBON ON THE BASE PATHS.
BASES-LOADED, NOW A FULL COUNT.
SOME OF THE TOUGHEST SITUATIONS
TO COME IN, WITH BASES-LOADED,
NO OUTS.
YOU HAVE NO PLACE TO GO.
YOU HAVE TO THROW STRIKES.
FOR ME, THE CALL MUST IN THE
SITUATION IS TO LIMIT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, BUT I'VE GOT TO GET
OUT.
IN THE ZONE, SOCKED BY DUGGAR,
AND GIVES IT A LOOK, AND IT'S
GONE.
STEVEN DUGGAR LOADS UP, AND IT
IS A GRAND SLAM FOR THE GIANTS
TO MAKE IT 8-0 SAN FRANCISCO.
WHAT A LAST OFF THE BAT OF
DUGGAR, HIS SECOND OF THE
SEASON.
HE WAS ALL OVER THAT FASTBALL.
NOT SOMETHING I WOULD HAVE SAID.
HE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HIT FOR
SOME POWER.
I WOULD HAVE SAID I SAW IT
COMING, BUT WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE BROADCAST, YOU CANNOT AS YOU
ARE GOING TO GIVE UP -- WHEN YOU
GET STUNG, THE GUY GIVING UP
MULTIPLE HITS, RALLY STARTS, AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN LIKE -- THAT IS
THE FRUSTRATING THING ABOUT THE
BALLPARK IS THAT THAT KIND OF
STUFF CAN HAPPEN PRETTY EASILY.
>> DUGGAR MENTIONED -- HITTING
DOWN THE BALLPARK, YOU WANT TO
HAVE SOME DAMAGE CONTROL.
YOU MAY GIVE UP ONE OR TWO, BUT
YOU DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP FOUR,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> THAT WAS OFF THE BACK WALL.
WHAT I SAW COME IT DIDN'T LAND
ON THE GRASS.
IT WAS ON THE BACK WALL.
>> LET'S RUN IT BACK.
THAT IS A HAPPY GUY WHO LOVES
HITTING IN THIS BALLPARK.
A CAREER HOME RUNS.
HE ENTERED THE DAY -- THREE
DOUBLES, FIVE R.B.I. COME IN A
SHORT SPAN, OF COURSE.
STEVE DUGGAR HAS STRUGGLED THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS QUITE TO
PICK ME UP THIS AFTERNOON.
427.
LET'S GO TO THE BALLPARK --
WHERE DID IT GO?
>> SCOTT, THE SOURCES -- AND BY
THAT I MEAN MY EYES -- CAN
CONFIRM THAT WAS OFF THE WINDOW
OF THE CENTER FIELD CLUB HERE AT
THE GREAT AMERICAN BALL PARK.
THAT IS A SERIOUS, SERIOUS
CENTER FIELD, AND THAT HAS TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION EARLIER
ABOUT MICHAEL FELIZ, A BIT OF A
ROSTER CRUNCH.
THEY HAD A LOT OF YOUNG PLAYERS
THAT WANTED TO GET ON THE
ROSTER.
THAT WAS THE REASON THERE.
I CAN CONFIRM MY EARS ARE STILL
RINGING WITH THE SOUND OF THAT
IMPACT IN CENTER FIELD.
>> THE BALL -- THAT IS A LONG
WAY.
>> THAT WAS STILL GOING.
STOPPED THAT BALL FROM GOING
FURTHER.
THAT IS A PRETTY GOOD LITTLE
POKE THERE.
>> STEVE DUGGAR IS A GREAT
ATHLETE.
MIGHT BE THE BEST ON THE TEAM.
PLAYS A NICE OUTFIELD, AND HE
CATCHES WITH THE GIANTS, CLOSES
THE BOOK ON TYLER MAHLE WITH THE
NEXT SEVEN RUNS IN TWO INNINGS.
GOING FOR IT, AND THERE ARE TWO
DOWN.
>> HE JUST WANTS TO SIT BACK
>> MY FAVORITE IS HE GIVES IT
ALL ON 17 INCHES, I QUIT.
>> HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHERE
EVERYTHING IS FUN TO WATCH.
HE IS UNIQUE.
HE HAS FUN DOING IT.
ALWAYS A SMILE ON JOHNNY'S FACE.
>> HE HAS A LOT OF FUN.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THAT GUYS
INSTAGRAM?
IT IS AWKWARD.
>> HE HAS SOME FUN.
WITH THE HORSES AND THE
CHICKENS, AND THE OVERALL, BARE
FEET, RUNNING AROUND, HE IS JUST
A REAL FUNNY GUY.
HE DOESN'T TALK A WHOLE LOT.
HE IS NOT THE GUY IN THE
CLUBHOUSE THAT'S LIKE A BIG
TALKER.
BUT HE HAS A LOT OF THAT HE IS
ANIMATED, BUT IT MAKES HIM WHO
HE IS, AND IT WORKS.
HE'S A GREAT GUY FOR THE TEAM.
>> HERE'S MY IDEA.
A SHOW WHERE HE DOESN'T SAY A
WORD, AND IT IS NARRATED BY
SOMEONE LIKE VIN SCULLY.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> YASTRZEMSKI ON THAT ONE.
>> OUT OF PLAY.
>> SCOTT, LET'S NOT FORGET, AND
MID-THE FUN, HOW GREAT HE WAS
FURTHER ROYALS AND THAT 2015
SEASON AND THE WORLD SERIES.
ON THE GRANDEST STAGE WE HAVE IN
OUR SPORT, ICE IN HIS VEINS.
HE IS SO CALM, SO COMPOSED, AND
THE REASON WHY THE ROYALS WON
THE WORLD SERIES THAT YEAR.
>> THAT WAS THEIR BIG PICKUP.
>> THAT IS IN TIGHT TO
YASTRZEMSKI.
>> THREE BALLS AND TWO STRIKES.
JOHNNY CUETO, THAT MAGICAL
WHEELS D -- THAT MAGICAL ROYALS
D, THE WORLD SERIES, $30 MILLION
WITH THE GIANTS, PAYOFF, MISSES,
BALL FOUR.
NEXT YEAR THERE IS AN OPTION.
$22 MILLION, $5 MILLION BUYOUT.
17 MILL NEXT YEAR.
5.5, WORKING HIS WAY BACK FROM
INJURY.
WE KNOW WHAT HE IS CAPABLE OF.
AGES UP THERE.
THAT IS A QUALIFYING OFFER.
SAW SAN FRANCISCO PICK UP.
VERY DIFFERENT STARTER.
JUST THINKING AHEAD TO NEXT
YEAR, WHAT YOU WOULD DO WITH
JOHNNY JEREMY -- WITH JOHNNY AND
JEREMY.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF YEAR
WHERE HE ABSOLUTELY HAS TO --
YOU ARE TALKING $22 MILLION, AND
I KNOW THAT IS NOT ROLLING
AROUND IN BASEBALL.
IT IS A LOT OF MONEY.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO -- ON THE
STAFF COME ON THE TEAM, I HAVE
TO HAVE A GUY THAT -- 22 MILLION
FULTON IS HE GOING TO GIVE ME 35
STARTS?
SIX INNINGS?
OR 30 STARTS WITH SIX INNINGS.
CAN HE PRODUCE WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT FOR 22 MILLION?
IF HE CANNOT, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
I WANT TO GET RID OF HIM.
IT JUST MEANS RE-SIGNING FOR 10
OR WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO.
FOR ME, I KNOW WHAT MY OPTION
IS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO TALK TO ME ABOUT
IT.
AND JOHNNY CUETO IS GOING TO BE
HANGING OUT RIGHT NOW, AND THIS
CONVERSATION, AFTER STEPPING
ASIDE JUST FOR A MOMENT,
REPLACING MICHAEL FELIZ FOR THE
GIANTS IN THE THIRD.
>> THE REDS WERE A POWERHOUSE IN
1970.
>> THEY GOT THE NICKNAME TO
MATCH.
>> THE BIG RED MACHINE.
THE BOOK OF THE BIG RED MACHINE.
>> JOHNNY WAS MAGNIFICENT.
>> BEST YEAR EVER.
>> HAD TO CALL A GREAT GAME.
>> JOHNNY BENCH WITH THE CALL.
>> WOULD HAVE BEEN INTERESTING.
>> I REMEMBER FACING HIM,
AGAINST THAT SCOREBOARD.
I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO KNOCK
IT DOWN.
>> THE REDS WON THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE PENNANT IN 1970, AND WITH
45 HOME RUNS, 140 R.B.I..
AND WAS THE LEAGUE'S MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER FOR TOP HE WAS
22 YEARS OLD AND WAS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST SPORTS STARS IN AMERICA.
.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS ABOUT THE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS, YOU SEE IT
RIGHT HERE.
THE SECOND LOWEST STARTING
PITCHING, IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
AS GREAT AS THEY HAVE BEEN, >>
GOOD CALL.
ALL THE SUCCESS THIS YEAR, I
KNOW THE FOCUS FOR THE GIANTS'S
-- LET'S SEE WHAT WE ARE MADE OF
IN 2021.
THEN WE WILL WORRY ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE OFF-SEASON, AND
RYAN HENDRIX REPLACES MICHAEL
FELIZ.
THEY SCORE SEVEN IN HIS THIRD
INNING, AND WE CONTINUE WITH HIS
SECOND TRIP TO THE PLATE IN THIS
FRAME.
BUT HE HAD TO PUT A BOW ON,
STARTING THE CONVERSATION.
I WILL SAY THIS, JEREMY.
THE GIANTS ARE A TEAM THAT HAS
SHOWN THE ABILITY TO EXPAND THE
PAYROLL IN THE PAST WHEN THEY
ARE READY TO ROLL, SO WITH THAT
FLEXIBILITY, THAT IS A KEYWORD
IN THE BAY AREA.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM GO AFTER
PLAYERS IN A TRADE.
BRYCE HARPER IN FREE AGENCY.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE GOING FOR
IT, ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT THIS
TEAM IS PUT TOGETHER IN THE
FIRST COUPLE OF MONTHS OF THE
SEASON.
>> WHAT HAS HURT A LOT OF TIMES
WITH THE OFFENSIVE PLAY
OPPOSITION, THAT -- TO RIGHT --
IT IS GONE INTO THE SEATS, ABOUT
THE THIRD ROW, SECOND HOME RUN
OF THE INNING FOR THE GIANTS.
A TWO-RUN SHOT TO MAKE IT 10-0.
TO ME, THERE AT THE POINT WHERE
-- LIKE HE SAID, HE TALKED ABOUT
IT A LITTLE EARLIER.
JUST I LIKE IS AT BAT, AND IN
THIS BALLPARK YOU CAN HIT THE
BALL OUT, THE BALL IS RIGHT ON
THE BLACK, SLIDER, HE CONNECTED
WITH THAT AND THAT BALL WILL GET
OUT, ESPECIALLY IN A DAY GAME.
LIKE I WAS SAYING EARLIER ON THE
OFFENSE, THE MAID THAT IN SAN
FRANCISCO PLAYABLE FOR NOT ONLY
PITCHERS -- YOU MAKE GOOD
PITCHES, YOU MAKE OUTS.
YOU MAKE BAD TOUCHES, THE GUYS
HAVE A CHANCE TO HIT IT OUT OF
THE BALLPARK.
THEY FEEL THEY CAN PUT UP THE
SAME NUMBERS, PUT IT ELSEWHERE.
THAT BAR -- THAT BALLPARK WAS SO
HARD TO HIT IN, AND NOW IT MAY
BE MORE ENTICING FOR ALL
ATHLETES, PLAYERS COMING TO THIS
BALLPARK IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT HAS BEEN FREE AGENCY FOR
THE GIANTS.
>> CUT AND A MISS FROM CRAWFORD.
THEY TOOK THE FIRST THREE GAMES
FROM CINCINNATI, AND NOW THEY
ARE UP 10-0.
>> CLOSE TO THE 34-MINUTE MARK,
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HAVE TO WAKE
UP JOHNNY CUETO TO PUT HIM BACK
ON THE MOUND.
THING NINE PLUS RUNS -- NINE
PLUS RUNS THIS SEASON.
THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
THE OFFENSE FROM THIS TEAM.
>> ALSO AGAINST COLORADO, A
10-RUN INNING.
NINE SO FAR.
THE SHOT WE JUST SAW FROM --
2-2 FROM HENDRICKS.
COUNT IS FULL.
THE STARTING PITCHING, WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW GREAT THEIR DEFENSE
IS.
IT UP THESE RUNS, IS PRETTY GOOD
HAVING THAT ABILITY TO PITCH AND
HIT IN THE SAME GAME.
PRETTY DANGEROUS.
AND CRAWFORD IS DOWN.
GOOD ONE THERE.
GOOD AGAINST A TWO RUN BLAST.
GOOD RUN FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
THEY DOCK -- THEY KNOCKED OUT
RELIEVER MICHAEL FELIZ.
STEVEN DUGGAR IS THE BIG MANT, .
THE GIANTS UP 10-0.
>> DUGGAR IS GOING TO MAKE A
DIVING CATCH.
NICE PLAY, STEVEN DUGGAR.
THAT GUY CAN PLAY CENTER FIELD.
>> WATCHES THE BALL ALL THE WAY
INTO THE GLOVE.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM DO THAT QUITE A
BIT.
THE BOOK 09 FROM THE GIANTS IN
THE TOP OF THE THIRD.
IT IS A RED --
>> NINE FROM THE GIANTS IN THE
TOP OF THE REDS' TURN TO BAT.
THEY CAN GET BACK AND GET A HUGE
COMEBACK, RIGHT?
JOHNNY CUETO, STRIKE.
>> THIS BALLPARK, YOU NEVER
KNOW, RIGHT?
COLORADO, THAT IS A PLACE WHERE
THERE ARE A LOT OF RUNS.
THIS PLACE GIVES UP A LOT, TOO.
AND THE REDS -- YOU RUN THIS
BALLPARK JUST LIKE COLORADO.
YOU DON'T PLAY LIKE YOU ARE AT
-- LIKE YOU ARE UP 10 NOTHING IN
ST. LOUIS.
YOU HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS GAME ALL THE WAY OUT, AND
YOU START GETTING A LITTLE LAX,
THE BALL OVER THE PLATE, LET HIM
HIT IT, YOU HAVE TO PITCH THIS
ENTIRE GAME.
CANNOT GET OUT AHEAD, AND THE
REDS HAVE THE ABILITY.
>> THE REDS ACCOUNT ALSO, GLASS
HALF-FULL.
IN THE COMMENTARY AREA.
SCORED 10 RUNS, HIGHEST TOTAL IN
THE MAJORS.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
OPTIMISM, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SCORE THEM ALL
RIGHT NOW, EITHER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SCORE 10 RUNS
IN THIS INNING, EVEN NINE.
JUST TECH AWAY.
YOU HOPE TO TAKE AWAY A COUPLE
HERE AND THERE, CRICK NUMBERS,
SEE WHERE YOU ARE AT THE END OF
THE GAME.
I WILL SAY THIS, JEREMY.
IN ADDITION TO THE REDS OFFENSE,
A SIGNIFICANT BRIGHT SPOT,
IMPROVEMENT FROM THEM FROM LAST
SEASON TO THIS YEAR.
THE WEAK SPOT FOR SAN FRANCISCO,
PLAYING FOR THE BEST TEAM IN
BASEBALL, CUETO FIRES LOW.
>> IT IS THE BULLPEN, THE UPS
AND DOWNS FROM IT.
>> YEAH, THAT IS THE CASE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FRONT
OFFICE, I AM FOCUSING ON -- I'M
NOT SAYING THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH.
IT HAS KIND OF BEEN A LITTLE BIT
-- YOU DON'T HAVE YET, FROM WHAT
I CAN SEE, YOU DO NOT HAVE THREE
OR FOUR GUYS THAT IT'S LIKE,
GUARANTEED YOU ARE GOING OUT AND
THIS GAME IS OVER.
YOU DON'T HAVE A TEAM IN
BASEBALL THAT IS -- TWO RUNS,
THESE GUYS COME IN, THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT QUITE YET.
I JUST FEEL LIKE IF I AM GOING
INTO THE SECOND HALF, I HAVE TO
GO OUT AND GET SOME GUYS THAT I
KNOW ARE GOING TO BRING IN THAT
WILL SEAL THE DEAL.
IT IS OVER, CONSISTENT, I KNOW
WHAT I HAVE EVERY TIME I GO OUT,
AND PUTS THESE TEAMS UP A LITTLE
BIT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE THAT
QUITE YET.
FIND ONE OR TWO GUYS I THINK.
>> I MEAN, THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR
CORE FOR.
AS THEIR CORE FOUR.
>> I WANTED TO, BUT, HEY, I
WANTED TO BRING ALL THAT.
THE OTHER WAY, SPLITS THE GAP,
AND HE IS IN BUSINESS.
DOUBLE TO LEAD OFF THE BOTTOM OF
THE THIRD FOR THE REDS.
>> BUT LET'S GUSH OVER THE GOOD
STUFF WITH THE GIANTS RIGHT NOW.
ALEX BRINGING IT IN WITH A .17 5
-- A 1.75 E.R.A..
1.66.
HE WAS GREAT AGAIN YESTERDAY.
BEST IN BASEBALL SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
>> THEY ALSO SET A RECORD IN THE
FIRST MONTH OF THE SEASON.
I WILL GIVE YOU THAT IN A
MOMENT.
HARD ON THE GROUND.
LAST MONTH, THE GIANTS BECAME
THE FIRST TEAM IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES, WITH THE LOWEST
ROTATION E.R.A.
>> THOSE THREE GUYS, 13-1.
I AM NOT A G.M.
I PLAY ONE ON YOUTUBE.
KEVIN GAUSMAN, MULTIYEAR DEAL
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SAN FRANCISCO ARE EAGER.
SOME SAID I DON'T KNOW.
WE SAW WHAT HE DID WITH
CINCINNATI.
HE HAS FOUND SOMETHING.
IT HAS CLICKED.
>> THAT IS WHAT THE GIANTS DID
BY THE QUALIFYING OFFER.
THEY WANTED TO SEE DID HE REALLY
HAVE IT?
HE IS SHOWING HE IS WORTH IT.
HE WILL GO DEEP INTO THE
BALLGAMES FOR YOU.
HE TOOK THE QUALIFYING OFFER.
HOW DO THESE TEAMS MISS THE
OTHER GUYS?
THESE GUYS HAVE COME IN, THIS IS
AN IMPRESSIVE THREE GUYS.
NOT TO JUST HAVE A TANDEM START
BUT THREE GUYS TO GO OUT AND
GIVE YOU THAT?
THAT DOES A LOT.
THAT RELAXES AND ALLOWS THE
OFFENSE AND DEFENSE TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
>> SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE GAME PLAN.
PITCHERS COME OVER, THE GIANTS
PLAY A DIFFERENT SET OF INFO.
GROUND BALL PERCENTAGE, TOP IN
BASEBALL.
WE HAVE SEEN QUITE A FEW HOME
RUNS OUT OF THAT BALLPARK OUT
WEST.
THE GIANTS ARE SMACKING THE BALL
ALL OVER THE YARD.
THE PITCHERS ARE NOT GIVING IT
UP.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE GROUND
BALLS.
ONE OF THE BEST IN FIELD
FORMATIONS IN BASEBALL.
GABE KAPLER NOT DOING THE WHOLE
ANALYTIC THING ALL THE TIME.
>> WINKER BOUNCES OUT.
WE WILL TALK TO KEVIN GAUSMAN IN
THE NEXT HALF INNING.
LOAD UP THOSE QUESTIONS, YOUTUBE
CREATORS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE ON THE GIANTS?
J.P.: CONTACTS FOR THAT CONTRACT
OFFER.
SARAH LANGS WROTE A GREAT STORY
RECENTLY ABOUT KEVIN GAUSMAN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, KEVIN
GAUSMAN THIS YEAR HAS 2-4 MOST
VALUABLE PITCHES IN TERMS OF
EXPECTED RUN VALUE IN ALL MLB.
FOUR-SEAMER AND SPLIT-FINGER
FASTBALL.
>> CRAZY.
>> THAT HELPS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT SPLIT.
IT IS A LOT LIKE ROGER CLEMENS.
HE WOULD THROW THAT FASTBALL LOW
WITH THE SPLIT OFF.
GUYS COULD NOT DIFFERENTIATE.
SIMILAR SCENARIO.
HITTERS HAVE TO COMMIT.
YOU CAN'T NOT BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> IT IS EASY TO THROW DOWNHILL.
>> GOOD POINT.
>> IT WAS HARDER FOR US.
>> CASTELLANOS UP THE MIDDLE.
THE REDS BREAK THE ICE.
THEIR FIRST RUNNER COMES IN,
SCORING OFF THE SINGLE FROM
NICK.
10-1.
>> CASTELLANOS STILL GIVING GOOD
AT-BATS OUT HERE, DOING THIS ALL
YEAR.
HE HAS BEEN BARRELING UP TO SO
MANY BALLS.
HIS POWER IS RIGHT CENTER.
AMAZING.
COMING IN TODAY, HE IS HITTING
.424.
>> NO BIG DEAL.
KEVIN GAUSMAN JOINING US SOON.
QUESTIONS FOR KEVIN.
LET US KNOW.
THE AT-BAT QUALITY FOR NICK
CASTELLANOS THIS YEAR.
IT KEEPS GETTING BETTER.
IN THE MONTH OF MAY, HE IS
NOTICING SOMETIMES PITCHERS
DON'T WANT TO GIVE HIM MUCH.
STEVENSON SENDS ONE TO THE GAP
IN LEFT CENTER.
CASTELLANOS WILL RACE AROUND AND
STOP AT THIRD.
TWO OUT DOUBLE FOR STEVENSON.
NOT ENOUGH FOR NICK TO GO HOME
BUT THE REDS HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO THIS AFTERNOON.
>> PUTTING UP THE CROOKED
NUMBERS.
SEE WHERE IT TAKES YOU.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF WORK.
I HAVE TO BEAR DOWN.
IF I'M NOT CAREFUL, THESE BALLS
WILL SPEED OUT OF THE BALLPARK
AND IT CANNOT GET OUT OF HAND.
I HAVE SEEN IT HAPPEN AT THIS
BALLPARK.
I HAVE PLAYED AGAINST IT.
JOHNNY KNOWS THIS.
HE UNDERSTANDS THE SITUATION.
THIS IS A BIG AT-BAT FOR HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> TYLER NAQUIN SWINGING OUT OF
HIS SHOES.
A PAIR OF DOUBLES AND IN R.B.I.
SINGLE.
TWO STRIKES AGAINST NAQUIN.
11 HOMERS FOR CASTELLANOS, NINE
FOR NAQUIN, EIGHT FOR WINKER.
MOST COMBINED OUTFIELDERS IN
BASEBALL.
THEY THROW THE BASEBALL ALL OVER
THE FIELD.
>> SEEMS LIKE NAQUIN HIT ALL
THOSE HOME RUNS THREE GAMES IN A
ROW.
I REMEMBER THIS GUY IN
CLEVELAND.
HE HAS GOT SO MUCH.
>> LAST YEAR, TYLER WAS THE GUY
IN THE OUTFIELD.
HE WAS PRODUCING FOR CLEVELAND.
THEY DIDN'T KEEP HIM.
SIGNED UP WITH CINCINNATI ON A
MINOR LEAGUE CONTRACT.
NOW, IN A REDS UNIFORM.
>> HE WAS PLAYING BECAUSE WINKER
WAS OUT.
HE WASN'T EVEN STARTING.
>> THE NUMBERS STILL SHINY.
HOW CAN YOU SIT THIS GUY?
EXCELLENT NUMBERS.
>> HE HAS TO BE CAREFUL.
YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER THIS GUY.
YOU WANT TO -- THE REDS ARE
PROBABLY HOPING TO WAKE HIM UP.
THIS IS NOT AN EASY LINEUP TO GO
THROUGH.
YOU ARE FACING A GUY WITH OUR --
WITH POWER.
>> FOUL.
SUAREZ, 0-1 TODAY.
THAT IS WHAT DAVID BELL TOLD US
YESTERDAY.
PLEASE A NICE THIRD BASE,
SHORTSTOP.
GOOD A.B. FROM NAQUIN TO STAY
ALIVE.
CASTELLANOS AND STEVENSON ON THE
BASES.
JOHNNY CUETO DIALS UP WITH THE
COUNT, FULL.
GOT HIM.
GREAT PITCH.
BIG-TIME CHANGEUP FROM JOHNNY
HE USES IT TO ESCAPE.
ONE RUN TO THE REDS.
GIANTS 10-1.
>> CUSTODY ON BOTH KILLS IT --
CASTELLANOS KILLS IT.
CASTELLANOS TIES THE GAME.
HIGH FLY FROM INDIA, GONE!
JONATHAN INDIA, THREE RUN HOMER!
>> HE SHOOTS IT TO CENTER FIELD.
ALL THE WAY TO THE FENCE.
BASE CLEARING DOUBLE.
HE DELIVERS.
THAT IS SPANKED INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
TWO RUN SINGLE.
SIX RUN INNING.
REDS, SEVEN, PIRATES, ONE.
HIGH IN THE AIR, DEEP LEFT
FIELD, BOMBER!
THE GO-AHEAD HOME RUN!
THE REDS TAKE A 4-2 LEAD IN THE
11TH INNING.
CASTELLANOS SENDS IT TO RIGHT.
CASTELLANOS, RUN-SCORING DOUBLE.
>> IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK.
CINCINNATI THIS WEEK.
WHICH ALL-TIME MLB SUPERPOWER
WOULD YOU MOST LIKE TO HAVE?
HOLD YOUR ANSWERS.
ENTER THEM IN.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST JOINING
US NOW FOR OUR NEXT HALF INNING
FROM THE DUGOUT, KEVIN GAUSMAN.
THE GIANTS ARE UP BIG, 10-1.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WHICH SUPERPOWER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO POSSESS?
KEVIN: I WOULD HAVE TO GO WITH
POWER.
THAT IS ONE THING I AM LACKING.
DEFINITELY.
SEE HOW FAR I COULD HIT A
BASEBALL.
>> EXCELLENT CHOICE.
AMY SAYS THE GIANTS WERE NOT IN
DISCUSSION TO BE LEADING THE
WEST.
THAT ONE IS SHOT INTO RIGHT.
CONTACT OFF THE BAT OF LONGORIA.
AMY G, WHO KNOWS THIS TEAM WELL,
AND YOU KNOW HER, SHE FOLLOWS A
TEAM ON A DAILY BASIS AND HAS
SEEN HISTORIC SEASON FOR THE
GIANTS.
SAN FRANCISCO IS LEAVING THE
WEST.
WHAT IS THE TALK IN THE
CLUBHOUSE?
KEVIN: THE CLUBHOUSE IS JUST
KIND OF KEEP OUR HEAD DOWN AND
WORRY ABOUT OURSELVES.
WITH THIS OFF-SEASON, THE
DODGERS AND PADRES, EVERYTHING
THEY DID, EVERYONE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THEM FOR GOOD REASON.
FROM DAY ONE, SPRING TRAINING,
GUYS, WE FELT LIKE, LAST YEAR WE
PLAYED SOME OF OUR BEST GAMES
AGAINST THE DODGERS.
WE FELT REALLY CONFIDENT.
WE FELT CONFIDENT WE HAVE PLAYED
SOME OF OUR BEST AGAINST THEM.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE WOULD BE SURPRISED.
A LOT OF YOUNG GUYS TRYING TO
ESTABLISH THEMSELVES WITH
VETERAN GUYS.
DOING INCREDIBLE THINGS.
IT IS FUN.
>> I HAVE HAD A LOT OF FUN
WATCHING YOUR PITCHING.
WHAT IS IT BEEN GOING THROUGH
ROUTINES?
THE GIANTS CLICK DIFFERENTLY.
IS IT THE PREPARATION?
ANALYTICS?
WHAT IS IT IN THIS UNIFORM YOU
FEEL DIFFERENTLY WHEN YOU TAKE
THE MOUND?
KEVIN: FROM DAY ONE, THEY SIGNED
ME TWO YEARS AGO, HEY WE WANTED
TO KEEP DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND WE WILL PAY YOU.
VIA A TWO PITCH PITCHER.
I HAVE HAD PITCHING COACHES THAT
ALWAYS SAID YOU REALLY NEED TO
WORK ON THAT SLIDER.
ALL THESE LITTLE THINGS.
IN THE BIG SCHEME OF THINGS,
THESE WERE HUGE THINGS IN MY
DEVELOPMENT BUT YOU KNOW, NOT
TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH.
NOT GETTING CAUGHT UP IN THIS
GUY CANNOT HIT SLIDERS WELL SO I
WILL THROW SLIDERS.
THE SHORTENED SEASON LAST YEAR
HAD SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT.
I GOT THE 10 STARTS.
JUST GO OUT AND PITCH WITH MY
STRENGTHS.
WHATEVER HAPPENS HAPPENS.
STUCK WITH THAT PLAN.
REALLY IT HAS MADE MY BREAKING
BALL BETTER.
KIND OF WEIRD.
I RARELY THROW IT.
YOU KNOW, OUR CATCHERS HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT.
YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE BUSTER POSEY
BACK THERE, HE IS CONSTANTLY
MANAGING.
YOU FEEL CONFIDENT HAVING THOSE
GUYS BACK THERE.
>> WITH THAT, OUR QUESTION FROM
OUR YOUTUBE CREATOR, JUSTIN
RIGHT, HOW BIG IS IT HAVING HIM
BEHIND THE PLATE?
KEVIN: HUGE.
PITCH CALLING, WHAT HE IS DOING
AT THE DISH THIS YEAR, JUST
CRAZY.
MOST GUYS TOOK THE YEAR OFF.
NOT HIM.
JUST HAVING HIM BACK THERE GIVES
YOU A GOOD SENSE OF CONFIDENCE.
HE HAS SEEN EVERY PITCH AND
CAUGHT EVERY PITCH.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SURPRISE
HIM.
HE IS ALWAYS THINKING OUT THE
BOX AND TRYING TO BE ONE STEP
AHEAD.
>> DUBON TAKES A PITCH ON THE
CORNER.
THAT WILL RETIRE THE SIDE.
NEXT DOUBLE PLAY, BLANDINO WILL
STAY ON THE BAG.
KEVIN GAUSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
LOVE THE INSIGHT.
GOOD LUCK.
KEVIN: THANK YOU GUYS.
>> ON.
THE WHISTLEBLOWING.
IT MUST BE TIME.
>> I'M DEFTLY AN ANALYTICAL --
>> HE IS METHODICAL, JUST LIKE
HIS GRANDFATHER.
>> HE TAUGHT ME A LOT.
YOU HAVE A GOAL.
TAKE OUT THE TRASH.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT LESSON HIS
GRANDFATHER TAUGHT HIM.
IT IS ONE THAT TOOK HIM A WHILE
TO APPRECIATE.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS OR
THAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
>> THE FAMILY TREE IS WHAT
AMERICA IS ALL ABOUT.
A MELTING POT OF TEXANS.
HE TOOK A DNA TEST AND
DISCOVERED HE IS 12% AFRICAN.
THAT IS HIS GRANDFATHER'S
LEGACY.
>> EVERYONE IS WHO THEY ARE.
IF YOU LOVE ONE ANOTHER, IF YOUR
REACTION TO THE OTHER PERSON IS
RESPECT, THERE WILL NEVER BE ANY
ISSUES.
>> LAST OF THE FOURTH, GIANTS UP
BY NINE.
HE HAS TIED BUMGARNER.
NEXT UP, CHRISTY MATHEWSON,
EIGHT IN A ROW, 1901.
KEVIN GAUSMAN IS A GUY YOU COULD
TALK TO FOR HOURS ABOUT
PITCHING.
HIS PROGRESSION ON THE MOUND,
HAS TWO OF THE NASTIEST PITCHES
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT I SAW FROM HIM, HIS
FASTBALL, THEY COME OFF THAT
SAME PLAN.
WHEN YOU COMMAND THAT FASTBALL,
THAT RELEASE, YOU ACTUALLY WILL
GET A BETTER BREAKING BALL
BECAUSE YOUR BREAKING BALL COMES
OFF THE FASTBALL.
YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO THROW A
BREAKING BALL.
IF HE STARTS GETTING GOOD
RELEASE POINT, THIS BREAKING
BALL WILL GET BETTER.
>> DICKERSON CLOSED IN ON THAT
BASEBALL FOR THE FIRST OUT.
JOHNNY CUETO COMING OFF A THREE
PITCH THIRD INNING.
THE REDS MADE HIM WORK AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE FRAME.
THIS IS KYLE FARMER.
PITCH 70.
1-1.
JOHNNY CUETO WITH A WIDE VARIETY
OF DELIVERIES.
>> AMAZING THE DIFFERENT LOOKS
HE GIVES.
WHAT IMPRESSES ME IS IT IS HARD
ENOUGH TO PITCH.
GUYS DO A QUICK PITCH TO KEEP
THE RUNNER CLOSE.
HE DOES IT FROM THE WIND UP AND
WITH HIS OFFSPEED.
QUICK PITCH, USUALLY YOU ARE
THROWING FASTBALL.
HE DOES IT WITH HIS OFFSPEED.
AMAZING TO BALANCE.
>> SUPER.
HITTERS AND THE SHIMMY RIGHT
HERE.
COMES OFF WITH A CHANGEUP OFF
THE SHIMMY.
THE HITTER HAS TO DECIDE.
AS HE GOES, THE GUYS LOADING.
HE LETS THE BALL GO.
HE IS ALREADY COMMITTED IN HIS
BRAIN.
>> THAT ONE HANGS UP FOR
DICKERSON.
CUETO, THE GUM ALMOST
FELL OUT OF HIS MOUTH DURING THE
SHIMMY SHAKE.
>> BASEBALL GENIUS WHO
POSITIONED THE GIANTS.
>> YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
IN CONTROL.
>> WILLIE MAYS, THE SAY HEY KID.
WINNING THE WORLD SERIES AT 23
TO HIS LAST HIT AT 42.
HE IS TURNING 90 YEARS OLD THIS
YEAR.
>> WILLIE MAYS!
>> THIS IS A KID'S GAME.
IT IS DESIGNED TO BE FUN.
PLAY WELL AND ENJOY BASEBALL.
IT IS NEVER BETTER.
>> EACH WEEK THIS SEASON WE WILL
FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR.
TODAY, OUR CREATIVE SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON HEALY6.
53,000 SUBSCRIBERS.
HIS FAVORITE MOMENT WAS THE CUBS
WINNING THE WORLD SERIES IN '16.
ALEX HEALY, WE WILL TALK TO YOU
IN JUST A BIT.
>> I WONDER WHAT HE THOUGHT
ABOUT THE GRAND SLAM?
>> LOOK AT HIM GO.
427 FEET.
ABSOLUTE SMASH.
PART OF A NINE RUN INNING FOR
SAN FRANCISCO.
10-1.
DUGGAR LEADS OFF THE FIFTH.
KEITH EMBRY, NEW MAN ON THE
MOUND FOR CINCINNATI.
HERE WE GO IN THE FIFTH.
-- HEATH HEMBREE.
I CANNOT FATHOM 427 FEET.
>> THE WINDOW STOPPED IT.
>> 427 IS A BIG DEAL.
>> THAT IS A LONG WAY.
IT IS.
I FELT LIKE IT WAS LONGER.
>> HEMBREE, X GIANT.
>> HE CAME UP WITH THE GIANTS.
>> HE CAN THROW A FASTBALL.
HE HAS DONE REALLY WELL FOR
HIMSELF.
IN PRETTY BIG GAMES.
CRAWFORD GOT HIM.
THEY WERE MINOR LEAGUE
TEAMMATES.
GOOD TO WATCH HIM TAKE OFF.
HE HAS DONE VERY WELL FOR
HIMSELF.
>> HE SEEMS TO HAVE THAT
EFFORTLESS GAS.
HE IS NOT TRYING THROW HARD BUT
IT JUMPS OUT OF HIS HAND.
>> DUGGAR CONNECTS, OTHER WAY.
BIG DAY FOR STEVEN DUGGAR.
LEADOFF BASE RUNNER FOR SAN
FRANCISCO.
WE HAVE TO GET YOUR RESPONSES.
DON'T GO OFF WHAT THE CROWD
SAID.
WHICH SUPERPOWER WOULD YOU MOST
LIKE TO HAVE?
KEVIN GAUSMAN SAID POWER.
JENNY GRAVES?
-- DANNY GRAVES?
>> I KNEW YOU WERE COMING TO ME
FIRST.
I AM TORN.
RICKEY HENDERSON.
I DON'T DRIVE FAST.
I WOULD LOVE TO RUN FAST.
>> NICE.
>> THAT IS GOOD.
>> I THOUGHT SPEED WAS
OVERRATED.
>> YEAH I KNOW.
>> FOR ME, TO BE A GOLD GLOVER
-- CRAWFORD MAKES IT LOOK EASY.
IT LOOKS SUPERCOOL WHEN YOU ARE
OUT THERE.
LIKE A SHORTSTOP.
>> RICKY WAS COOL.
HE WOULD TELL YOU HOW COOL HE
WAS.
HE WAS FAST.
>> RICKY WAS REAL FAST.
>> I LOVE WATCHING RICKY.
>> I LOVE THE LISTENING TO
RICKY.
>> RICKY, REFERRING TO
HIMSELF IN THE THIRD PERSON.
2-1.
YOU ARE FORMER BALLPLAYERS.
MOST PEOPLE ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION THOUGHT BABE RUTH WAS
AWESOME.
HE IS THE LEGEND.
THE EASIEST WAY FOR ME TO GET TO
THE SHOW -- IF I HAVE BABE RUTH
POWER, I WILL BE IN THE BIGS.
I AM MAKING IT SOMEHOW.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
TOO MANY GUYS NOWADAYS HAVE
POWER.
THE FASTBALL, EVERYONE THROWS
HARD.
I WANT SOME SPEED.
>> BUT BABE RUTH WAS ALSO A GOOD
PITCHER.
>> FOR A TIME, HE WAS.
>> HE HAD SOME NO-HITTERS.
>> HE THREW A NO-HITTER.
>> I AM SURE HE DID.
>> I DID IT.
>> I THINK HE DID IT IN THE BIG
LEAGUES, THOUGH.
>> I THINK HE WAS A GOOD PLAYER.
>> OUCH.
>> CASALI TAKES ONE OFF HIS LEFT
ELBOW.
HE IS DOWN.
>> THAT DEFINITELY DID NOT FEEL
GOOD.
>> WITH THE DAY OFFER BUSTER,
YOU HOPE USE GOING TO BE OK.
>> HE WILL DO EVERYTHING HE CAN
TO STAY IN.
THE TOUGHNESS HE HAS, DOES NOT
EVER WANT TO COME OUT.
>> THAT IS DAVE, THE TRAINER FOR
THE GIANTS.
HE ALWAYS HAD THE TOUGHEST JOB.
HE TRIES TO HELP YOU.
YOU EVER NOTICE THE TRAINER
HAVING TO CHASE THE PLAYER
AROUND?
GIVE ME YOUR HAND.
LET ME SEE IT.
THEY PULL IT.
SO EMBARRASSING.
>> TRAINERS, HERE IN CINCINNATI,
BACK IN THE DAY, RUN OUT TO THE
FIELD, THE PLAYERS WAVE THEM
OFF, NO NO, THEN YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK OUT.
IF I'M GOING OUT TO THE FIELD, I
AM NOT GOING TO STOP AND TURN
AROUND.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO GET SHOOED
OFF.
OK FINE, I WILL GO BACK.
>> YOU CAN SEE WHERE THAT
BASEBALL LANDED.
THERE IS A BIG CIRCULAR MARK ON
HIS ELBOW.
LET'S GO BACK.
>> THAT IS KIND OF ON THE BONE,
THAT LOOKED LIKE.
>> THAT IS GOING TO STIFFEN UP.
HE MIGHT PLAY THE REST OF THE
GAME BUT --
>> UNFORTUNATE HE HAS TO JUMP ON
A PLANE.
THAT ALTITUDE.
>> I THINK HE IS TRYING NOT TO
RUB IT.
>> CUETO FLAILS AND MISSES AND
STRIKES OUT.
SECOND TIME TO DAVID >> J.P.
MOROSI IS AT THE PARK.
>> JEREMY HAS A GREAT
RECOLLECTION OF THIS YEAR.
2012 WORLD SERIES CRAWFORD
MADE ONE GAME CHANGING PLAY
AFTER ANOTHER.
A FEW YEARS LATER WHEN JIM
LEYLAND MANAGED THE BASEBALL
CLASSIC, BRANDON CRAWFORD WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST NAMES.
HIS RUN PRODUCTION, ABSOLUTE
PROFESSIONAL.
THE NEXT SPRING, HE WAS TRADED.
>> CRAWFORD.
HE WAS AWESOME.
SO MUCH CONFIDENCE.
UNBELIEVABLE PLACE.
GAME SEVEN, WORLD SERIES.
CRAWFORD ONE-HANDED IT.
THREW HIM OUT AT FIRST FOR A BIG
DOUBLE PLAY.
HE SAVED SO MANY RUNS, MADE SO
MANY BIG PLAYS.
CRAWFORD IS QUIET.
DOESN'T TALK A LOT.
I TELL YOU WHAT, HE IS AS
TALENTED AS IT GETS.
HE IS PHENOMENAL.
>> HE HAS THE LOOK.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE LINES FROM
LOGAN WEBB HE SAID, I THINK
EVERY TEAM I FACED, THE
SHORTSTOP HAD LONG HAIR BECAUSE
OF BRANDON CRAWFORD.
>> HE HAS THAT LOOK.
HE WILL WET IT DOWN WITH
HAIRSPRAY.
THAT IS NOT NATURAL.
HE HAS GOT IT GOING.
>> HE HAS PRETTY HAIR.
EVERY TIME I WATCH THE GIANTS, I
THINK, I DON'T CARE IF THIS GUY
HITS, I JUST WANT TO SEE HIM
DIVE TO MAKE HIS HAIR FLAIL.
HIS HAIR IS LEGIT.
IT ALWAYS LOOKS PURTY.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT FACIAL HAIR.
>> A LOT OF ENVIOUS SITUATIONS
THERE.
>> I AM ENVIOUS OF YOU RIGHT
NOW.
SCOTT BROUGHT IT UP, JP.
ALL THESE RINGS YOU HAVE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY.
YOU DIDN'T BRING THEM.
>> I FORGOT.
>> I DON'T PULL THEM OUT THAT
OFTEN.
THE ONE WITH COLORADO TOO.
>> I WAS WITH YOU IN SPRING
TRAINING THAT YEAR.
>> I REMEMBER THAT.
>> WE WERE ALL KIND OF RANDOM.
>> A LOT OF RANDOM GUYS.
>> NEEDLESS TO SAY, I DIDN'T
MAKE THE TEAM BUT I WAS THERE.
>> WHAT YEAR WAS THAT?
>> 2007.
>> YASTRZEMSKI, THE THIRD TIME
HE HAS WALKED TODAY.
BRANDON CRAWFORD ON-DECK.
THIS COULD BE HIS FINAL SEASON.
THE BIG THREE FOR THE GIANTS.
HOMEGROWN POSITION PLAYERS.
BIG DEAL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A SPECIAL ERA
IN GIANTS BASEBALL.
THE WORLD SERIES RINGS.
IDENTIFIABLE STARS.
POSEY, CRAWFORD, FELT, ALL HAD
GUARANTEED CONTRACTS THAT EXPIRE
AFTER THIS YEAR.
A LOT OF SCENARIOS.
THEY COULD COME BACK.
ESPECIALLY WITH HAVING THE FANS
BACK, GIVES YOU A CHANCE TO
APPRECIATE THAT.
ALL THOSE TEAMS WERE UNIQUE.
THEY HAD GOOD CHARACTERS.
THEY WERE ALL DIFFERENT.
THE HOMEGROWN NATURE OF THE
ROTATION.
SO HOMEGROWN.
BUMGARNER WAS JUST 20 YEARS OLD
IN 2010.
A LOT OF GREAT HISTORY.
DANNY, DON'T FEEL BAD ABOUT
THIS.
YOU MENTIONED BEING A SHORT
STATURE DID RIGHT-HANDED PITCHER
.
NINTH ALL-TIME.
YOU ARE 10 SAVES OUT OF JEFF
BRANTLEY.
AS A FELLOW GUY SHORTER THAN SIX
FEET, I LOOK UP TO YOU.
>> THAT IS AMAZING.
I AM BLUSHING.
>> THAT SKIPS AWAY.
A RUN FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
11-1, GIANTS IN THE FIFTH.
>> THAT IS AMAZING.
AMAZING FIND.
I HAD NO IDEA.
I WILL REMEMBER THAT.
>> ALL-TIME.
A FORMER RED IS ON THE LIST,
JOHN FRANCO.
BILLY WAGNER.
THE TOP RIGHT-HANDER ON THE
LIST, FERNANDO RODNEY, THE
AGELESS.
>> IS HE STILL PITCHING?
>> I FORGOT.
>> HIS LAST OUTING WAS THE 2019
WORLD SERIES, AS I RECALL.
>> I LOVE THAT.
I NEED TO TALK TO J.P. MORGAN.
I AM BLUSHING RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN'T SEE IT.
AMAZING.
>> ALL-TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ALL-TIME UNDER SIX FOOT TEAM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> BIG HEART.
DARIN RUF.
ONE CAREER TRIPLE.
WE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
SEEMS LIKE HE HAS BEEN UP HERE A
LONG TIME.
>> EVERY AT-BAT.
ALWAYS3-2.
>> THIS WILL BE A TOUGH BALLPARK
TO HIT A TRIPLE IN.
>> HE IS FIFTH IN THE MAJORS IN
PLATE APPEARANCES.
TWO ON.
3-2.
FOULED AGAIN.
>> HE DOES HAVE ONE CAREER
TRIPLE.
>> IT WAS PROBABLY IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> OFF THE WALL.
>> TELL ME THERE IS A CHANCE.
>> IT WAS IN WASHINGTON DC.
>> ANOTHER PLACE YOU CAN GET
THEM.
>> HE WILL HAVE PLENTY MORE
CHANCES.
>> I IMAGINE HE IS THINKING
TRIPLE RIGHT NOW.
IF HE SAYS HE IS NOT, HE IS
LYING.
>> I HAVE BEEN THINKING TRIPLE.
I WOULD BE THINKING IT SUMMER.
>> RUF RIPS THAT ONE.
THIS TIME IT IS SUAREZ TO MAKE
THE CATCH.
SAFE AT THIRD IS CASALI.
COMPETITION HERE, DUE TO PLAYER
OF THE GAME, NEW TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK FOR THE 2021 SEASON.
VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER WILL
RECEIVE THE TROPHY.
WHO ARE WE GOING TO CHAT WITH
DURING THE POSTGAME SHOW?
STAY TUNED, LATER ON, YOU
DECIDE, PLAYER OF THE GAME, WITH
SOME POLLING OPTIONS.
CRAWFORD SENDS ONE DEEP RIGHT
FIELD, FORGET ABOUT IT!
BRANDON CRAWFORD!
THREE RUN SHOT!
14-1, SAN FRANCISCO.
>> AMBUSHED.
CHECKING OUT STUFF.
STRAIGHT AMBUSH.
>> SECOND ONE OFF OF HIM IN THIS
SERIES.
HE HIT ONE THE OTHER NIGHT,
COWERING.
FIRST FASTBALL HE SAW, HE HIT IT
TO RIGHT CENTER.
NOW HE MIGHT BE THE TEAM LEADER
IN HOME RUNS.
>> SHOHEI OHTANI IS ON ANOTHER
LEVEL, HE IS AHEAD OF HIM.
>> SHOHEI OHTANI, WHO ALSO CAN
PITCH, HAS 14 ALMONDS.
-- HOME RUNS.
>> IF HE IS NOT WITH ANAHEIM, HE
IS WITH ANAHEIM.
IT IS A QUIET TEAM.
THANK DOES NOT GET TALKED ABOUT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TOUGH
THINGS TO DO.
THAT IS INCREDIBLE HOW THAT GUY
CAN DO THAT.
HE HAS ARM INJURIES BUT IT TAKES
A LOT OUT OF YOUR BODY TO HIT OR
PITCH, LET ALONE HIT AND PITCH.
>> HE PLAYS RIGHT FIELD TOO.
>> THAT IS AMAZING.
ALMOST A PHENOMENON.
AS DIFFICULT AS BASEBALL IS, TO
SEE SOMEONE DO THAT IS CRAZY.
>> WE ARE IN THE FIFTH.
THE GIANTS HAVE A SEASON-HIGH 13
RUNS.
THEY HIT THE 12 MARK TWICE THIS
YEAR.
CRAWFORD PUTS THEM AHEAD.
LONGORIA TO LEFT.
THE SIDE IS RETIRED BY WINKER.
THREE RUNS, BRANDON CRAWFORD,
BIG BAT.
WHAT A SEASON HE HAS HAD.
11 ON THE YEAR.
BEST RECORD IN BASEBALL, SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> NICE GUNS, I'M KIDDING, HAHA.
>> THROW IN THE KITCHEN SINK.
THE BLENDER.
YEAH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> KEEP IT COMING, GUYS.
>> ON A DAY LIKE TODAY, IT IS
NICE TO HAVE JESSE WINKER ON
YOUR SIDE TO KEEP IT LIGHT.
>> HE HAS A TENDENCY.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS HIS PERSONALITY.
THAT IS WHY HE IS SUCH A GOOD
HITTER.
DOESN'T DWELL ON THINGS.
TRIES TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
HAPPY-GO-LUCKY GUY.
>> WHY NOT?
HE HAS BEEN TORCHING THE
BASEBALL THIS SEASON.
LAST YEAR, ONE OF THE WORST
OFFENSES IN THE GAME.
THIS YEAR, ONE OF THE BEST.
IT IS JUST THAT THE GIANTS
PITCHING IS SO GOOD AND IT HAS
BEEN ON TODAY.
THAT HIT BLANDINO AND HE SHAKES
IT OFF.
>> TOUGH TO PLAY A FOUR GAME
SERIES WHEN YOU ARE FACING THE
BEST STARTING E.R.A.
>> THAT IS REVIEWABLE.
>> JOHNNY CUETO IMMEDIATELY, YOU
COULD READ HIS LIPS SAYING "WAS
THAT A FOUL BALL?"
>> HE SOLD IT REALLY WELL.
THE KNOB OF THE BAT, THAT IS IT.
THAT IS IT.
KNOB OF THE BAT.
>> FOUL BALL.
>> PROBLEM IS, IT NEVER LOOKS
GOOD.
>> WOW.
ALMOST.
>> HE IS COMING BACK.
>> IN HIS DEFENSE, MAYBE HE
SHOOK HIS HAND BECAUSE IT
VIBRATED SO MUCH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> EVEN BLANDINO IS WALKING BACK
WITH A SMILE.
>> THAT IS THE THING.
YOU HAVE REPLAY NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO CATCH YOU.
>> YOU CANNOT HACK.
>> COULD THAT HAVE BEEN THE
QUICKEST REPLAY REVIEW IN THE
HISTORY OF REPLAY?
>> IT IS UP THERE.
>> HEADSET ON, HEADSET OFF,
LET'S CONTINUE.
GOLDEN GLOBE WINNER, ALEX
BLANDINO.
>> IF I AM A TEAMMATE, I AM
GETTING A BAG OF ICE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> CUT AND A MISS, NOT HIS BEST
SWING.
>> CUETO PICKS UP THE STRIKEOUT.
JESSE WINKER, OUR PLAYER
SPOTLIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS SEASON.
HE CRUSHES RIGHT-HANDED
PITCHING.
LOVES FASTBALLS.
BEST BATTING AVERAGE IN THE NL.
PLATOON PLAYER, STILL HAS
SOMETHING TO PROVE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT.
JESSE WINKER HAS SHOWN HIMSELF
AS ONE OF THE BEST HITTERS BUT
HE WILL ALSO TAKE HIS BASE.
>> HE IS PATIENT AND SELECTIVE.
SOMETIMES IT GETS HIM IN TROUBLE
.
THERE ARE PITCHES THAT ARE
CLOSE.
THE PATIENT'S HAS BEEN GREAT FOR
HIM -- PATIENCE HAS BEEN GREAT
FOR HIM.
NOW HE WILL GET BETTER AT FACING
LEFTIES ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THE MORE HE GETS UP TO FACE
LEFTIES, THE BETTER HE WILL GET.
>> THE PINCH HITTER HAS A 3-1
COUNT.
LOOK AT CUETO, PICKING UP THE
PACE.
STRIKE TWO.
BACK TO JP.
>> LEADS THE NATIONAL LEAGUE IN
BATTING AVERAGE THIS YEAR.
HE COULD BE A VERY INTRIGUING
POSSIBILITY.
REDS FANS DO NOT WANT TO HEAR
THAT.
A LOT OF OUTFIELDERS THIS SEASON
HAVE HAD DIMINISHED PRODUCTION.
SCOTT, FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
HIS PERSONALITY, HE WAS BORN IN
BUFFALO, NEW YORK, GREW UP AND
REMAINS A FAN OF THE BUFFALO
BILLS.
VERY STRONG CHARACTER BUILDING
ASPECT OF LIFE.
>> SHOGO FLIES OUT TO LEFT.'
YOU THINK JESSE WINKER IS A
TRADE CANDIDATE BASED ON THE
FACT -- THERE IS THE BIRTHPLACE.
ONE OF THE TOP HITTERS IN THE
SPORT THESE DAYS.
DO YOU THINK THE REDS WILL
ENTERTAIN OFFERS?
JP?
STILL THERE?
WINKER SENDS ONE TO LEFT CENTER.
LET'S CABLE THAT.
I PROMISE WE WILL GO BACK TO JP.
A LITTLE
WE WILL GO TO THE SIXTH ON
YOUTUBE.
>> 1-0.
BARRY BONDS.
714 HOMERS.
RIGHT CENTER FIELD, THERE IT IS,
OUT OF HERE!
HE IS NOW TIED WITH THE BABE.
THE GIANTS PLAYERS ARE COMING
OUT OF THE DUGOUT.
BARRY BONDS HAS TIED BABE RUTH.
>> SWINGING?
I WAS I WAS.
HOW ABOUT YOU?
ME?
NAH.
SEE YOU GOT POP.
I RUN.
>> AMAZING.
AMAZING CONTENT RIGHT THERE.
DUBON AND WINKER TALKING.
DUBON SAYS NO.
WINKER SAYS YES.
CARSON IS IN THE GAME FOR
CINCINNATI.
TYLER MAHLE GAVE UP SEVEN RUNS.
DICKERSON, DUBON, DUGGAR, DUE UP
IN THE SIXTH.
I HAVE ANOTHER TOPIC OF THE WEEK
FOR YOU.
STAYS UP.
ONE DOWN IN THE SIXTH.
3-0 PITCH FROM A POSITION PLAYER
, HIS MANAGER SAID DON'T SWING,
HE SAID HE WOULD, HE DID.
IS THIS CONVERSATION TIRED?
DUBON GOING AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH.
HE WILL POP IT TO INDIA.
>> WE HAVE A LOT TO SAY, AT
LEAST I DO.
ANY POSITION PLAYER PITCHING,
THERE ARE NO RULES.
YOU HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY AS A
HITTER TO BE UP THERE SWINGING.
HITTERS DON'T WANT TO STRIKE
OUT.
3-0, HE ENDS UP THROWING IT.
I DON'T KNOW.
TO ME, I DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH DOING IT.
I SEE A PROBLEM THROWING AT SOME
ON THE SIXTH INNING.
IF THEY HAD SUCH A BIG PROBLEM
WITH IT, THEY SHOULD HAVE HIT
THE VERY NEXT PLAYER AND NOT
WAIT 24 HOURS UNTIL THE SEVENTH
INNING.
THAT IS MY OPINION.
>> I HAD A PROBLEM WITH THE
CALL.
POSITION PLAYER, WHO CARES?
THAT IS JUST AN ISSUE WITH
RESPECT.
BECAUSE IT IS 3-0, IF YOU HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH IT, DON'T WAIT.
>> DOWN ON STRIKES.
YOU GOT I HAVE IT EVERYONE.
IT IS ALL GOOD.
1, 2, 3 INNING IN THE SIXTH FOR
CARSON FULMER.
>> IN THE AIR TO RIGHT, MAKES A
DIVING CATCH!
>> HE CRASHED HIS HEAD INTO
THOSE GLASSES.
>> HE LOST HIS BALANCE.
ROLLING INTO THIRD.
>> HE LOST TISSUE -- LOST HIS
SHOE.
>> WE HAVE ABOUT SEEN IT ALL.
>> 2, 3, 4 DUE UP FOR THE REDS
IN THE BOTTOM SIX.
POTENTIAL HALL OF FAMERS ON
THESE ROSTERS.
BUSTER POSEY HAVING A
RENAISSANCE.
JOEY VOTTO CURRENTLY ON THE
INJURED LIST.
ONE OF THE ULTIMATE BATTERS.
THIS GUY KNOWS HOW TO TAKE A
PITCH.
POSEY, MULTIPLE WORLD SERIES
TITLES.
WHICH OF THESE PLAYERS BELONGS
IN THE BASEBALL HALL OF FAME.
JEREMY?
>> I PLAYED WITH BOTH.
WITH TODAY'S STANDARDS, I'M NOT
SURE.
JOEY VOTTO IS A GREAT PLAYER.
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
HE TAKES SO MANY WALKS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE GOING
TO PUT HIM IN.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE IS NOT ONE
OF THE BEST PLAYERS IN ONE OF
THE BEST ERRORS.
-- ERAS.
CLUSTER SHOULD GET IN.
-- BUSTER SHOULD GET IN.
HE HAS CAUGHT NO-HITTERS,
M.V.P.'S, WORLD SERIES, GOLD
GLOVES, SLUGGERS, 1500 GAMES.
FOR ME, WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
CATCHER AND YOU LOOK AT THE TYPE
OF CATCHER HE WAS, DEFENSIVELY
AND OFFENSIVELY, I DON'T SEE HOW
HE CAN'T NOT GET IN.
I THINK OF MOLINA AND POSEY.
THOSE OTHER GUYS -- THOSE OTHER
GUYS YOU LEARN TO BE A CATCHER
FROM.
THEY CONTROL THE GAME.
THEY CONTROL EVERYTHING WELL.
TO ME, IT IS A BIG DEAL.
VOTTO IS IN A TOUGH SPOT.
HIS NUMBERS HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD
OVERALL.
HE COULD EASILY GET IN.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT FROM
HIM.
>> MAN, THIS IS TOUGH.
I ALMOST HOPE WE WILL ASK JP.
IT WAS VERY UNFAIR.
WE DON'T HAVE OUR VOTER CARD.
TO THE POINTS JEREMY WAS MAKING,
JOEY VOTTO DOES HAVE A SHOT.
300 CAREER HOME RUNS.
BUSTER POSEY IS A .303 CAREER
HITTER.
I THINK THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE
FOR VOTTO.
BUSTER POSEY IS A SHOO-IN.
WORLD SERIES, M.V.P., CAREER 300
HITTER, I THINK HE IS THE A
PYGMY -- EPITOME OF A HALL OF
FAME PLAYER.
HIS CHARACTER.
BUSTER POSEY IS THE FACE OF WHAT
A HALL OF FAMER IS.
>> WE WILL GET JP.
VOTING RIGHT NOW ON YOUTUBE.
ARE THEY ON THE HALL OF FAME
HIGHLIGHT CARD?
HE IS ON THE GROUND.
THEY GOBBLE IT UP.
STRIKE OUT AND A GROUNDBALL.
BUSTER POSEY HAD A DAY OFF,
ADDING TO HIS POTENTIAL HALL OF
FAME.
>> BOTH OF THEM ARE DESERVING.
I THINK FOSTER IS MORE
DESERVING.
-- BUSTER POSEY IS MORE
YOU HAVE TO TAKE SPORTSMANSHIP
INTO CONSIDERATION.
I USUALLY ASK MYSELF, IF I'M
GOING TO WRITE A SINGLE PAGE
SUMMARY BASED ON THE ERA THIS
PLAYER PLAYED, HOW IMPORTANT IS
THIS PLAYER TO THAT ERA?
THREE WORLD SERIES RINGS, THAT
POSITION, WINNING M.V.P., TO ME,
BUSTER POSEY BELONGS IN THE HALL
OF FAME.
CATCHERS ARE VERY UNIQUE.
FASCINATING, LOOK AT THE GAMES
PLAYED BEHIND THE PLATE BETWEEN
POSEY AND JOE MAUER.
JOE HAD THE BATTING TITLES.
THE OVERALL CAREER BATTING
AVERAGE, JOE MAUER MAY BE ABLE
TO GET IN.
>> HE HAS CAUGHT THREE
NO-HITTERS, HE HAS WON THREE
RINGS.
LOOK AT THE RESUME.
WHAT ELSE DOES HE NEED TO DO?
>> ON THE OTHER SIDE, JOEY VOTTO
HAS HAD QUITE THE MODERN CAREER.
HE IS TRENDING DOWN LATELY.
MUCH MORE POWER IN HIS FIRST
DECADE IN THE BIGS.
HE IS STILL AMONG THE BEST IN
BASEBALL.
SLUGGING IS DOWN.
CURRENTLY ON THE SHELF RIGHT
NOW.
HE IS A BIG PART OF THIS TEAM.
HE SAW HUTCHISON PLAYING FIRST
FOR THE FIRST TIME YESTERDAY.
JOEY VOTTO IS A MORE CURIOUS
CASE.
THAT IS FOULED OFF BY TYLER
NAQUIN.
JP, FINISH THIS OFFER US.
>> VOTTO AND HELTON, THE RESUMES
ARE QUITE SIMILAR.
I THINK HELTON IS TRENDING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IF HE GETS IN, IT WILL BODE WELL
FOR HOW THEY WILL REGARD VOTTO.
>> EVERYBODY WATCHING ON YOUTUBE
HAS ALL THE INFO THEY NEED TO
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION WHEN
THEY VOTE FOR THESE PLAYERS.
>> CAN I GIVE SOME ADVICE?
TAKE THE ADVICE OF J.P. MOROSI,
ONE THAT VOTES FOR REAL.
JEREMY AND I DON'T.
>> WE DON'T VOTE.
I WOULD.
>> I AM JUST GLAD WE ARE
SITTING.
>> NAQUIN CONTINUING TO FOUL
PITCHES OFF.
NINE PITCHES SO FAR.
>> CINCINNATI HAS SO MANY
BEAUTIFUL SKIES THIS TIME OF
YEAR.
>> I THINK NAQUIN IS HITTING
EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
10TH PITCH AND COUNTING.
SOME OF THE YOUTUBE CREATORS
RESPONDING WITH COMMENTS TO THE
POLL QUESTION.
>> FUNNY WHEN PEOPLE SAY HALL OF
FAME.
COME ON.
COME UP WITH SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.'
>> THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
CHANGES.
TO PLAY AS GOOD AS SOME OF THESE
GUYS ARE PLAYING, WITH THE
SCOUTING, THE NUMBERS, BUT
COMPUTERS AND THESE GUYS STILL
COME OUT AND PLAY GOOD.
BUSTER HAVING HIS BEST YEAR SO
FAR TO DATE.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO PICK
HIM APART AS A HITTER AND HE IS
STILL MAKING ADJUSTMENTS.
IT IS HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND, IT IS SO HARD TO BE
A GOOD PLAYER.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE POSITION.
AS A CATCHER, YOU'RE SQUATTING
BEHIND THE PLATE, BLOCKING
BALLS.
TO THINK ABOUT EACH PITCH,
SETTING GUYS UP, MENTALLY TO THE
PLATE.
THEN DRIVING IN RUNS?
BEING A CATCHER, OFFENSIVE AND
DEFENSIVE IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
DO.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A 14 PITCH
AT-BAT, YOU HAVE TIME TO LAY IT
OUT.
GIANTS WITH A BIG DAY.
>> STEP UP TO THE PLATE, COMPETE
ONLINE.
COVID-19 VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
JOIN THE TEAM AND GET THE
VACCINE.
8, 9, 1 DUE UP FOR THE GIANTS.
WE ARE HAVING A GREAT DAY.
GLOBAL AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE.
CASALI, 1-2, HIT BY A PITCH,
SCORED ONE OF SAN FRANCISCO'S 14
RUNS.
MOST RUNS WE HAVE SEEN IN A GAME
THIS SEASON.
HE DID NOT GO.
>> IF YOU ARE A RELIEVER, YOU
ARE HIDING RIGHT NOW.
YOU DON'T WANT TO PITCH.
>> THE INNING BEFORE WHERE HE
THREW NINE PITCHES, WHATEVER IT
WAS, I KIND OF FEEL LIKE HE IS
THE M.V.P. OF THE REDS TODAY.
>> EAT UP SOME INNINGS.
BOTH THESE TEAMS HEADING INTO A
BIG WEEKEND SERIES.
BACK AT HIM -- DID THAT HIT HIM?
IT DID.
HIT BY A PITCH THE SECOND TIME
TODAY.
>> AT LEAST HE WAS WEARING THAT
ARM GUARD.
>> DID IT GET HIM?
>> I THINK IT HIT THE ARM GUARD.
>> I THINK IT NICKED IT HIM A
LITTLE.
>> A LOT OF TIMES PITCHERS,
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNGER ONES
DON'T KNOW HOW TO EFFECTIVELY
PITCH INSIDE.
HE TRIED TO GO IN A LITTLE AND
IT RUNS UP AND IN, NEXT THING
YOU KNOW THE HITTER IS HAVING
TROUBLE.
>> THE STUFF THEY HAVE THESE
DAYS, IF THEY CAN COMMAND THEIR
FASTBALL ON THE INNER PART OF
THE PLATE --
>> AUSTIN SLATER IS IN THE GAME.
>> PITCHING EFFECTIVELY TO THE
INSIDE IS WHAT KEEPS YOU IN THE
BALLGAME.
HITTERS CAN LEAN OUT OVER THE
PLATE.
IT MAKES THEM SO COMFORTABLE TO
ADJUST TO YOUR PITCHES.
IF YOU CAN PLACE A STRIKE ON THE
BLACK INSIDE, IN IN IN AND COME
BACK OUT, THERE IS A LOT YOU CAN
DO.
WITH THESE GUYS NOW TRYING TO
THROW AS HARD AS THEY CAN, I
THINK IT TAKES AWAY FROM THEIR
ABILITY TO LOCATE CERTAIN
PITCHES.
>> CARSON FULMER STRIKES OUT
SLATER.
IT IS A FOOD FIGHT.
WHICH BALLPARK FOOD IS BEST THIS
YEAR?
LOG ONTO MLB.COM/FOODFIGHT
TODAY.
>> BALLPARK BY THE RIVER.
CINCINNATI, A LOT MORE FULL VERY
SOON.
GREAT AMERICAN.
YASTRZEMSKI SENDS IT TO RIGHT.
MARK PAYTON.
>> THAT WAS YASTRZEMSKI'S FIFTH
AT BAT AND WE DID NOT TALK ABOUT
THE MUSTACHE ONCE.
THAT WAS THE COOLEST MUSTACHE.
>> THEY HAVE GOT IT DOWN.
SLATER, I SWEAR, THERE IS
PROBABLY NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT REMEMBER HIM, MAYBE THERE
IS BUT HE LOOKS LIKE RANDY
JOHNSON.
YEAH.
THEY ARE DOING SOME SORT OF --
>> THE RACE IS ON FOR RUF.
HE WILL HOLD UP AT SECOND.
>> HE CAN BLAME THAT ON CASALI
CLOGGING UP THE BASES.
>> COUPLE DOUBLES, THE SINGLE IN
THE TWO RUN HOMER.
-- AND THE TWO RUN HOMER.
>> DID YOU SEE HIM LOOK FOR
CASALI?
[LAUGHTER]
COME ON MAN!
>> PANDA HAD THE LAST --
TRIPLE, AGAINST COLORADO.
>> I THINK IT WAS IN COLORADO.
>> ANOTHER TRIPLE PLACE.
>> GO DARREN GO DARREN!
>> THAT IS GOING TO SCORE ONE.
HERE COMES ANOTHER.
BRANDON CRAWFORD BRINGS IN TWO
MORE FOR SAN FRANCISCO TO MAKE
IT 16-1.
CASALI AND RUF, COME ON DOWN.
>> AMAZING, FOR THOSE TUNING IN,
BUSTER POSEY HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THESE 16 RUNS.
THAT IS REMARKABLE.
>> HE IS PROBABLY ASKING FOR AN
AT-BAT.
>> THE SERIES THEY HAVE COMING
UP AGAINST THE DODGERS -- THIS
IS THE GAME FOR HIM TO SIT AND
DO NOTHING.
>> PERFECT GAME TO REST.
>> I CAN REST MY MAIN GUY.
I WILL BE USING HIM IN THE NEXT
THREE STRAIGHT GAMES.
IT WILL BE A DOGFIGHT.
>> EVAN LONGORIA HAS LEFT THE
YARD.
TWO RUN HOMER AND THE GIANTS
HAVE SCORED MORE RUNS IN A GAME
THAN ANY TEAM THIS SEASON.
18 SPOT.
LONGO'S FIFTH OF THE YEAR.
>> SO BIZARRE THE WAY HITTING IS
SO CONTAGIOUS.
GUYS START HITTING OUT OF THE
BALLPARK AND EVERYONE WANTS TO
BITE.
>> ALEX DICKERSON INTO THE
SHIFT.
MORE DAMAGE FROM THE GIANTS.
THEY TAG ON FOUR.
THE TALLY IS 18, MOST BY A TEAM
IN A SINGLE GAME THIS SEASON.
>> GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING POWER
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF DATA THAN
EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
STATCAST, POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
EUGENIO SUAREZ, LOOK AT THE WAY
THAT SHE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
CAPITALIZE -- HE HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO CAPITALIZE OVER THIS
YEAR.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS,
2018-19, THAT MIDDLE AWAY, TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE BALLPARK, RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
IT CARRIES OUT THERE AND THAT IS
WHAT HE DID.
HE WANTS TO HIT 50 HOME RUNS
TODAY, FEEL LIKE HE IS PRESSING
TOO HARD TO GET YOU -- GET TO
WHAT HE WAS BEFORE.
HAVE FUN AND LET NEW YORK -- LET
IT COME AS IT WAS.
>> THE MIDDLE NUMBERS REALLY
SURPRISING, TOO.
STILL, THAT 182 ON PITCHES DOWN
THE PIKE THAT ARE NOT AS
POSITIVELY SURPRISING.
THAT IS A HANGER.
SUAREZ HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO TIME
IT UP.
CAMILO DOVAL IS DEFINITELY OFF
THE CHARTS.
JUST BEING A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTROL TO FIGURE OUT E.R.A.'S
NOT THE SEASON.
AGAINST THE CINCINNATI LINEUP,
17-RUN CUSHION.
>> THE NUMBER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NET BEING SO LOW, WHEN YOU
CAN TELL THAT YOU ARE REALLY
TRYING TO CRUSH THE BALL SO BAD,
WAY OUT IN FRONT OF IT.
DON'T HIT IT, LIKE YOU CAN.
DRAG THE BALL UP THE MIDDLE.
>> FOUR MISSES FROM REVOLVER.
WE HAVE A CHANCE, REALLY GREAT
JOB FROM THE CREATORS TO THE
PLAYERS, THEIR COMMENTS.
POSEY, 48%.
40% -- 88% THINK POSEY IS A
LOCK.
I THINK THAT BOTH WILL
EVENTUALLY BE HEADED TO
COOPERSTOWN.
IF THEY RETIRED IN THE SAME
YEAR, POSEY ENTERING BEFORE
VOTTO.
BUT EVENTUALLY.
WELL DONE BY EVERYONE ON THAT
ONE.
OUR HALL OF FAME VOTER J.P.
MOROSI, CAN YOU SIZE OF THE
RESULTS?
>> REALLY ENJOY THE CONVERSATION
AND THE FEEDBACK.
I DO THINK THAT ULTIMATELY POSEY
AND VOTTO WILL GET IN.
MY HALL OF FAME BALLOT FOR NEXT
YEAR, I'M EXCITED TO SEE A
COUPLE OF PLAYERS -- SCOTT
ROLEN, WHO HAS HAD MORE AND MORE
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS, AND JIM,
YOU PLAYED AGAINST HIM, THE
CLASSIC 2012 DIVISION SERIES.
I THINK ROLAND EVENTUALLY GETS
IN.
JEFF KENT -- I'M A JEFF KENT
VOTER OFFENSIVE SECOND BASEMAN
EVER.
DEFENSE, GREAT DEFENDER, SOLID
DEFENDER, CERTAINLY GOOD ENOUGH
WHEN YOU CONSIDER OFFENSE BEING
ONE OF THE BEST -- WANTED TO
MAKE THAT POINT THERE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS NEXT
YEAR.
>> GOOD ENOUGH TO STAY AT THE
POSITION.
YOU REMEMBER 2002, MADE THE
WORLD SERIES.
HOME RUN LEADER FROM THAT YEAR.
20 HOME RUNS ON THAT TEAM.
>> BILL.
THE HARVARD GRAD.
>> BEAT YOU TO IT.
J.P. GOING WITH DAVID
BELL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SORRY, JEREMY, MY MISTAKE.
I DID MENTION THE 2012 DIVISION
SERIES, GET ON YOUR GOOD SIDE
THAT WAY.
>> THERE IS THE STRIKE.
BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
>> IN THE FUTURE IF THERE'S ANY
TRIVIA QUESTION, TURN HIS MIC
AND LET US GET IT WRONG AND HE
CAN TELL US THE RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I ACTUALLY DO NOT KNOW THAT
MY MIC WAS EVEN OPEN.
>> THAT IS BECAUSE OF J.P.
, PLAYING ALONG -- THAT IS
CLASSIC J.P.
>> MICS ARE ALWAYS HOT, J.P.
>> STAY HOT.
DOVAL GETS THE K.
THREW TWO RUNNERS REACH.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A GUY WHO
CAN HIT WITH HIS FASTBALL.
USES HIS SLIDERS.
>> THERE IS REASON, BECAUSE HE
CANNOT CONTROL HIS BASKETBALL.
THINK HOW NASTY HE WOULD BE?
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A SWINGING ARM
SLOT LIKE THAT AT 100 MILES AN
HOUR, IT IS IS WHIPPING THE BALL
THROUGH THERE.
IT IS ALL ABOUT TIMING OF THE
RELEASE SO HE WOULD PROBABLY
WANT THE COMMANDERS LATER, HE
WILL GO TO THAT CORNER.
IF YOU CAN GET CONSISTENT
ANYWHERE OVER THE PLATE, 97 TO
100, KNOWING HE COULD COMMAND A
SLIDER LIKE THAT, SWING MORE ON
FASTBALLS OUTSIDE THE ZONE.
THEY WILL NOT HIT ANYTHING HARD
RIGHT NOW KNOWING HE CANNOT
COMMAND IT.
>> I THINK WE SEE MORE AND MORE
RELIEVERS LIKE THAT RIGHT NOW,
BACK TO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
COMMAND.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE IT IS GOING.
>> WE HAVE TO COMPETE WITH A GUY
THROWING HARD.
YOU CAN STILL THROW HARD AND BE
NASTY.
99 RIGHT THERE.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE IT GOES.
THAT IS A MATTER OF HONING IN ON
YOUR MECHANICS.
SO INCONSISTENT WITH STAYING
BACK.
>> CAMILO, 100 DOWN TO 99.
>> YOU SEE THE 100 DOWN THE
MIDDLE, KIND OF RIGHT ON IT.
BLANDINO DIDN'T EVEN SEE
IT.
GOOD PROBLEM TO HAVE, RIGHT?
>> 2 ON.
2-2.
IN THERE.
STRAIGHTENS HIM UP.
NEW TO THE MO BECAME OF THE
WEEK--MLB GAME OF THE WEEK?
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HIT YOUR MOBILE DEVICE OR YOUR
COMPUTER AND YOU CAN VOTE FOR
WHICH PLAYER WILL PROCEED.
CUSTOMIZED, ENGRAVED, WITH THE
NAME OF THE PLAYER.
THAT CLARITY W-- JACK LARRY WON
IT LAST WEEK.
WE WILL TALK TO THE PLAYER
POSTGAME.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A TEAM WITH 18
RUNS, NOT THAT EASY TO PICK IT
UP.
>> JEREMY, HOW ABOUT DUOVA--
DOVAL WEARING 75 FOR THE
GIANTS?
>> THAT IS NOT A NEVER MOST
PEOPLE CHOOSE.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE STORY
BEHIND THAT.
MAYBE ONE OF HIS FAVORITE
PITCHERS OR SOMETHING.
DEFINITELY NOT A NUMBER THAT YOU
WOULD CHOOSE TO HAVE.
DEFINITELY PRETTY UNIQUE.
>> AKIYAMA.
THAT IS CLOSE.
>> BUT FOR UMPIRES TO SEE THAT
AND NOT CALL THAT A STRIKE CAN
JUST THE FACT THAT THE NOTE KEEP
COMMAND ANYWAY.
HE IS THROWING A LOT OF STRIKES
AT 100 MILES AN HOUR.
>> CRAWFORD BUBBLES.
AKIYAMA IS SAFE.
>> AKIYAMA GETS DOWN VERY QUICK.
NOT THE FASTEST ON HIS TEAM, BUT
BEING LEFT-HANDED -- I DON'T
EVEN KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID,
HOW CRAWFORD BOBBLED IT, LIKE HE
EXCHANGED HANDS, GETTING RID OF
THE BALL SO QUICK.
>> WAS AN INFIELD SINGLE.
>> NOW THE REDS HAVE THE BASES
LOADED.
THERE IS A STRIKE AT THE TOP OF
THE ZONE.
MAX SCHROCK JUST CALLED
UP-TO-DATE -- CALLED UP TODAY.
1-9 SO FAR THIS SEASON.
THAT WAS RULED AN ERROR ON
BRANDON CRAWFORD.
>> TOUGH ERROR RIGHT THERE.
>> TOUGH.
>> I GUESS WHEN YOU ARE AS GOOD
AS BRANDON CRAWFORD --
>> GIANTS HAVE THE FEWEST ERRORS
IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE THIS
SEASON.
>> FIND THE PITCHER HERE -- IF
I'M THE PITCHER HERE, NOT GOING
TO --
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY DO
THAT ANYMORE.
>> SCHROCK.
DANNY, I WILL GIVE THE REDS
THIS -- THE SCORE IS LOPSIDED,
BUT THE QUALITY OF THE AT-BATS
FROM THE REDS THIS AFTERNOON HAS
BEEN IMPRESSIVE.
>> IT REALLY HAS.
THEY MADE THESE PITCHERS WORK.
YES, THEIR AT-BATS HAD BEEN VERY
GOOD.
>> GIANTS PITCHERS ARE SO GOOD.
KEVIN HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BEST
IN THE BIZ THIS YEAR, WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
RELEASING SEEN THAT THROUGHOUT
THE SERIES.
GIANTS HAVE JUST CONTINUED TO
ESCAPE.
SEE IF DOVAL CAN DO IT.
NO, THAT ONE GETS AWAY.
IN COMES THE RUN FOR CINCINNATI.
IT IS 18-2.
THAT IS SUAREZ'S GOING.
>> THAT IS TOUGH, CASALI.
WHEN YOU ARE THROWING AS HARD AS
DOVAL DOES AND HE DOESN'T GET TO
THE PLATE, IT IS REALLY HARD.
HE TAKES A LOT OF PRIDE IN THE
BLOCKING BALL.
ON AN EASY ONE TO BLOCK -- NOT
AN EASY ONE TO BLOCK.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE RUNNERS IN
POSITION, HOW GOOD THEY ARE.
1-9, REDS IN SCORING POSITION.
>> THERE YOU GO.
PAYOFF TO SCHROCK.
FISHING FOR THE SLIDER.
ONE MORE FOR.
>> YOU NERVOUS?
>> SO?
>> I WILL TAKE --
THREE-STRIKEOUTS AND A HOMER.
>> MAURICIO DUBON'S MIC'S UP
TODAY ON YOUTUBE.
I LIKE THAT.
A CONVERSATION YOU WOULD NOT
HAVE HAD A DECADE AGO.
EVERYONE HAS A CARD ON THE FIELD
AND DUBON IS LIKE, HA HA, DRIER
THAN YOURS.
>> THE CONVERSATIONS AMONG THE
ATHLETES HAVE DEFINITELY
CHANGED.
>> THIS MIGHT BE THE FIRST TIME
I'VE BEEN PART OF A BROADCAST
WHERE THE POSITION PLAYER
PITCHES.
ACTUALLY KIND OF EXCITED RIGHT
NOW.
>> ANOTHER FIRST FOR ME.
-- NOT THE FIRST FOR ME.
65-MILE AN HOUR BREAKING PITCH.
40TH CAREER PITCHING APPEARANCE.
BLANDINO WAS AT FIRST.
NOW HE IS ON THE MOUND.
YOU WOULD THINK YOU COULD AVOID
70-SOMETHING MILES AN HOUR.
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU THIS,
HE'S WEARING THE PITCHER'S
PANTS, FOR SURE.
HE LOOKS LIKE A PITCHER.
>> OH, HE DID A SHAKE.
LOBBED LEFT.
BUT A KNOCK.
DUBON'S SECOND HIT OF THE DAY.
>> THIS MIGHT BE ME, BUT I FEEL
LIKE HE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
THE DELIVERY SET UP.
IN MY RIGHT ON THAT?
>> I FEEL LIKE THAT IS HOUSTON
STREET.
I FEEL LIKE THE DELIVERY, ALL
THAT STUFF, 94.
>> SOMEONE SITTING AT HOME IN
SAINT YOU JUST COMPARED --
>> WHO'S GOT IT.
>> WHILE WE HAVE A MOMENT, YOUR
PLAYER OF THE GAME, WHO IS
TODAY'S YOUTUBE PLAYER?
CRAWFORD WITH THE BIG DAY.
TWO SINGLES, A WALK, AND A
TWO-RUN SHOT.
COAL IS NOW.
LET US KNOW.
LET'S GET SOME HELP, TOO.
BLANDINO FACES CASALI.
HELP OUR YOUTUBE VIEWERS MAKE A
DECISION, JEREMY.
THE PLAYER OF THE GAME IS?
>> I'M GOING WITH DUGGAR.
THAT GRAND SLAM PRETTY MUCH
OPENED IT UP.
IT WAS LOCKED IN.
HE KIND OF STAYED FOCUSED AND
PUT THE NAIL IN THE COFFIN TO
KIND OF PUSH THAT SCORE TO WHERE
-- WITH DUGGAR.
>> THAT IS A REALLY GOOD -- HARD
TO GO AGAINST A GUY WITH A GRAND
SLAM.
HERE'S MY TAKE.
HE IS JUST A ONE HIT WONDER.
I'M GOING BRANDON CRAWFORD WITH
THE FLOW.
SIX RBIS ON THE DAY.
>> AND THE HAIR.
>> THE HAIR HELPS.
>> HE FOOLED US.
HE WAS THROWING 70 TO START THE
INNING.
>> GOT A RUNNER ON BASE.
>> UPSET.
>> HASN'T GIVEN UP A RUN IN HIS
CAREER.
THIS IS THE FOURTH APPEARANCE.
NOW IT IS AUSTIN SLATER.
BIG SMILE FROM SLATER.
ON THE GROUNDS.
ALEX BLANDINO, YOU ARE AN
EFFECTIVE MAJOR LEAGUE RELIEVER.
GIVE THAT MAN A STANDING O.
>> THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE IS PRESENTED BY JIM
BEAM.
VISIT THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
OFFICIAL YOUTUBE CHANNEL TO
WATCH HIGHLIGHTS.
SUBSCRIBE TO YOUTUBE.COM/GIANTS
TODAY.
J.P. MOROSI WATCHING THIS ONE
SLUGFEST TODAY.
J.P., A BIG WEEKEND COMING OUT
FOR BOTH SIDES.
LET'S HIGHLIGHT WHAT SAN
FRANCISCO IS ABOUT TO RUN INTO
BACK HOME.
JOSE ALVAREZ ABOUT TO TAKE OVER
IN THE 8TH.
>> CAN'T WAIT BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN SIX NO-HIT BASEBALL GAMES
THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN A
GIANT-DODGERS GAME.
TREVOR BAUER ON THE MOUND
AGAINST THE FORMER DODGER ALEX
WOOD.
N.L. WEST BECOMING A FASCINATING
DIVISION.
A LOT OF US THAT IN SPRING
TRAINING IT WOULD BE THE DODGERS
AND THE PADRES.
THEY HAVE GOT A GREAT TEST
TOMORROW WITH THE FIRST GAME OF
THE SEASON.
>> FIRST MATCHUP OF THE SEASON
BETWEEN THE GIANTS AND DODGERS.
A LOT OF JUICE.
LOOK AT THE DODGERS.
GAMESMANSHIP EARLY IN THE
SEASON, HOW MUCH A SERIES LIKE
THIS WHEN SAN FRANCISCO IS
RUNNING AWAY RIGHT NOW, BEST
RECORD IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THERE WILL BE 28-16 ON THE YEAR,
AND BOTH WILL GET BIG-TIME
PLAYING TIME IN A SERIES AGAINST
VERY TOUGH PITCHERS ON THE L.A.
SIDE.
I RODE UP FOR THAT ONE, -- FIRED
UP FOR THAT ONE, JEREMY.
>> THIS WILL BE A GREAT SERIES.
ALWAYS A RIVALRY GAME, BUT THIS
WILL BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THE GIANTS ARE NOW 12
GAMES OF OVER .500.
THEY ARE AHEAD OF THE DODGERS.
GOING TO BE AN OVERALL GOOD
GAME.
PROBABLY MORE LIKE A PLAYOFF
EXPERIENCE LAST FEW YEARS OF THE
GIANTS HAVE NOT BEEN IN GREAT
CONTENTION COMPARED TO THE
DODGERS.
THIS IS A FUN SERIES THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LOOKING
FORWARD TO ALL YEAR.
I'M SURE A LOT OF BASEBALL
PEOPLE WILL BE READY TO WATCH
THIS GAME.
>> AND THEN THE NEXT WEEKEND AT
DODGER STADIUM, A LOT OF ACTION
BETWEEN THOSE TWO TEAMS COMING
UP.
STEPHENSON FLIES OUT.
GABE KAPLER MANAGING SO FAR THIS
YEAR.
12 YEARS IN THE BIGS.
DIRECTOR OF PLAYER DEVELOPMENT,
MANAGE THE PHILLIES.
PART OF THE DODGERS FRONT
OFFICE.
GIANTS HAD THE BEST RECORD IN
BASEBALL.
YOU WERE SERIOUS WHEN YOU SAID
THIS MORNING DURING OUR CHAT,
ONE OF THE BEST ANSWERS I'VE
EVER RECEIVED TO A QUESTION
ABOUT HIS LEARNING PROCESS AS A
BIG-LEAGUE MANAGER.
LEARNING THAT THIS GAME IS MORE
A SCIENCE.
>> YOU JUST GAVE ME CHILLS
LISTENING TO THAT.
THEY ARE IN FIRST PLACE, TEAM
THAT WAS NOT EVEN TALKED ABOUT
BEING THIS GOOD.
DODGERS AND PADRES.
HE HAS EVOLVED INTO A MANAGER
THAT LOVES THE ANALYTICS BUT
LOVES THE ART OF THE HUMAN --
ABOUT HOW YOU GO OUT THERE AND
PLAY THE GAME.
IT'S BEEN AMAZING.
IT WAS AMAZING TO HEAR HIM SAY
THAT.
I HAD SOMETHING TO ASK HIM, BUT
I COULD HARDLY TALK ANYMORE.
>> GOT LOST IN HIS ANSWER.
IT WAS A GREAT ONE.
>> IT WAS AMAZING.
BUT AS ANALYTICAL AS HE WAS, HE
PRETTY MUCH SAID I'M GOING TO
MAKE THIS DISH LOOK HOW GOOD
THEY ARE.
NOT JUST THE ONE-SIDED, PEOPLE
SAY OLD-SCHOOL, ONE-SIDED, NO
ANALYTICS.
SEE HOW GOOD WE CAN BE.
THEY ARE THE BEST TEAM IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
>> SHIPPED TO LEFT OFF THE BAD
OF SUAREZ.
>> HE LOOKED LIKE A HITTER THAT
WAS RELAXED.
THAT IS SOMETHING -- HE JUST
TRIED TO DRIVE THAT.
>> IT THERE.
>> TO AVOID A PITCH A GAME LIKE
THIS WHEN YOU ARE ON THE WINNING
SIDE AND YOU JUST WANT TO THROW
STRIKES.
THRU CHANGEUP, GET TO 0-2, AND
SUAREZ CAN MASH PASSED BALLS.
-- FASTBALLS.
>> FOUR HOMERS AND THE LAST 11
GAMES.
THE CURRENT HITTER FOR
CINCINNATI TELLS THE STORY OF
THIS SEASON FOR SUAREZ.
ANDERSON SPRING TRAINING --
ENTERS SPRING TRAINING AND THEY
GO STOP COME AND THEY DIDN'T
SOLVE THAT ISSUE.
OF COURSE YOU ARE GOING TO
NATURALLY WONDER IF THAT WAS
JUST ANOTHER RESPONSIBILITY
ADDED TO HIS PLATE.
MADE IT A LITTLE MORE
DISTRACTING, WHAT HE DID AT THE
PLATE.
>> VERY DEMANDING POSITION,
BEING A CATCHER.
THE SHORTSTOP HAS THAT, TOO.
LEADER OF THE INFIELD.
I FEEL LIKE GINO PUT TOO MUCH
PRESSURE ON HIMSELF TO BE GREAT
AT THAT, INSTEAD OF WHAT HE WAS
GREAT AT ALREADY.
>> HERE IS BUSTER.
JUST A CATCHER THIS YEAR,
GETTING SOME TIME.
>> PAINFUL, BUT --
>> YEAH.
>> THE TECHNOLOGY THEY HAVE.
UP THE SHOOT, TWO OUT
BASERUNNING.
WE ARE NOT REALLY COMPLAINING,
SCOTT.
I MEAN, WE DIDN'T HAVE ALL THAT
STUFF.
>> WHAT DID THEY GIVE YOU IN THE
CLUBHOUSE?
INDIA FLIES OUT TO SECOND.
WHAT A DAY FOR GABE KAPLER'S
GROUP.
>> HE SAID I AM GOING TO LET YOU
PLAY UNTIL YOU PROVE YOU ARE NOT
THINKING -- NOT THINKING OF THE
TEAM FIRST.
IN MY MIND, IT MAY BE PUT A
LITTLE MORE PRESSURE ON ME.
AND WHAT THAT ALLOWED ME TO DO
IS PLAY THE GAME THE WAY I PLAY
IT.
BUT ANY TIME YOU PASS MY
SCULPTURE, I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD NOT ONLY THINK OF JOE
MORGAN, BUT ALL THE GREAT
PLAYERS WHO HELPED MAKE THAT
STATUE POSSIBLE, LONG LIVE THE
BIG RED MACHINE.
>> VISIT THE CINCINNATI REDS
OFFICIAL YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
CHECK OUT TOP HIGHLIGHTS,
EXCLUSIVE BEHIND THE SCENES
CONTENT AND AN ORIGINAL YOUTUBE
SERIES.
NEVER MISS A NEW VIDEO.
PHILLIES AND MARLINS, AFTERNOON
ACTION A WEEK FROM TODAY.
AFTER THAT, THE METS MEET UP
WITH THE DIAMONDBACKS AND THEN
THE DODGERS AT THE PIRATES.
MIKE TROUT IS ON THE I.L., BUT
OHTANI SHOULD BE THERE ON THE
17TH AS THE TIGERS THE ANGELS.
AND THEN REDS AND BREWERS,
ANOTHER CINCINNATI GAME.
WE WILL HAVE THEM IN MILWAUKEE.
CHRISTIAN YELICH & CO..
WE ARE IN THE NINTH.
I AM ALSO GOING TO DO A SHOUT
OUT, ALEX BLANDINO GOING 88,
INSIDE CORNER FOR A STRIKE, AND
WHY NOT?
COMING UP AGAINST A PITCHER WHO
IS 0-2 IN HIS CAREER.
I NEVER DO THIS, BUT I FEEL LIKE
IT IS DEFINITELY GOING TO
EXEMPLIFY WHAT THESE YOUTUBE
GAMES ARE ALL ABOUT ON A GLOBAL
STAGE.
HE LIVES IN BERMUDA.
HE IS A YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
SUPER FAN.
HE HAS BEEN ASKING ME FOR YEARS
WHEN WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
REDS ON YOUTUBE.
WINSTON, I HOPE YOU ARE ENJOYING
THIS ONE AND WE LOVE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WORLDWIDE.
I ALWAYS CHECK SOCIAL AFTER THE
GAME AND THE RESPONSES ARE
INCREDIBLE.
IT IS SO COOL TO SEE WHERE
EVERYONE IS TUNING IN.
OF COURSE, THE UNITED STATES,
BUT THEN WORLDWIDE VIEWERSHIP.
KEEP IT UP.
THANKS FOR WATCHING WITH US.
>> THAT'S AMAZING, BERMUDA, A
REDS FAN IN BERMUDA.
SCOTT: I HAVE AN OPEN
INVITATION.
HE WORKS AT A HOTEL AND HE SAID
BRING THE FAMILY OUT HERE.
BIG BASEBALL FAN, REDS FAN, AND
HE GETS TO TUNE IN AND SEE A
SUNSHINY, BERMUDA LIKE DAY.
WE WILL GET HIM A BETTER RESULT
THE NEXT TIME THE REDS ARE ON
YOUTUBE.
>> WELL, HE DID TELL YOU TO
BRING DANNY AND JEREMY.
SCOTT: IT'S OPEN INVITATION.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS OPEN INVITATION?
SCOTT: I WILL LET YOU KNOW.
I WILL HOOK YOU GUYS UP IF YOU
WANT.
DARIN RUF IS A TRIPLE SHY OF THE
CYCLE.
BY THE WAY, THE RELIEF PITCHER
WHO HAS HAD TWO CAREER AT-BATS
JUST WALKED AGAINST THE POSITION
PLAYER ON THE MOUND.
THINGS ARE GETTING REAL HERE ON
YOUTUBE THIS AFTERNOON.
HE IS A TRIPLE SHY.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE MOST
EPIC THREE-BAGGERS I HAVE EVER
SEEN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW FAST ALVAREZ IS
OFF FIRST.
>> I WANT TO KNOW THE LAST TIME
A PITCHER HAS FACED A POSITION
PLAYER REVERSED.
HOW MANY TIMES -- I MEAN, I HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF POSITION PLAYERS
PITCHING, BUT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
HOW MANY PITCHERS I HAVE SEEN
HITTING.
>> I BET WITH THE TECHNOLOGY ON
THE BENCHES THEY COULD TELL US.
>> IT SHOULD BE ON MY APPLE
WATCH ALREADY.
>> THAT IS PULLED FOUL.
INSTEAD OF POSITION PLAYERS
PITCHING, CAN WE GET SOME
PITCHERS BATTING?
YES, WE GOT ONE, AND IT WORKED
OUT JUST LIKE EVERYTHING FOR SAN
FRANCISCO TODAY.
>> I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW
SOURCE WILL BE KNOWS GOING TO BE
TOMORROW.
>> HE IS THROWING -- HOW SORE
SHE IS GOING TO BE TOMORROW.
HE IS THROWING HARD.
>> THIS IS THE FOURTH TIME
BLANDINO HAS PITCHED, CORRECT?
IN HIS CAREER AS A MAJOR LEAGUE
ATHLETE.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THIS WOULD BE THE LONGEST OUTING
BY A POSITION PLAYER THIS YEAR
IF HE GETS A FEW MORE OUTS,
WHICH THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
NO OUTS IN THE NINTH.
40 PITCHES TODAY OUT OF ALEX
BLANDINO?
MAYBE.
OF COURSE IT'S A 3-2 COUNT FOR
DARIN RUF.
>> IMAGINE THAT.
>> KAPLER SMILING RIGHT NOW.
>> HE IS SAYING THESE GUYS THINK
I AM THE SMARTEST PERSON IN THE
WORLD.
>> FALL FOUR -- BALL FOUR.
NO CYCLE.
J.P., WHAT IS THE SCOUTING
REPORT ON ALEX BLANDINO?
J.P.: I HAVE TO CREDIT JEREMY
AFFLECK BECAUSE HE WAS ONTO
SOMETHING.
BLANDINO GREW UP IN THE BAY
AREA.
HE STARTED MOUNTAIN VIEW HIGH
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA AND WAS
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED BY THE
OAKLAND ATHLETICS BEFORE HE WENT
TO STANFORD.
SO JEREMY, THAT WAS SOME GREAT
SCOUTING ON YOUR PART.
JEREMY: WELL, I DO A LOT OF
STUFF BEFORE THE GAME, J.P., SO
I AM PREPARED FOR EVERYTHING.
>> HE WAS PREPARED FOR BLANDINO
PITCHING.
IT'S AMAZING BECAUSE HOUSTON
STREET, AS GOOD AS HE WAS, HE
WAS ABOUT 88, 89 WITH SOME SINK.
SCOTT: HE FOOLED US BECAUSE THE
FIRST BATTER HE FACED, IT WAS A
79 MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL, SO WE
WERE LIKE OH, IT'S GOING TO BE
LIKE THAT.
NO.
>> HE JUST THREW AN 81 MILE PER
HOUR CHANGEUP.
JEREMY: HE'S GOT ALL KINDS OF
STUFF WORKING.
DANNY COULOMBE LISTEN, I KNOW --
>> LISTEN, HE MIGHT WANT TO
SWITCH ROLES.
HE HASN'T GOTTEN A HIT AT THE
PLATE.
SCOTT: HE MIGHT WANT TO SWITCH
POSITIONS.
THIS IS A LIVE TRY OUT.
>> HE'S GOT THE MOUND PRESENCE.
SCOTT: STATCAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD, BRANDON CRAWFORD
TODAY, SIX R.B.I.'S THIS
AFTERNOON, AND THIS IS HIS 11TH
BOMB OF THE SEASON.
BRANDON CRAWFORD HAS ONLY GOTTEN
TO THE 20 MARK ONCE IN HIS
CAREER AND WE ARE ALREADY AT 11
IN MAY.
HIS CAREER HIGH 21.
>> RIGHT NOW HE IS THIRD IN THE
LEAGUE, I BELIEVE.
>> JEREMY, I DID SOME RESEARCH
FOR YOU.
OUR EXCELLENT STAFF.
HERE IS PEYTON.
AND THERE IS OUT NUMBER ONE.
SO ACTUALLY, DAVID PERALTA HAD
TO PITCH IN A GAME LAST WEEK FOR
ARIZONA, POSITION PLAYER, AND HE
FACED PAOLO ESPINO, WHO IS A
PITCHER, SO IT HAPPENS MORE
OFTEN THAN YOU THINK.
JEREMY: AND WHAT HAPPENED IN
THAT AT-BAT?
DO WE KNOW?
SCOTT: HE REACHED ON AN ERROR.
AND THEN ESPINO FACED PERALTA IN
THE NEXT GAME AND PERALTA
RECORDED A BASE HIT.
>> YOU GUYS DO KNOW -- I AM SURE
YOU KNOW THIS.
PERALTA WAS A PITCHER WHEN HE
GOT DRAFTED.
WHEN HE SIGNED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SCOTT: NEW PITCHER, ANOTHER
POSITIONCK.
WELCOME TO THE BIG LEAGUE CLUB
TODAY, WE NEED YOU ON THE MOUND,
THANKS.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> HIT HIGH AND DEEP AND THIS
ONE IS HEADED TO THE WATER AND
GONE.
>> ALMOST GOT HIT BY IT.
>> THAT IS A LONG, LONG SHOT.
>>'S A GIRL DRIFTING OUT.
COMING ON IS HARTFORD.
-- SEGURA DRIFTING OUT.
MAYBE THREE FEET IN FRONT OF
HIM, HE RAISED HIS GLOVE AS IF
HE WAS GOING TO CATCH THE POP
UP.
VERY, VERY SOFT HIGH-FIVE.
>> LOOKING OUT OVER THE BULLPEN,
THE TEAM HAS BECOME ADDICTED TO
PLAYING THIS DURING THE GAME,
HAVE SOME FUN, MAYBE SOME
PHYSICAL EXERCISE.
THAT'S WHAT MIKE NAPOLI TOLD ME
HE USES IT FOR.
>> THAT ONE DOWN THE LINE.
WHAT A PLAY!
THAT'S LISA CROSS WITH THE
GOLDEN GLOVE OUT THERE.
SCOTT: 18-FOUR.
BACK ON YOUTUBE, AND THAT IS
GOING TO SCORE A RUN FOR SAN
FRANCISCO.
MAX SCHROCK IN THE GAME, AND
19-5 IS NOW YOUR TALLY.
HERE IS -- HERE IT IS ONE MORE
TIME.
OOPS.
GROUND RULE DOUBLE.
>> POSITION PLAYER ON THE MOUND,
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
>> HE WAS SORT OF LIFTED.
SOMEONE MIGHT WANT TO TELL THE
SCOREKEEPER.
>> DO YOU WANT A MERCY RULE?
>> IN SOME WAYS, DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE AT, YEAH, I DO
ACTUALLY.
IN SOME WAYS, I WOULDN'T DOUBT,
IN SOME WAYS, THE WAY THIS GAME
HAS BEEN PLAYED, THE RULE
CHANGES AND ALL THAT STUFF.
I SOMETIMES WONDER IF THEY WILL
IMPLEMENT A RULE LIKE THAT.
>> THE INNING IS OVER.
I CAN'T ELABORATE ON THAT.
I'M HERE FOR THE COUNTDOWN.
SCOTT: IN 5, 4.
THERE ARE TWO MINUTES.
YOU'VE GOT TIME.
>> THERE WAS A 5, 4 IN YOUR EAR,
TOO.
YOU NEED TO TALK TO THE
PRODUCERS.
>> THAT WAS MEAN.
>> THAT WAS SCOTT.
SCOTT: WE ARE GETTING A LITTLE
LOOSE HERE.
IT'S 19-4.
NOW, LET'S START THE COUNTDOWN,
THE REAL ONE.
FLIES OUT TO CENTER AND THE
GIANTS FOR ANOTHER JUST
-- JUST FOR KICKS, WHY NOT?
THEY WIN WITH 19 HEADING INTO
THEIR SERIES WITH THE DODGERS
THIS WEEKEND.
>> WHEN I FIRST GOT TO
CINCINNATI, AND THEN DURING THE
1970'S WHEN I WAS MAYOR, PEOPLE
WOULD GO TO THE GAME STRESSED
OUT.
WE WERE A WHITE-COLLAR TOWN, TO
BE HONEST.
THE BIG RED MACHINE WAS A VERY
CORPORATE, JOE MORGAN, JOHNNY
BENCH, EVERYBODY SAYING THE
RIGHT THING, DOING THE RIGHT
THING, AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
1990.
THE 1990 TEAM WAS REALLY THE
FIRST PEOPLES TEAM.
THEY WERE REGULAR CHARACTERS.
NUTS, BUT REGULAR.
>> OUR FANS LOVED US BECAUSE WE
WENT OUT THERE AND PUT A
BLUE-COLLAR BASEBALL ON THAT
FIELD EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> WORKMAN WIN THE GAME, NO
MATTER WHAT.
YOU'VE GOT A FIGHT TWICE, THREE
TIMES, WIN THE GAME.
>> IT'S OUT OF HERE.
>> THEY HAD THAT ATTITUDE ABOUT
THEM OF WE ARE GOING TO KICK
YOUR BUTT, AND WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT IT?
>> WE WERE THERE TO DO A JOB.
>> WE'VE SEEN TONS OF OFFENSE
FOR THE GIANTS TODAY, BUT LET'S
NOT OVERLOOK JOHNNY CUETO.
>> BRING IT.
HEY, WE ARE GETTING LOOSE TODAY,
DANNY AND JEREMY.
IT IS 19-4, WE ARE IN THE NINTH,
AND JOHNNY CUETO IS DANCING.
>> YOU SET IT FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THE GAME.
IT WASN'T A JAM TODAY, BUT HE
WAS WIGGLING.
THERE WAS OFFSPEED STUFF, SOME
HEAT.
HE WAS AS ADVERTISED TODAY,
EXACTLY WHAT GIANTS FANS WANTED
TO SEE.
>> EFFECTIVE, LOOKING A LITTLE
HEALTHIER FROM HIS LAST OUTING,
AND MAKING BIG PITCHES IN BIG
SITUATIONS.
THAT IS WHAT HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT.
HE SHOWED THAT TODAY WITH THE
THREE-TWO CHANGEUP.
SCOTT: WIGGLING.
DANCING.
I WAS ALWAYS WONDERING WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN JOHNNY'S HEAD, AND
FINALLY, THE PRODUCTION CREW WAS
ABLE TO TAKE US INSIDE HIS MIND.
DISCO BALL, MUSIC.
THAT'S HOW YOU PITCH.
JEREMY: IT MIGHT'VE BEEN WITH
THE HORSES, TOO, THAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
I KNOW HE IS HUGE INTO HORSES.
SCOTT: YES, HE OWNS ABOUT 15 ON
HIS FARM IN THE DR.
MATT WISLER IS THE NEW PITCHER
FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
SLIDER.
A LITTLE TOO MUCH OVER THE PLATE
SO FAR THIS YEAR.
BUT THE POTENTIAL IS THERE.
STARTER EARLY ON IN HIS PRO
DAYS.
SLIDER UP, GOOD SWING AND MISS.
JEREMY: ANOTHER FORMER RED.
SCOTT: THAT'S RIGHT.
BLANDINO DOUBLED IN THE THIRD
AND SCORED.
HE ALSO PITCHED.
STRIKE THREE.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
LIVE GAME COMMENTARY.
DANNY: WHICH SUPER BOWL WAS
THAT?
I'M NOT GOOD AT ROMAN NUMERAL'S.
SCOTT: 23.
DANNY: I BET MY NEIGHBOR WASHING
CARS THAT THE BENGALS WOULD WIN
THAT ONE.
SCOTT: 20-16.
AND SAN FRANCISCO IS ONE RUN
AWAY FROM THAT POINT TOTAL.
HAPPY FLIGHT HOME COMING UP FOR
THE GIANTS, BACK TO THEIR OWN
BALLPARK TO WELCOME AND THE
DODGERS THIS WEEKEND.
YOU CAN'T GIGGLE AND THE MIC
PICKS IT UP AND I'M NOT WITH YOU
IN TEXAS.
I'M SITTING HERE ALL ALONE AND
NOT SAY SOMETHING.
DANNY: OH, DID YOU HEAR THAT?
SCOTT: I PICKED UP A LITTLE.
DANNY: JEREMY DOESN'T HIDE HIS
GIGGLES VERY WELL.
JEREMY: SORRY.
SOMEONE JUST SENT ONE OF THE
GUYS A TWEET THAT SAYS ASK HOW
HE THROWS HIS GOOD -- SCUD.
DANNY: HIS FORMER TEAMMATE SENT
ME THAT.
SCOTT: I HAVE ONE FROM A WOMAN
WHO HAS COVERED THIS TEAM FOR
YEARS WHO IS RUNNING THE GIANTS
ACCOUNT TODAY.
SHE SAID I DON'T KNOW IF THE
BROADCASTERS WILL SAY THIS, BUT
WE DID, BUT PLEASE ASK AFFELDT
ABOUT HIS A B'S -- ABS WITH THE
GIANTS.
HE SCREAMED ONCE.
JEREMY: I DID.
I THINK IT WAS WITH FLAHERTY AND
THE BRAVES.
SIDEARMER, AND I WAS 0-2, AND HE
THREW THIS THING AT ME, AND I
DID, I SCREAMED.
I JUST LOOKED OVER AT MY CANON
THOUGHT WELL, THAT'S NOT EVEN
FAIR.
-- AT MCCANN AND THOUGHT, THAT'S
NOT EVEN FAIR.
LEFTY ON LEFTY SIDEARMER.
HE RAN OFF AND I WAS JUST
SHAKING MY HEAD.
BUT YEAH, I MIGHT HAVE HAD MORE
OF A SQUEAL THAN I YELL.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: YOU GOT A FEW KNOCKS,
3-17 IN YOUR CAREER.
JEREMY: THANK YOU FOR FINDING
THAT OUT.
TWO OF THEM WERE GAME-WINNING
R.B.I.'S.
MY BAD.
HE HAS A LOSS BECAUSE OF ME.
[LAUGHTER]
DANNY: THAT'S AMAZING.
JEREMY: I REMEMBER I GOT AN
INFIELD BASE HIT AGAINST THE
DODGERS, AND I WAS HITTING LIKE
.500 THAT YEAR, AND THE NEXT DAY
THEY THREW THE BATS AT ME.
SCOTT: THAT WILL KEEP THE GAME
GOING.
BASE HIT FOR MAX SCHROCK.
DANNY: GOOD, THAT GIVES US MORE
TIME TO TALK ABOUT YOUR HITTING.
JEREMY: I ACTUALLY WENT IN AND
WAS LIKE GUYS, WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THE BASICS.
I STARTED TEACHING THEM HOW TO
SQUASH THE BUG WITH THE BACK
FOOT AND AUBREY LITERALLY THREW
HIS BAT AT ME.
DANNY: THEY DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR
IT.
JEREMY: THEY DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR
THEY'D HAD LIKE THREE HITS OVER
THE LAST SEVEN GAMES.
SCOTT: DANNY, HOW MANY HITS FOR
YOU?
DO YOU KNOW THE NUMBER?
DON'T LOOK.
DANNY: SINCE YOU ASKED, SINCE
YOU ASKED, EIGHT HITS.
AND GUESS WHAT?
MY FIRST TWO WERE HOMERS.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
JEREMY: WE SHOULD PROBABLY TALK
ABOUT THAT.
DANNY: WE ARE EIGHT AND A HALF
INTO THE GAME AND YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HOMERS?
SCOTT: UNBELIEVABLE.
DANNY: SCOTT DIDN'T WANT ME TO
TALK TOO MUCH ABOUT IT SO HE
WAITED UNTIL THE LAST INNING.
SCOTT: I MADE A PROMISE TO
MYSELF THAT I WOULD ONLY BRING
IT UP IF IT WAS 19-4 IN THE
NINTH.
HERE WE ARE.
ONE MORE TRIVIA QUESTION, DO YOU
KNOW WHICH TWO PITCHERS YOU HIT
THOSE HOMERS OFF OF?
DANNY: MIKE MADDUX TONY
MCKNIGHT.
SCOTT: BINGO.
JEREMY: YOU BASICALLY GOT HIM
FIRED.
DANNY: I HAVE 1-2 OFF GREG, TOO,
SO I OWN THE MADDUX FAMILY.
I ALSO HAVE A STOLEN BASE.
ANYWAY.
SCOTT: SAVAGE.
DANNY: WELL, SEE, YOU HAVE THREE
WORLD SERIES RINGS AND I HAVE
NONE, THERE ARE THINGS I HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT.
SCOTT: HOMERS.
AWESOME.
GAME OVER.
THAT'S IT.
NO MORE BRAGGING ABOUT YOUR
CAREER.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
GIANTS WIN.
THEY SWEEP THE REDS IN A FOUR
GAME SET.
LET'S START THE POSTGAME SHOW.
♪
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
SCOTT: THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE POST GAME SHOW
IS PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
19 RUNS THIS AFTERNOON FOR SAN
FRANCISCO, DOING THEIR THING, A
TEAM THAT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT
A TON IN THE FIRST SIX WEEKS OF
THIS SEASON.
THEY HAVE THE BEST RECORD IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THEY SWEPT THE REDS IN FOUR
GAMES.
ALL OF THE TALK, I WOULD SAY
MOST OF THE TALK, HAS BEEN ABOUT
SURPRISE STARTING PITCHING.
AND THE BATS GO HOLD UP, WE CAN
SWING IT.
19 RUNS OFF 16 HITS.
THAT'S A BIG SMILE FOR GABE
KAPLER.
HE GETS TO REST SOME ARMS THAT
HAVE BEEN USED A LOT LATELY.
ALL LOADED UP FOR A HUGE WEEKEND
SERIES AGAINST THE DODGERS.
ON THE REDS SIDE, THEY FALL TO
19-23 ON THE YEAR.
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH SOME
TOUGH TIMES LATELY.
THEY ARE 10-18.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT STARTED OFF
6-7.
IT HAS NOT BEEN ROSY IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEASON FOR THE
REDS.
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH SOME
SEVERE STRUGGLES TO START OFF
WELL.
A 1-8 START.
A BETTER START THIS YEAR, BUT
NOW THEY HAVE HIT TOUGHER TIMES.
SO, LET'S START WITH THE RIGHT
SIDE.
SCOTT BRAUN, JEREMY AFFELDT,
DANNY GRACE, GIANTS WIN.
GIANTS HAVE THE BEST RECORD IN
BASEBALL.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A COMPLETE TEAM
RIGHT NOW.
DANNY: GO AHEAD, JEREMY.
JEREMY: I THINK IT DOES.
WHAT THEY WENT OUT AND DID THIS
ENTIRE SERIES HAS BEEN PRETTY
GOOD.
THEY WERE SHUT OUT LAST NIGHT.
THEY CAME IN OUT OF THE GATE
MAKING GREAT AT-BATS, WORKING
THE COUNT, NOT GIVING AWAY AT
BATS, HITTING HOMERS, HITTING
SINGLES.
AND THEN CUETO COMING OUT AND
DOING HIS JOB OF KEEPING THESE
GUYS BACK AT THE PLATE AS QUICK
AS POSSIBLE.
EVEN THE LONG INNING WITH NINE
RUNS, CUETO WENT TO FIRING
STRIKES RIGHT AWAY.
IT WAS A GOOD OUTING FOR CUETO,
GOOD INNING FOR THE BULLPEN --
GOOD GAME FOR THE BULLPEN.
THEY HAVE THE DODGERS THIS
WEEKEND AND THEY PUT ON A PRETTY
GOOD SHOW TODAY.
DANNY: TO SCORE 19 RUNS WITHOUT
BUSTER POSEY IS A HUGE BONUS.
THEY DID EVERYTHING RIGHT FROM
THE GET GO.
GABE KAPLER PUSHED ALL THE RIGHT
BUTTONS, HAD ALL THE RIGHT GUYS.
INSERTING DARIN RUF INTO THE
LINEUP WHEN HE KNOWS DARIN RUF
HAS A BILLION STRIKEOUTS AGAINST
RIGHTIES.
BUT HE GOES OUT AND HAS A CAREER
DAY TODAY.
SO MANY GUYS, JUST A HUGE
OFFENSIVE OUTPUT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE STARTING
PITCHING AND HOW GREAT THEY ARE,
BUT THE OFFENSE SHOWS THEY HAVE
SOME HUGE NUMBERS, TOO.
SCOTT: WE THREW UP THE POLL
QUESTION, WHO IS THE PLAYER OF
THE GAME?
AND THE ANSWER IS BACK I.
BRANDON CRAWFORD, SIX RUNS
BATTED IN -- THAT GUY.
BATTED IN FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
GOLD GLOVE AWARDS, AND ONE OF
THOSE TROPHIES THAT IS ON YOUR
SCREEN.
HE IS ABOUT TO JOIN US.
YOU CAN SEE THE DAY FOR BRANDON,
A SINGLE, A HOMER, ANOTHER
SINGLE LATER ON, DRIVES IN SIX
OUT OF THE 19 RUNS, AND HE IS
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
WITH THE TROPHY.
HOW DOES IT FEEL, BRANDON.
BIG DAY.
WE LIKE TO SEPARATE ALL THE
REGULAR SEASON GAMES BECAUSE YOU
ARE GOING TO REMEMBER 19 RUNS,
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE A TROPHY TO
SHOW FOR YOUR SIX R.B.I.'S.
HOW DID IT FEEL TODAY?
BRANDON:.
THIS IS GOING ON THE TOP SHELF
FOR SURE OVER ALL THE OTHER
TROPHIES.
I FELT GOOD OUT THERE.
MY SWINGS WERE FEELING GOOD.
TRY TO KEEP IT SIMPLE.
BUT SOME BARRELS ON THE BALL.
-- PUT SOME BARRELS ON THE BALL.
JEREMY: HEY BRANDON, IT'S JEREMY
AFFELDT.
I PLAYED WITH YOU FOR A FEW
YEARS IN SAN FRANCISCO GO.
BRANDON: JEREMY?
JEREMY?
JEREMY: I BASICALLY GOT YOU
FAMOUS.
BRANDON: THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE FOR THIS GIG, HUH?
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: IT'S SO AWESOME WATCHING
YOU GUYS PLAY THIS YEAR.
YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE YOU'RE HAVING
A LOT OF FUN.
IT HAS BEEN A FEW YEARS AND SIU
HAVE ENJOYED WATCHING YOU -- A
FEW YEARS SINCE WE HAVE ENJOYED
WATCHING YOU GUYS HAVE FUN.
WHAT IS IT LIKE RIGHT NOW AT
THIS POINT IN THE SEASON?
BRANDON: IT'S GREAT.
WE ARE PITCHING AND PLAYING
DEFENSE WHICH WE DID A LOT IN
THE YEARS WHEN WE WERE HAVING A
LOT OF FUN.
AND WE ARE SCORING RUNS.
19.
I MEAN, WE CAN SWING THE BATS.
IT HAS BEEN FUN.
I THINK WE COME IN EVERY DAY
WITH A PRETTY GOOD FEELING THAT
WE ARE GOING TO WIN THE GAME.
DANNY: HEY BRANDON, THIS IS
DANNY GRAVES, AND UNFORTUNATELY,
I DID NOT PLAY WITH YOU BACK IN
THE DAY, AND UNFORTUNATELY, I AM
SITTING HERE WITH JEREMY BRIDGES
STUCK HERE.
-- WITH JEREMY.
JUST STUCK HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE A QUESTION THAT IS NOT
ABOUT BASEBALL.
I HAVE HAD A MAN CRUSH ON YOUR
HAIR FOR SO LONG.
WHAT DO YOU PUT IN IT?
I AM TRYING TO GROW MINE OUT.
BRANDON: THAT IS A SURPRISINGLY
COMMON QUESTION THAT I GET.
A LITTLE BIT OF WATER TO DAMPEN
IT, AND THEN SOME JOHNNY BEES
GEL.
SCOTT: GOOD PLUG FOR JOHNNY
BEES.
I'M GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN BECAUSE
WE MENTIONED THIS DURING THE
BROADCAST.
YOUR TEAMMATE LOGAN WEBB SAID I
THINK EVERY SHORTSTOP I FACED IN
HIGH SCHOOL HAD LONG HAIR
BECAUSE OF BRANDON CRAWFORD.
HOW MANY YOUNGSTERS HAVE YOU
COME ACROSS DURING YOUR TIME IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT SAY BRANDON,
LOOK, I GREW THIS OUT BECAUSE OF
YOU.
BRANDON: UNFORTUNATELY, SOME OF
THEM ARE NOT YOUNGSTERS ANYMORE.
JONATHAN IN THE DUGOUT TOLD ME
HE DID THAT.
IT MADE ME FEEL OLD.
IT IS NICE TO HEAR THAT WITH
FANS WHO ARE NOW PLAYING IN THE
MAJOR LEAGUES.
JEREMY: LAST QUESTION FOR ME, I
AM ACTUALLY JUST TRYING TO DELAY
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE, HOW ARE YOU
FEELING GOING INTO -- OBVIOUSLY,
COMING OUT THIS SERIES, BUT
FIRST TIME FACING THE DODGERS.
YOU ARE PLAYING REALLY WELL.
YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE A
PLAYOFF ATMOSPHERE.
YOU HAVE YOUR BIG GUYS GOING FOR
YOU.
IS THERE SOME EXCITEMENT WITH
YOU GUYS EVEN NOW?
IT'S A BIG TEST.
SEVEN OF THE NEXT NINE GAMES YOU
ARE PLAYING THE DODGERS.
WOULD YOU SAY THIS IS PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST WEEK OF YOUR HALF?
BRANDON: I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
IS THINKING ABOUT THAT YET.
WE WILL WORRY ABOUT TOMORROW
TOMORROW.
LIKE I SAID EARLIER, WE COME IN
EVERY DAY WITH A PRETTY GOOD
ATTITUDE THINKING WE CAN BEAT
WHOEVER IS IN THE OTHER DUGOUT.
IF IT'S THE REDS TODAY OR THE
DODGERS TOMORROW, WE FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT OUR CHANCES.
SCOTT: IS BUSTER POSEY JEALOUS
OF THE TROPHY?
HE HAS EVERYTHING ELSE ON HIS
RESUME, BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
YET.
BRANDON: PROBABLY.
THIS IS THE ONE THING HE DOESN'T
HAVE.
SCOTT: EXACTLY.
THANKS FOR THE TIME, MAN.
GREAT TALKING TO YOU.
HAPPY FLIGHT BACK HOME AND GOOD
LUCK THIS WEEKEND AGAINST L.A.
BRANDON: THANKS, GUYS.
SCOTT: BRANDON CRAWFORD, SIX
R.B.I.'S, AND HE WINS PLAYER OF
THE GAME ACCORDING TO THE FANS.
JEREMY, I THINK HE ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU IN
PARTICULAR.
OR MAYBE NOT.
JEREMY: PROBABLY NOT.
SCOTT: HE WAS LIK
AWESOME.
HEY, LET'S CONTINUE OUR POSTGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY JIM BEING --
JIM BEAM IN A MOMENT AS WE
CONTINUE TO WRAP UP THE GIANTS
AND THE REDS.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> THERE GO THE RUNNERS.
BELT SWINGS, AND THERE IS A LONG
ONE.
DEEP RIGHT CENTER FIELD AND INTO
THE SECOND DECK.
GRAND SLAM, 9-0 GIANTS.
HIGH DRIVE, DEEP RIGHT FIELD,
WAY BACK GOES BLACKMON.
AND BUSTER POSEY GOES TO THE
OPPOSITE FIELD, AND IT IS 10-0
GIANTS.
>> BUSTER ON THE FIRST PITCH,
HIGH DRIVE, THE SECOND PITCH
POSEY HAS SEEN OFF WHEELER, AND
HE HITS HIS THIRD HOME RUN OF
THE YEAR.
BUSTER HITS A HIGH DRIVE TO LEFT
.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
OUT OF HERE.
♪
SCOTT: BACK IN CINCINNATI, THE
GIANTS SWEEP THE REDS IN AUTO
GAMES.
A MIDWEEK SERIES AND A TON OF
MOMENT -- IN FOUR GAMES.
MOMENTUM.
HERE'S HOW IT HAPPENED.
AT ONE POINT, DARIN RUF WAS
MOSTLY PLAYING AGAINST
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
GABE KAPLER SAID EVEN THOUGH HE
IS UTTER AGAINST SOUTHPAWS, HE
CAN BE -- BETTER AGAINST
SOUTHPAWS, HE CAN BE GREAT
AGAINST EVERYONE.
EIGHTH PITCH OF THE AT-BAT, FIND
SOME OPEN SPACE, DARIN RUF IS IN
BUSINESS, AND HE IS IN WITH A
ONE OUT DOUBLE.
JEREMY: THAT WAS AS BIG OF A
BIG-LEAGUE AT BAT AS YOU CAN
HAVE IN A BASEBALL GAME.
SCOTT: EVAN LONGORIA HITTING THE
BALL AS HARD AS HE EVER HAS IN
HIS CAREER.
PAY OFF PITCH PAST THE INFIELD,
BASE HIT.
RUF BEING WAVED AROUND.
A KNOCK BY LONGORIA TO BREAK THE
ICE FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
1-0, TWO ON.
BRANDON CRAWFORD DROPS ONE INTO
RIGHT AND YASTRZEMSKI IS BEING
WAVED AROUND, AND HE WILL COME
IN TO MAKE IT 2-0 SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S IN R.B.I.
FOR BRANDON CRAWFORD TO DRIVE IN
THE SECOND RUN OF THE DAY, NO
OUTS.
TO THE RIGHT SIDE, OPEN SPACE,
THAT WILL SCORE ANOTHER RUN FOR
THE GIANTS.
STATION TO STATION, 4-0.
THEY ARE ALL OVER TYLER.
DAVID BELL TAKES THE BASEBALL.
MICHAEL FELIZ IS SUMMONED FROM
THE BULLPEN IN A 4-0 GAME.
IN THE ZONE, 95 DOWN, NAQUIN
GIVES IT A LOOK, AND IT IS GONE!
STEVEN DUGGAR LOADS UP AND IT IS
A GRAND SLAM FOR THE GIANTS TO
MAKE IT EIGHT-ZERO SAN
FRANCISCO.
WHAT A BLAST OFF THE BAT OF
DUGGAR, HIS BIG AND OF THE
SEASON, AND HE WAS ALL OVER THAT
FASTBALL.
HE'S BORED -- THEY'VE SCORED
SEVEN IN THE THIRD INNING.
DARIN RUF.
DANNY: IT'S GOING INTO THE
SEATS, ABOUT THE THIRD ROW.
SCOTT: SECOND HOME RUN OF THE
INNING FOR THE GIANTS AS THEY
POWER UP.
DARIN RUF WITH A TWO RUN SHOT TO
MAKE IT 10-0.
STANDUP DOUBLE AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE THIRD FOR THE REDS.
AND THE REDS BREAK THE ICE,
THEIR FIRST RUN COMES IN.
BLANDINO SCORING ON THE R.B.I.
SINGLE.
JEREMY: THIS IS A SITUATION FOR
JOHNNY WHERE I HAVE TO BEAR DOWN
RIGHT HERE.
I HAVE TWO OUTS AND A RUN ACROSS
ALREADY.
10-1, NO BIG DEAL, BIG AT-BATS.
SCOTT: TYLER NAQUIN, GOT HIM.
DANNY: GREAT PITCH.
SCOTT: BIG-TIME CHANGEUP FROM
JOHNNY CUETO.
THAT IS HIS BEST HIT -- HIS BEST
PITCH, AND HE USES IT.
FLY BALL SKIPS AWAY, THERE IS A
RUN FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
DUGGAR COMES IN.
IT'S 11-1 GIANTS IN THE FIFTH.
CRAWFORD SENDS ONE DEEP RIGHT
FIELD.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
BRANDON CRAWFORD MUSCLES UP FOR
A THREE RUN SHOT.
AND THE GIANTS ARE ONE AWAY FROM
MATCHING THE MOST RUNS BY A
BASEBALL TEAM IN A SEASON.
EVAN LONGORIA HAS LEFT THE YARD.
IT IS A TWO RUN HOMER AND THE
GIANTS HAVE SCORED MORE RUNS IN
A GAME THAN ANY TEAM THIS
SEASON.
AND 18 SPOT.
BUT WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
WE HAVE POSITION PLAYERS.
WE HAVE RUN SCORING.
WE SAW NOT ONE, BUT TWO POSITION
PLAYERS IN THIS GAME FOR THE
REDS.
DARIN RUF, SIX HOME RUNS OF THE
YEAR.
CRAWFORD WAS THE YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME, SIX RUNS BATTED IN.
JOHNNY CUETO, A RUN AND FOUR
STRIKEOUTS.
STATCAST BROUGHT TO YOU BY
GOOGLE CLOUD SHOWS 16 HITS PUT
TOGETHER BY THE GIANTS THIS
AFTERNOON, JEREMY, THIS TEAM HAS
POP WHICH WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH
OF FROM THE GIANTS OVER THE PAST
FIVE OR SIX YEARS.
LAST YEAR WE SAW IN FLASHES.
THIS YEAR, HERE IT IS.
THIS TEAM KNOWS HOW TO POWER UP.
>> YOU ARE DEFINITELY SEEING IT
WITH CONSISTENCY.
YOU HAVE AN OFFENSE THAT'S GOING
TO PRODUCE FOR YOU, NOT JUST --
WE SAW SOME GREAT AT-BAT'S,
WORKING COUNTS, HITTING SINGLES
AND DOUBLES, BUT THEN YOU HAVE
THOSE GUYS WHO CAN COME IN AND
TURN THOSE SINGLES AND DOUBLES
INTO THREE RUN HOMER'S.
THAT'S THE SIGN OF A VERY
DANGEROUS TEAM.
IN THE PAST, IF YOU HAD A SINGLE
OR DOUBLE, SOMETIMES HE WOULD
SEE THE GIANTS WITH 11 HITS, NO
HOMERS, TWO RUNS.
NOW YOU ARE SEEING A SITUATION
WHERE A COUPLE GUYS GET ON AND
ANYBODY IT SEEMS LIKE IS HITTING
A HOMER.
CRAWFORD IS HITTING HOMERS LIKE,
HE'S HAD EIGHT ALREADY THIS
MONTH.
BILL DIDN'T PLAY TODAY, HE HAS
EIGHT OR NINE HOMERS.
-- BELT DIDN'T PLAY TODAY AND HE
HAS EIGHT OR NINE HOMERS.
THESE GUYS CAN ALL HIT HOME
RUNS.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
THAT'S A DANGEROUS TEAM RIGHT
NOW GOING INTO THESE NEXT FEW
GAMES WITH THE DODGERS.
IF I'M THE DODGERS, I NEED TO
PREPARE THAT THIS IS NOT THE
SAME GIANTS TEAM WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS OFFENSE OF
TEAM AND DANGEROUS DEFENSIVELY.
IT'S PRETTY AWESOME TO WATCH
THESE GUYS.
SCOTT: DANNY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU COULD GO EITHER WAY HERE FOR
SAN FRANCISCO.
BUT FOR CINCINNATI, HEADING INTO
THE YEAR YOU GO OK, TEAMS THAT
DIDN'T DO A TON DAY SHE -- A TON
-- ST. LOUIS DID.
BUT LET'S KICK IT OVER TO THE
RED SOX -- TO THE REDS FOR A
MOMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS TEAM?
DANNY: IT'S DEFINITELY A ROUGH
PATCH IN THESE LAST FOUR GAMES.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE TO
GIVE CREDIT TO THE OTHER TEAM.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE BROADCAST.
SAN FRANCISCO'S STARTING
ROTATION IS THE BEST IN BASEBALL
NUMBERS-WISE.
WHEN YOU PLAY A FOUR GAME
SERIES, YOU ARE NOT GETTING ANY
KIND OF BREAK.
IN A THREE-GAME SERIES, YOU HAVE
A LOSING STREAK POSSIBLY AND
THEN YOU MOVE ON.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE FOUR DOMINANT
STARTERS FACING YOU, IT'S TOUGH
IS AN OFFENSE.
THERE IS AN INJURY AND
CINCINNATI WITH JOEY VOTTO OUT.
BUT THERE IS STILL SO MUCH
BASEBALL LEFT.
I KNOW IT IS A CLICHÉ, BUT IT'S
ONLY MAY.
THERE IS A LOT OF TIME LEFT IN
THIS DIVISION.
I THINK THE CARDINALS ARE
PLAYING BETTER THAN EVERYBODY
ELSE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT TOTALLY
SEPARATING THEMSELVES.
THERE IS STILL AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BETTER.
FOR THEM TO CONTINUE TO STRIVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I STILL SEE POTENTIAL IN THIS
TEAM AND I KNOW IN THE CLUBHOUSE
THEY ARE NOT GIVING UP.
THEY HAVE JESSE WINKER AND NICK
CASTELLANOS, TWO GUYS LEADING
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE IN BATTING
AVERAGE.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO PUT
UP SOME RUNS.
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING UP RUNS AND
PITCHING ON THE SAME DAY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE SERIES YOU
JUST HAVE TO TURN TO THE NEXT
DAY AND GET READY TO GO PLAY THE
NEXT OPPONENT.
SCOTT: WIPE IT OUT.
THE REDS ARE 5.5 BACK FROM THE
FIRST-PLACE CARDINALS.
AND THE CUBS ARE IN SECOND PLACE
AT THE MOMENT, A HALF-GAME
BETTER THAN THE BREWERS, THREE
POINT FIVE BACK FROM ST. LOUIS.
LET'S HEAD OUT TO MR. MIDWEST,
J.P. MOROSI.
HE'S AT A DIFFERENT MIDWEST
BALLPARK JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY.
HOW WAS YOUR STOP ON THE TOUR
TODAY IN CINCINNATI?
J.P.: GORGEOUS SKIES IN
CINCINNATI.
NOT A GREAT RESULT FOR THE HOME
TEAM, BUT I DIDN'T APPRECIATE IN
THE NINTH INNING TO SEE THE RARE
PITCHING CHANGE WHERE THE FIRST
BASEMAN AND PITCHER JUST SWITCH
LACES.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT IN A WHILE.
MAX SCHROCK AND ALEX BLANDINO
BOTH DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
A NOTE WAS PASSED TO US VIA THE
SPORTS BUREAU.
THE FIRST TIME THE REDS HAD
MULTIPLE POSITION PLAYERS PITCH
IN THE SAME GAME SINCE 1904,
THAT FAR BACK.
INCREDIBLE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
HOW FAR BACK IT WAS, BABE RUTH,
SHOHEI OHTANI, YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK EVEN FURTHER FOR THAT COMBO
OF POSITION PLAYERS.
BUT A MORE SOMBER TONE FOR THE
HOME TEAM.
THE REDS ARE NOW 5.5 GAMES BACK
FROM THE CARDINALS HERE IN THE
N.L. CENTRAL.
THAT IS THEIR LARGEST DIVISIONAL
DEFICIT OF THE SEASON.
IT STARTS TO GET TO THE LARGER
QUESTION THAT DANNY RAISED.
WHEN YOU HAVE CASTELLANOS
PLAYING AS WELL AS HE IS
PLAYING, AND WINKER, DOES LUIS
CASTILLO RETURN TO FORM?
SONNY GRAY AS WELL.
THERE IS QUALITY ON THIS TEAM
BUT TIME IS GETTING SHORT.
IT COULD BE AN EARLIER START TO
THE TRADING SEASON.
I THINK IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS, IT WILL BE INTERPRETIVE
FOR THE REDS AND THEIR TRADE
DEADLINE.
NOW WITH THE GIANTS AND THE
DODGERS, WE ARE ALMOST TO
MEMORIAL DAY.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR TOMORROW NIGHT
.
WE HEARD FROM BRANDON CRAWFORD
EARLIER.
HE WILL SEE A FELLOW UCLA BRUIN,
TREVOR BAUER ON THE MOUND FOR
THE DODGERS.
ALEX WOOD GETS THE START FOR THE
GIANTS.
FORMER DODGER WHO JUST WON A
WORLD SERIES RING WITH THE
DODGERS.
NOW HE IS ON THE MOUND FACING
HIS FORMER TEAM.
I SEEM TO RECALL A BIG MOVE THE
DODGERS MADE RECENTLY TO BRING
IN A RIGHTY BAT YOU HAVE HEARD
OF BEFORE, ALBERT PUJOLS.
THIS COULD BE HIS FIRST TASTE OF
THE GIANTS-DODGERS RIVALRY.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
DODGERS GIANTS RIVALRY THIS
WEEKEND.
CANNOT WAIT TO SEE WHAT THE NEXT
CHAPTER WILL BRING.
DAVID PRICE WILL GET A START IN
THIS EVENING'S GAME.
MUCH MOSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM STRAIGHT
AHEAD WITH OUR MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
>> OH MY.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
IT'S OUT OF HERE.
>> JOEY VOTTO HAS DOUBLED TO
LEFT.
AND THAT ONE IS SHOT OUT OF A
CANNON TO RIGHT FIELD.
A TOWERING HOME RUN, NUMBER 300,
AND THE REDS TAKE A 3-2 LEAD.
A NO AS JOSEPH DANIEL VOTTO
BECOMES THE THIRD MAN IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY WITH 300 BIG
ONES.
>> LOOKS TO MAKE REDS AND
BASEBALL HISTORY.
IN THE AIR TO RIGHT.
0-2.
STRIKE THREE, AND HE IS ONE OUT
AWAY.
GROUND BALL.
WIZARDRY FROM WADE MILEY, A
NO-HITTER AND BASEBALL HISTORY.
SCOTT: THAT'S A COOL STATUE.
THE POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
JIM BEAM.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
WHAT THE GIANTS ARE DOING THIS
SEASON IS SO IMPRESSIVE, EXCITED
TO SEE THE SERIES AGAINST MY
HOME TEAM DODGERS.
AS J.P. MOROSI MENTIONED,
JEREMY, TREVOR BAUER IS GOING TO
START.
DAVID PRICE IS GOING TO BEGIN
TODAY'S GAME FOR L.A., BULLPEN
GAME.
HE IS NOT STRETCHED OUT.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THE
DODGERS WERE GEARING UP FOR A
WEEKEND SERIES THAT MATTERS MORE
?
IT'S A DIVISIONAL OPPONENT THEY
COULD BE FIGHTING AGAIN FOR THE
ENTIRE SEASON.
ALL THE TALK IN THE OFF-SEASON
WAS PADRES DODGERS.
AND I WAS ONE OF THEM.
I SAID -- THERE WAS A LOT OF
FLAK FROM FANS GOING HEY, IT'S
DODGERS GIANTS.
I SAID OK, BUT RIGHT NOW, THE
CURRENT FLAVOR RIVALRY IS
PADRES-DODGERS.
THEY SAID NO, NO, NO, IT'S
DODGERS-GIANTS.
NOW ALL THREE ARE INVOLVED IN
THE DIVISION.
JEREMY: AND THE WAY THE DODGERS
AND THE GIANTS PLAYED LAST YEAR,
THE ARGUMENTS EARLY ON THIS
SEASON, IT WAS THAT.
THERE WAS FRICTION BETWEEN THOSE
TWO TEAMS.
BUT IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN BETWEEN
THE GIANTS AND DODGERS.
BUT NOW IT IS HEIGHTENED.
NOW YOU HAVE THE DODGERS AND
GIANTS WITH PRETTY CLOSE
RECORDS.
THE GIANTS HAVE A BETTER ONE.
BUT THESE SEVEN GAMES, IF IT
GOES REALLY BADLY FOR EITHER
TEAM, IT'S GOING TO FLIP-FLOP
THE DIVISION OR IT'S GOING TO
REALLY SEPARATE THE GIANTS FROM
THE DODGERS OR IT'S JUST GOING
TO END UP BEING WHAT IT IS, I
THINK ALL BASEBALL FANS SHOULD
BE EXCITED.
ALL OF THE BASEBALL GUYS WHO
LOVE THE PURITY OF THE GAME
PROBABLY WANT IT TO BE A CLOSE
MATCH ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
IT WILL BE A FUN SEASON.
IT'S A BIG DEAL THIS WEEKEND.
IT'S A BIGGER DEAL THAN THE
DODGERS THOUGHT IT WAS WHEN THE
SCHEDULE CAME OUT.
LIKE BRANDON SAID EARLIER, THEY
ARE TAKING IT GAME BY GAME.
THEY HAVE TO GO GAME BY GAME.
BUT FOR ALL OF US WATCHING, IT'S
GOING TO BE A REALLY FUN WEEK
FOR DODGERS FANS, FOR GIANTS
FANS.
THERE'S A REASON WHY THE DODGERS
HAVE TO RAMP IT UP.
I THINK IT'S NOTHING BUT GOOD
FOR THE GAME RIGHT NOW TO SEE
THAT THIS WHOLE NATIONAL LEAGUE
WEST, CUTTHROAT GAME HAPPENING
BETWEEN TWO TEAMS IS HAPPENING
AGAIN.
SCOTT: THE GIANTS HAVEN'T EVEN
EXPERIENCED A THREE-GAME LOSING
SKID YET THIS SEASON.
THE ONLY OTHER TEAM TO NOT GO
THROUGH THAT IS THE WHITE SOX.
THIS QUESTION CAME IN.
LET'S SPIN IT FORWARD TO AFFELDT
AS A BROADCASTER TODAY.
U2 HANGING OUT IN THE STUDIO ALL
DAY LONG.
YOU GUYS ACTUALLY LIVE PRETTY
CLOSE BY EACH OTHER.
HOW WAS J.A. NEXT TO YOU?
DANNY: WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
INVITE TO BERMUDA.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT YOU SHOULD
FOCUS ON.
DANNY: PLEASE.
HERE IS THE THING, ME AND JEREMY
GO WAY BACK.
WE HAVEN'T REALLY HUNG OUT MUCH
SINCE WE PITCHED TOGETHER.
BUT THAT IS WHY YOU HEARD US
CHUCKLING ALL DAY.
SCOTT: --
JEREMY: TALK ABOUT FACIAL HAIR.
DANNY: WHO WAS THE PITCHER
AGAIN?
JEREMY: FLIRTY, SCARY STUFF.
I WAS HITTING .500.
MY LAST AT-BAT OF MY CAREER WAS
AGAINST THE BRAVES IN ATLANTA
AND I THREW THE BAT ABOUT 18
ROSE UP SWINGING AND MISSING.
THAT IS PHENOMENAL.
THAT IS ONE OF THOSE FACIAL
HAIRS THAT YOU THOUGHT WAS COOL
AT THE TIME BUT AS THE YEARS
HAVE GONE ON, YOU ARE LIKE, I
CANNOT UN-SEE THAT RIGHT NOW.
DANNY: THAT WAS INTIMIDATING.
AS AN OPPONENT TO YOU, YOU HAD
THAT FACIAL HAIR AND WE WERE
SCARED OF YOU.
WE DIDN'T KNOW YOU, AND WE WERE
LIKE THIS GUY IS THE MEANEST
DUDE ON THE PLANET.
SCOTT: THIS GUY MIGHT BE A
LITTLE CRAZY.
I DON'T NOW.
HE'S WILD-CARD.
I WISH YOU WERE MIKED UP FOR
THAT AT-BAT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, NOWADAYS WE
MIKE UP SOME OF OUR PLAYERS,
SOME OF THE BEST IN THE BIZ.
JESSE WINKER WITH THE
MICROPHONE, JUST YOUTUBE TAGGING
ALONG WITH THEM ALL DAY LONG,
AND IT SOUNDED LIKE THIS.
>> HOW ARE YOU ALL DOING?
THANK YOU, MAN.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> NAQUIN, NAQUIN, NAQUIN.
PUTS IT IN FOR THREE!
>> LET'S GO, YOUTUBER.
>> FOR THE KIDS, MAN.
FOR THE KIDS.
SWEEEEEEEEEEEET MOTION.
OH, I GOT THAT.
I GOT IT, I GOT IT, I GOT IT!
WHOO!
>> ARE YOU MIKED UP, TOO?
HOW THE HELL DID YOU HIT,
HONESTLY?
DIDN'T YOU HOMER LIKE TWO DAYS
AGO?
SEE, YOU'VE GOT POP.
I RUN INTO BALLS.
JEREMY: I HAVE THIS CARD IN MY
POCKET AND PEOPLE KEEP THINKING
IT'S A CELL PHONE.
I JUST WANT TO GET IT ON AIR
THAT THIS IS NOT MY CELL PHONE.
I ALWAYS GET HECKLED.
PUT YOURSELF CELL PHONE AWAY!
>> I NEVER HEARD YOU CALL THE
BALL.
>> YEAH?
>> THAT'S THE HARDEST I HAVE
SEEN YOU RUN IN A WHILE.
>> OH YEAH!
GOT IT, BABY.
DANNY: ARE YOU MIKED UP?
DID YOU HIT A HOMER THE OTHER
DAY?
JEREMY: THE SINGING.
DANNY: DON'T EVER LET ME SING ON
AIR.
JEREMY: NEVER.
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS HE
WILL LOOK BACK ON AND PROBABLY
THOUGHT IT WAS COOL AT THE TIME,
BUT IT WASN'T.
SCOTT: IT'S LONELY OUT THERE.
TRUST ME, I HAVE BEEN IN THE
STUDIO BY MYSELF.
IT'S LONELY OUT THERE ON YOUR
OWN.
JESSE KNOWS HE IS MIKED UP.
HE'S A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
HE GAVE US A LITTLE
ENTERTAINMENT.
IT WAS GOLD.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE VOICE,
JESSE.
THE ACTUAL WORDS COMING OUT OF
HIS MOUTH ALL DAY, GOLD.
THAT IS THE CONTENT THAT WE
CRAVE.
GUYS, YOU ARE AWESOME.
REALLY ENJOYED IT.
GIANTS 19.
REDS FOUR.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE RETURNS ONE WEEK FROM
NOW ON THURSDAY, MAY 27TH.
WE HAD TO SELL FLORIDA FOR THE
PHILLIES AND THE MARLINS.
COVERAGE -- SOUTH FLORIDA FOR
THE PHILLIES AND THE MARLINS.
WE WILL TALK THEN WITH THE
DYNAMIC DUO OF DANNY GRAVES AND
JEREMY AFFELDT.
MR. MIDWEST J.P. MOROSI AND OUR
ENTIRE CAREER.
I AM SCOTT BRAUN LOGGING OFF.
WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT WEEK ON
MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.